GOOD AFTER WE'RE GOING
TO START OUR BUDGET SUB SIX
HEARING- ON THE- CUVETTE
NINETEEN MITIGATION EFFORTS IN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
SO WELCOME TO READ SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS LIKE ARE WE
ALWAYS DO WHAT IN THE
PHYSICALLY. DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. EVEN THOUGH THIS IS
THE LARGEST HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS AND A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF. THERE WERE
ALSO FOLLOWING VERY STRICT
PHYSICAL SOCIAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS I DON'T SEE ANY
PUBLIC HERE BUT IF THERE WERE
PUBLIC THEY ARE ALLOWED ROOM-
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT PUBLIC COMMENT IS ONE
MINUTE LONG AND- THEY DO HAVE A
CHOICE AFTER THE MAKEUP PUBLIC
COMMENT TO LEAVE THE ROOM OR-
THEY COULD. STAY OF COURSE AND
CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO THE-
REMAINDER OF THE HEARING. THE
PANELISTS ON THE AND THE L. A.
O. AE APPEARING EITHER IN THE
CAPITAL OR THEIR RESPECTIVE
OFFICERS THERE ARE PUBLIC
STATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT THE AGENDA
CONTAINS THE LOCATIONS OF THESE
STATIONS INCLUDINGONE. IN
CAPITAL PARKER FROM. THE
BECAUSE OF MIND HOLD WHETHER.
ALBUMS WITH THE WITH GETTING
INTO PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE CALL
THE OFFICE AT. 916-319-2099 AND
A STAFF MEMBER CAN ASSIST YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO EMAIL US
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR EMAILS
PLEASE EMAIL US AS BUDGET SUB
S. U. B. THE NUMBER SIX- ASM
DOT C. A. DOT GOV. THE REASON
WE'RE HAVING THE HEARING IS-
TWO OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF 
THAT HAVE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF COVERT CASE AND ALSO
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
DEATHS HAVE REALLY BEEN AROUND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AS
WELL AS OUR PRISON SYSTEM
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE- DISCUSSED.
AT LENGTH THE SOME OF THE
REASONS IN PARTICULAR. FOR WHAT
CAUSED THE SPIKE IN COVERT
CASES IN OUR CORRECTIONS SYSTEM
OKAY WELL WE'RE HERE TODAY IS
NOT TO SO MUCH DWELL ON THE
PAST BUT TO REALLY LOOK AT THE
FUTURE. AND FIGURE OUT WAYS
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE. THE PROTOCOLS- THAT
ARE BEING DEVELOPED OR HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED- WITH THE BEING
FOLLOWED HOW STRINGENTLY
THEY'RE BEING FOLLOWED. IT ALSO
ON WHAT WE CAN DO TO AGAIN-
PROTECT ALL OF CALIFORNIANS. I
KNOW WHAT ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE- ONE FACILITY ALONE
CREATED A MAJOR OUTBREAK IN
HIS. COUNTY WHICH IS I KNOW WHY
HE'S- HAD SUCH AN INTEREST ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE SO THE
STAKES CAN BE. A RATHER HIGH
AND THEN- MANY OF THE AFFECTED
INMATES WERE SENT INTO MY
COUNTY- FOR CARE SO. AGAIN WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
SITUATIONS WHICH COULD BE
AVOIDED- ARE AVOIDED WE REALLY
DO APPRECIATE ALL THE- ALL THE
FOLKS WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY.
ON BEHALF THE DEPARTMENT BUT
ALSO THE RECEIVERS HERE AND
ALSO VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND HIS
TEAM'S REPORT. SO WITH THAT LET
ME SEE IF THEY'RE ANY. OPENING
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS. MR
WALTER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOUFOR
CA THIS HEARING ON A VERY TOPIC
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A DUAL
PURPOSE HERE NOT ONLY ARE WE
INTERESTED IN HELPING TO
CONTAIN THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS BUT ALSO THE- THE
INMATES OF CDC ARE ARE A GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE A STATE
OBLIGATION OF DUTY AND CARE
TOWARDS AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT WE'VE EXERCISED
OUR RESPONSIBILITY IN THAT
RESPECT SO. I'M GOING TO BE
HERE TODAY AND LOOKING FOR THE
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR FOR WELCOMING ME TO- TO
THIS HEARING AT TO JOIN THE
COMMITTEE- TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION AND SOLICIT.
INFORMATION IN FREE REMARKS
ABOUT MY CONCERN- WHICH PREDATE
ANY OPERATE CAN OUR STATE
PRISON SYSTEM I IN ADVOCATES
HAD. ADVOCATED TWO CDC ARE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PLAN FOR.
COATED AND- IT WAS A FAILURE TO
PLAN. THAT HAS RESULTED IN- IN
THE TRAGEDY THAT THOUSANDS OF
PRISONERS HAVE SUFFERED. AND
MANY HAVE DIED INCLUDING
STAFFS. BUT THAT THE GREAT RISK
WAS NOT JUST CONTAINED WITHIN
THE WALLS OF PRISONS. THE RISK
WAS TO COMMUNITIES THAT THE
PRISONS ARE LOCATED IN. AND THE
HIGHER RATES OF HOSPITALIZATION
FOR THE MEDICALLY VULNERABLE.
INCARCERATED PEOPLE. WHICH WERE
FAR TOO MANY FOR ANY ONE
PRISONS COMMUNITY TO HANDLE AND
HAS MISTER CHAIR. HAD NOTED
SPILLED OVER INTO NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT VERY CLOSELY. WELL
THERE'S GREAT TALK ABOUT
VACCINES WE KNOW THAT HAVING
THOSE VACCINES TO PROTECT
EVERYONE IN OUR COUNTRY. IS
THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE MONTHS
AND MONTHS AWAY AND SO WE NEED
TO WORK DILIGENTLY
AGGRESSIVELY- AND VERY MINDFUL
OF THE DETAILS TO PROTECT BOTH.
THOSE THAT WORK AND LIVE WITHIN
OUR PRISONS- AND ALSO TO
PROTECT THE COMMUNITIES IN THE
HOSPITALS THAT SERVE THEM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
OPENING COMMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE WE WILL
START WITH OUR INSPECTOR
GENERAL. IT ALL YEAH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TO TALK ABOUT
THE TOOL IG REPORTS ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION'S RESPONSE. TO
THE NOBLE CORP CORONAVIRUS AS
YOU ARE AWARE IN RESPONSE TO
THE ASSEMBLY SPEAKERS REQUEST
MY OFFICE HAS LOOKED AT TO VERY
SPECIFIC ASPECTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S RESPONSE TO COPE
AT NINETEEN. WE EXAMINE THE
SCREENING PROCESS THE
DEPARTMENT UNDERTOOK TO MAKE
SURE. POTENTIALLY AFFECTED THAT
OUTSIDERS WERE NOT ALLOWED INTO
A PRISON. AND WE LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT USAGE OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT FOCUSING
ON THE WEARING OF MASS. AND WE
ALSO LOOK AT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF SOCIAL DISTANCING AS WELL AS
THE ENFORCEMENT OF ITS
GUIDELINES. BEFORE GETTING TO
THE FINDINGS OF OUR REPORTS I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS
OPERATE CREATED A MONUMENTAL
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND SWEPT
THE ENTIRE WORLD CREATING A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC. CONGREGATE
LIVING SITUATIONS SUCH AS
PRISONS WERE ESPECIALLY HARD
HIT. URBAN AND ITS MEDICAL
EXPERTS REACTED QUICKLY AND
WITH GREATER URGENCY AT THE
OUTSET OF PANDEMIC. AND LIKE
ALL OTHER SECTORS OF GOVERNMENT
HAD A STEEP LEARNING CURVE. WE
APPROACH OUR REVIEW IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE VALUE ADDED
AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE LESSONS
LEARNT. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE RECEIVER THE SECRETARY AND
THEIR STAFF AND SENIOR
LEADERSHIP FOR THEIR
PROFESSIONALISM. AND THEIR
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE MY STAFF
HAD EVERYTHING WE NEEDED TO
PROPERLY DO OUR WORK. I HAVE
PROVIDED THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE OF FACT SHEET WHICH
OUTLINES THE MOST IMPORTANT
FINDINGS OVER TO REPORTS MY
BRIEFING TO YOU WILL FOLLOW THE
FACT SHEET. I FIRST PRESENT
YOUR FINDINGS ON THE SCREENING
PROCESS BEGINNING. IN EARLY
MARCH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. THE
DEPARTMENT TOOK SEVERAL STEPS
TO PROTECT INSTITUTIONS. FROM
STAFF AND OUTSIDE VISITORS WHO
COULD POTENTIALLY REDUCE THE
CORONAVIRUS INTO A PRISON. THE
FIRST THING THE DEPARTMENT DID
WAS TO SUSPEND NORMAL
VISITATION. THIS IS HAVE AN
ENORMOUS IMPACT ON THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION BUT
THERE'S NO ARGUMENT THAT THIS
IS A NECESSARY PRECAUTION TAKE.
THE NEXT STEP THE DEPARTMENT
TOOK WAS TO BEGIN VERBAL
SCREENING OF ALL STAFF AND
VISITORS WHO ENTER PRISONS.
LIKE TWO WEEKS AFTER THE VERBAL
SCREENING BEGAN. THE DEPARTMENT
ADDED TEMPERATURE SCREENING TO
THE ASSESSMENT OF WHETHER A
PERSON WAS PERMITTED TO ENTER
PRISON. WE NOTED SOME
DIFFICULTIES THE DEPARTMENT HAD
IN IMPLEMENTING THESE MEASURES.
FIRST THERE WAS NO STANDARD
THAT THE PRISONS USED FOR THEIR
SCREENING PROCESS SOME%
INSTITUTIONS SCREEN STAFF AND
VISITORS AND THEIR VEHICLES
BEFORE THEY ENTERED THE MAIN
PROJECT AROUND. AND SOME
PRESENCE DID NOT SCREEN STAFF
AND OTHERS UNTIL AFTER THEY
PARK THEIR VEHICLES AND WALKED
TO A SCREENING AREA ON PRISON
FOR. SOME SCREENING AREAS WERE
RATHER PROXIMAL TO THE PARKING
AREA BUT AT SOME INSTITUTIONS.
PEOPLE WERE NOT SCREENED UNTIL
AFTER THEY HAVE A THROUGH AREAS
WHERE THEY POTENTIALLY EXPOSE
STAFF INCARCERATED PEOPLE PRIOR
TO THEIR SCREENING. IN ADDITION
WE FOUND THAT WE'RE SCREENING
WAS NOT DONE PRIOR TO PARKING.
THERE WAS A HIGHER LIKELIHOOD
THAT NO SCREENING WOULD BE
CONDUCTED. IN THE CASE OF MY
OWN STAFF THIRTY EIGHT TIMES
OUT OF TWO HUNDRED TWELVE
VISITS. MY STAFF WAS NOT
SCREENED. THIS EQUATES TO
NEARLY 20% OF OUR VISITS. I
WANT TO ADD THAT MY STAFF WAS
NOT TRYING TO AVOID SCREENING
BUT RATHER IN MANY
INSTITUTIONS. THE SCREENING
LOCATIONS WERE NOT READILY
APPARENT AND AT ONE PRISON WE
RECEIVED CONFLICTING
INSTRUCTIONS AS TO WHO NEEDED
TO BE SCREENED FROM THREE
DIFFERENT PRISON STAFF. IN A
SURVEY WE CONDUCTED. 5% OF CDCR
STAFF WHO RESPONDED. NOTED THAT
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN SCRIPT EVERY
TIME. SECONDLY WE FOUND THAT
LITTLE TO NO TRAINING WAS
PROVIDED TO THE SCREENERS. THE
SCREENERS WERE A MIX OF CUSTODY
AND HEALTH CARE STAFF WHO ARE
ASSIGNED TO THE STUDENTS. IT
APPEARS THAT NON MEDICAL STAFF
WAS NOT VERY WELL TRAINED ON
THE THERMOMETERS THEY WERE
USING. WE LOOK AT TRAINING
RECORDS FOR A SAMPLE OF SEVENTY
FIVE SCREENERS AT FIVE
DIFFERENT PRISONS. AND FOUND
THAT MOST SCREENERS HAVE
RECEIVED NO TRAINING. ON THEIR
PRISON SCREENING PROCESS. FOR
THE VERY FEW WOULD RECEIVE SOME
TRAINING. NONE RECEIVE TRAINING
SPECIFIC TO THE THERMOMETER
THEY WERE GIVEN FOR SCREENING
PURPOSES. FINALLY THE EQUIPMENT
ITSELF WAS NOT ALWAYS RELIABLE.
IN OUR SURVEY APPROXIMATELY TWO
THIRDS OF THE SCREENERS NOTED
THAT THEY HAD ONLY
MALFUNCTIONING PARAMETERS TO
USE. WE ALSO NOTED THAT MANY
STAFF REPORTED TO US THAT THE
THERMOMETERS THEY WERE USING
STOP WORKING BECAUSE THEY RAN
OUT OF BATTERY POWER AND
SCREENERS DID NOT HAVE FRESH
BATTERIES AVAILABLE. AS A
RESULT OF THESE ISSUES WE'VE
MADE A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDING
CHANGING SCREENING LOCATIONS.
MAKING SURE SCREENERS ARE
PROPERLY TRAINED MAKING SURE
THAT THE EQUIPMENT WAS
SERVICEABLE. AND MAKING SURE
SPUR BATTERIES WERE AVAILABLE.
OUR SECOND REPORT FOCUSED ON
THE DEPARTMENT USE OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND MASK
USAGE. IN EARLY MARCH THE
DEPARTMENT MADE SIGNIFICANT
EFFORTS TO LOCATE AND
DISTRIBUTE PP FOR THOSE WHO
NEEDED TO BE A DIRECT CONTACT.
WITH PATIENTS WHO HAVE SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS OF CODE NINETEEN
OR THOSE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WHO'D BEEN EXPOSED TO POSITIVE
CASES OF CODE NINETY. THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE MEDICAL STAFF
THAT SHOULD BE LAUDED FOR THEIR
SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS TO OBTAIN
THE PPP NEEDED. FOR DIRECT
CONTACT WITH COLD NINETEEN
PATIENTS. IN ADDITION TE
DEPARTMENT ALSO PRODUCED AND
DISTRIBUTED APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
CLOTH FACE COVERINGS FOR ISSUE
TO STAFF INCARCERATED PERSONS.
DEPARTMENT PRODUCED ENOUGH FACE
COVERINGS FOR ALL PERSONS TO
HAVE AT LEAST THREE MASKS.
SHORTLY AFTER PROCURING ENOUGH
FACE MAX THE DEPARTMENT ISSUED
DIRECTIVES TO STAFF AND A
PERFORATED PERSONS TO WEAR FACE
COVERINGS AND RECOMMENDED THAT
STAFF AND INCARCERATED PERSONS
STRUCK THE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
ABOUT ONE MONTH LATER THE
DEPARTMENT ISSUED SPECIFIC
PHYSICAL DISTANCING DIRECTIVES
FOR THE INCARCERATED PERSONS.
INEXPLICABLY ONE MONTH AFTER
THAT ON JUNE ELEVENTH THE
DEPARTMENT RELAXED ITS FACE
COVERING REQUIREMENTS FOR STAFF
AND ON JUNE TWENTY FOURTH RELAX
THE FACE COVERING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE INCARCERATED POPULATION.
STAFF AND OF COURSE THREE
PERSONS WERE ALLOWED TO REMOVE
FACE COVERING FALL OUTSIDE AND
MORE THAN SIX FEET FROM OTHER
RELAXING OF REQUIREMENTS DID
NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
DYNAMIC NATURE OF WORK AND LIFE
IN A PRISON. WHERE AN INCIDENT
REQUIRING IMMEDIATE RESPONSE IS
A NORMAL OCCURRENCE. THE
RELAXING OF REQUIREMENTS CAME
DESPITE THE FACT THAT ACTIVE ON
THE RIVER IN AND OUTSIDE OF
PRISONS. AND SURVEYS THAT WE
CONDUCTED 31% OF RESPONDENTS
REPORTED THAT THEY HAD OBSERVED
STAFF FAILING TO PROPERLY WEAR
FACE COVERINGS. AND 38%
REPORTED THAT STAFF ARE CURSORY
PERSONS FAILED TO COMPLY WITH
SOCIAL DISTANCING ACQUIRE. MY
STAFF OBSERVE DEPARTMENTAL
STAFF FAILING TO COMPLY WITH
FACE COVERING DIRECTORS AT
TWENTY THREE OF THE THIRTY FOUR
PERSONS THAT WE VISITED. IT
DOES NOT APPEAR THAT THE
DEPARTMENT VIGILANTLY ENFORCE
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR FACE
COVERAGE OR SOCIAL DISTANCING
DURING THE PERIOD COVERED BY
OUR REPORT. AT FIVE PRISONS WE
CAPTURED THE NUMBER OF
SUPERVISORY ACTIONS OF PUNITIVE
ACTIONS FOR NON COMPLIANCE WITH
POLICY. THOSE FIVE PERSONS
EMPLOYED TEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO STAFF. OUR
OBSERVATION PERIOD TWENTY EIGHT
STAFF WERE SUBJECT TO
SUPERVISORY ACTION AND ONLY ONE
PERSON RECEIVED ADVERSE ACTION
FROM THE DEPARTMENT FOR FAILURE
TO COMPLY WITH FACE COVERED
DIRECTIVES. WE BELIEVE THE
DEPARTMENT COULD HAVE BEEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE IN DISCIPLINING
THOSE WHO REFUSE TO COMPLY WITH
POLICIES THAT ARE FOUNDATIONAL
TO STOPPING THE SPREAD OF THIS
DISEASE. I AM AWARE THAT BOTH
THE RECEIVER AND SEX AND THE
SECRETARY HAVE RECENTLY
EMPHASIZED. WITH WARDENS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE FORCING THESE
POLICIES AND I APPLAUD THEIR
EFFORTS. OUR OFFICE OBSERVE
FIRST HAND THE POSITIVE EFFECT
THAT THIS INCREASED LEADERSHIP
EMPHASIS ATTACK. AT A RECENT
VISIT JUST THIS WEEK TO SIERRA
CONSERVATION CENTER WE OBSERVE
1100% COMPLIANCE WITH MASK
WEARING PULSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND I AM
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU. THANK YOU LET'S GO TO
HELLO MISTER. PUSH MORAL. THANK
YOU BECAUSE TOMORROW THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
ARE ASKED TO STOP BY STOP
DISCUSS REASON OREGON SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON ON OCTOBER
TWENTY AT THE STATE APPELLATE
COURT RULED THAT CITIES YOU'LL
JUST WANT TO COVER NINETEEN
VIOLATE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS OF INMATES HOUSED AT SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF JUNE SAN QUINN HAS
HAD ROUGHLY TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
CASES OF COBIT NINETEEN. WITH
CASES PEAKING IN JULY ON JULY
SEVENTH WITH SIXTEEN HUNDRED
ACTIVE CASES. ABSENCE DECLINE
SUBSTANTIALLY CURRENTLY THERE
ARE ABOUT THREE ACTIVE CASES
ODDS OF ONLY NOVEMBER. CITIES
ARE STATEMENT NUMBER ACTIONS
REGARDING COVER NINETEEN CLEAN
TESTING INMATES AND STUFF AS
WITH MANAGEMENT INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND ALSO HAS CREATED
CORE TEAM SPACE AND ISOLATION
SPACE FOR INMATES RELEASED ITS
SOME INMATES ORDERLY AND
LARGELY SUSPENDED IN TAKE. THE
LAST OF THESE TO HELP REDUCE
YOUTH ARTS POPULATION AT SAN
QUENTIN FOR ABOUT FORTY THREE
HUNDRED INMATES IN JUNE TO
ABOUT TWENTY NINE HUNDRED IN
OCTOBER. HOW WOULD THAT
DORTMUND DID NOT ADOPT. NATIONS
MADE BY PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TO DECREASE AND QUINN'S
POPULATION BY HALF TO DO THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ORDER OUTBREAKS.
THEY HAVE HELD COURT FOUND THAT
BY NOT ADOPTING THIS
RECOMMENDATION. THE DEPARTMENT
VIOLATED THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS OF INMATES HOUSED AT SAN
QUENTIN AND PHYSICALLY VIOLATED
STATE AND FEDERAL CONSTITUTIONS
BANS ON CRUEL AND UNUSUAL
PUNISHMENT. IN ORDER TO REMEDY
THIS THE COURT ORDERED THAT
CDCR REDUCE AKRON'S POPULATION
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE INMATES EITHER
THROUGH TRANSFERRING INMATES TO
OTHER INSTITUTIONS OR BY
RELEASING INMATES. SINCE THAT
ORDER THE SUPREME STATES FROM
COURT IS OPEN A CASE FOR
APPEAL. AND HAS EXTENDED THE
REVIEW PERIOD FOR THE ORDER
UNTIL FEBRUARY SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I SAYS THE
ORDER IS NOT CURRENTLY IN
EFFECT AND WOULD NOT GO INTO
EFFECT UNTIL THAT DATE. NUMBER
SEVENTIES. THANK YOU KNOW HOW
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU LET'S GO TO OUR
RECEIVER MR KELSO. IF YOU JUST
START SPEAKING IT SHOULD SWITCH
TO YOUR SCREEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW YES I CAN HEAR YOU
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS CLARK
KELSO WHEN I SERVED AS THE
FEDERAL RECEIVER. RESPONSIBLE
FOR MEDICAL CARE WITHIN CDCR-
AS MEMBERS KNOW I WAS APPOINTED
TO THIS POSITION- BY THE
FEDERAL COURT IN THE CLASS
ACTION LITIGATION PLOT OF
VERSUS NEWSOME. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT- AND WAS CHARGED WITH
BRINGING THE LEVEL OF MEDICAL
CARE AND CDC ARE UP TO
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS. AS
RECEIVER I EXERCISE ALL THE
POWERS THAT SECRETARY- ALISON
BUSINESSES. BUT ONLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
MEDICAL CARE SYSTEM. WHICH IS
ADMINISTERED. BY CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES C. C. H. C. S. THAT IS
WHY SECRETARY OF BOTH SECRETARY
ALISON AND I ARE HERE TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU JUST AN
OVERVIEW OF WHERE WE CURRENTLY
ARE AT IN OUR EFFORTS TO COMBAT
WILL BE NINETEEN- AND THE
INDICATE SORT OF RECENT
IMPROVEMENTS IN ACTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN. I WHEN I WENT
TO OUR NINTH MONTH OF THE CODE
PANDEMIC. DURING THOSE MONTHS
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED UNPRECEDENTED
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGES TO
RESPOND TO COVERT NINETEEN. AND
THOSE CHANGES HAVE BEEN DRIVEN
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING. BY OUR
MEDICAL LEADERSHIP AND PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. WHO HAVE THEMSELVES
CONSULTED REGULARLY WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL- AND LEADING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
EXPERTS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY. AND
STANFORD. AMONG OTHERS.
RESPONDING TO THE PANDEMIC
REMAINS THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR C. D. C. R. AND C. C. H. C.
S. OUR RESPONSE HAS DEVELOPED
OVER TIME AND CONTINUES TO
DEVELOP AND IMPROVE. AS
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE VIRUS AND
HOW IT SPREADS INCREASES AND
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO FIGHT
THE VIRUS HAVE BECOME AVAILABLE.
IT REMAINS A OR RAPIDLY
EVOLVING SITUATION OR WE SEE
CHANGES STILL ON A DAILY BASIS.
ON THE ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY
OF A VACCINE THAT MAY HAVE 90%
EFFICACY OF BEING JUST THE MOST
RECENT EXAMPLE. I DO AGREE WITH
THE REMARKS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE. THAT THE POSSIBILITY OF
THAT VACCINE- DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING IN TERMS OF OUR
EFFORTS. WE HAVE TO CONTINUE.
AT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY PERCENT-
UNTIL WE SEE IF THAT VACCINE
ACTUALLY MATERIALIZES. AND HOW
IT ACTUALLY. WORKS THIS IS NOT
A TIME TO RELAX. OCTOBER
NINETEEN SPREADS THROUGH CDC
ARE THROUGH THREE PRIMARY
MECHANISMS- AND WE'VE TAKEN
STEPS TO TRY TO MITIGATE EACH
ONE OF THOSE FIRST. IT'S
INTRODUCED INTO THE
INSTITUTIONS FROM STAFF
CONTRACTORS AND OTHER VISITORS
ARE RESPONSES INCLUDED-
CLOSINGS CDCR TO VISITORS BACK
IN MARCH. MANDATING THE USE OF
FACE COVERINGS AND OBSERVANCE
OF DISTANCING AND AS YOU HAVE
ALREADY HEARD SECRETARY ALISON
I BEGAN LAST WEEK A NEW PROGRAM
OF MUCH STRICTER ENFORCEMENT IN
RESPONSE TO BE DISTURBING
FINDINGS BY THE O. I. G.
IMPLEMENTING GATE SCREENING FOR
STAFF AND CONTRACTORS.
IMPLEMENTING SERIAL TESTING FOR
ALL STAFF USING BOTH RAPID
POINT OF CARE TESTS AND PCR
LABORATORY TESTS. IMPLEMENTING
CONTACT TRACING FOR ALL STAFF
CASES- AND THEN PROVIDING
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS FOR STAFF.
THE SECOND MECHANISM OFFERED
BILL WOULD COMING IN IS FROM
PATIENTS TRANSFERRING THE
BETWEEN INSTITUTIONS. ATIONS
MOVING OUT AND THEN BACK INTO
INSTITUTIONS FROM HOSPITALS AND
COURTS. AND THE NEW INMATES
COMING IN FROM COUNTY JAILS.
OUR RESPONSES HAVE INCLUDED ON
MARCH TWENTY FOURTH CLOSINGS
CDCR TO INTAKE FROM JAILS.
ENFORCING MOVEMENT GUIDELINES
TO MINIMIZE THE RISK OF
SPREADING THROUGH INTER
INSTITUTION TRANSFER INCLUDING
TESTING WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS OF TRANSFER BETWEEN
INSTITUTIONS. LIMITS ON THE
NUMBER OF PATIENTS WHO CAN
TRAVEL ON BUSES REQUIREMENTS
THAT ALLSTAFF AND INMATES ON
BUSES WHERE AN NINETY FIVES. IN
REQUIRING FOURTEEN DAY
QUARANTINE AND TESTING IT
RECEIVING INSTITUTIONS. ON NOW
THEY DIDN'T TAKE IT SLOWLY RE
OPENING WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH JAILS TO ESTABLISH
PROTOCOLS FOR THE SAFETY
TRANSFER OF INMATES AND TURNING
BACK BUSES FROM TRAILS THAT DID
NOT COMPLY WITH THOSE PROTOCOLS.
THE THIRD METHOD BY WHICH
GRAVERT SPREADS WITHIN THE
INSTITUTIONS IS BECAUSE OF
HOUSING IN OPEN DORMS. CLOSE
CONTACT AMONG INMATES AND CLOSE
CONTACT BETWEEN INMATES AND
STAFF. OUR RESPONSES HERE
INCLUDED TAKING STEPS TO REDUCE
THE OVERALL POPULATION IN
DORMS. TAKING STEPS TO MOVE THE
COVE IN HIGH RISK PATIENTS THE
OLDER PATIENTS AND THOSE WITH
SIGNIFICANT COMORBIDITIES
PLACING THEM AT RISK TO COPE
WITH. TAKING STEPS TO MOVE THEM
OUT OF DORMS AND INTO SAFER
HOUSING. AGGRESSIVELY
DISTRIBUTING AND REQUIRING USE
OF PP BY OUR PATIENTS.
PROVIDING CLEANING SUPPLIES AND
HAND SANITIZER. IDENTIFYING
ISOLATION AND QUARANTINE SPACE
IT NEARLY ALL INSTITUTIONS
WHICH IS NECESSARY TO MANAGE
OUTBREAKS. IMPLEMENTING CONTACT
TRACING FOR ALL PATIENT CASES
CONDUCTING REGULAR SURVEILLANCE
RESPONSUM SERIAL TESTING FOR
ALL PATIENTS USING BOTH RAPID
POINT OF CARE TESTS AND PCR
LABORATORY TESTS. NOW AS A
GENERAL MATTER PRISONS AND
JAILS ARE NOT BEEN DESIGNED
BUILT OR OPERATED WITH
CONSIDERATION OF THE RISKS
POSED BY COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
AS NOTED OVER A DECADE AGO BY
C. C. H. U. S. A STATEWIDE
MEDICAL EXECUTIVE DR JOS A BIT.
ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S LEADING
EXPERTS ON INFECTIOUS DISEASES
IN A CORRECTIONAL SETTING.
QUOTE MOST JAILS AND PRISONS
WERE CONSTRUCTED TO MAXIMIZE
PUBLIC SAFETY. LOCKS TO
MINIMIZE THE TRANSMISSION OF
DISEASE OR TO EFFICIENTLY
DELIVER HEALTH CLERICAL SCHOOL.
THAT IS WHY FACED WITH OVER
NINETEEN PRISONS ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY HAVE STRUGGLED TO
PROTECT THEIR PATIENTS. AND WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED THE SAME
STRUGGLES AS OTHER CONGREGATE
LIVING ENVIRONMENT SUCH A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES-
SHELTERS AND CRUISE SHIPS. IN
GENERAL THESE ARE NOT SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH TO BE
HOUSED DURING A PANDEMIC.
FOCUSING JUST ON THE FEDERAL
PRISON SYSTEM IN THE TEN
LARGEST STATE PRISON SYSTEMS
CDCR FINDS ITSELF RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PACK CDCR AS HAD
A LARGER NUMBER OF CASES PER
CAPITA THAN SOME PRISONS. BUT A
LOWER NUMBER OF DEATHS PER
CAPITA. THE PROGRESS OF PROBING
NINETEEN CHRISSY DC ARTS
INSTITUTION BECAUSE LARGELY
TRACK THE PROGRESS OF THE
DISEASE IN THE FREE WORLD.
SMALL NUMBERS OF CASES. AND
CLIMBING MORE RAPIDLY WITH THE
NUMBER OF CASES ACCELERATING IN
JUNE A CENTRALLY MIRRORING THE
CASE TRENDS IN CALIFORNIA.
OUTBREAKS ARE AFTER DROPPING
TWO I'M SORRY OF THE NUMBER OF
ACTIVE CASES IN CDC ARE PEAK IN
EARLY JULY AT TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FOUR. AFTER
DROPPING 210-003-0012 IN LATE
AUGUST WE EXPERIENCED A SECOND
PEAK IN LATE SEPTEMBER. AT
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE. OCTOBER SAW A RAPID DROP
IN THE NUMBER OF ACTIVE CASES
TO A LOW THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY IN LATE OCTOBER. I WOULD
RAISE OUR RECENT OUTBREAKS
ABSENT UP IN C. B. S. B. HAS
RAISED THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
ACTIVE CASES. TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN AS OF TODAY. AND AS OF
TODAY WE'VE HAD A- TOTAL
SIXTEEN. SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE CASES AND EIGHTY TWO
DEATHS. SUMMARY OF OUR RESPONSE
WILL NOT BE COMPLETE WITHOUT
SPECIAL MENTION OF THE OUTBREAK
AT CENTERPOINT. THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF THAT OUTBREAK WITH
THE TRANSFER OF A HUNDRED MAYBE
EIGHT PATIENTS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR MEN
TO PRISONS COURT RENDON
STANDPOINT. THOSE PATIENTS
HAPPEN HOW LARGE DORM UNIT AB
CIM WHICH WAS EXPERIENCING AN
EXPANDING OUTBREAK IN ITS OTHER
UNITS. DURING LATE APRIL AND
EARLY MAY WE RESIST THE
PRESSURE TO ATTEMPT A MOVEMENT
OF THOSE MEN OUT OF CIM BECAUSE
WE HAVE NOT YET DEVELOPED A
PROTOCOL FOR INTER INSTITUTION
MOVEMENT OF PATIENTS. THAT
PROTOCOL. THAT WAS BEING
DEVELOPED IN THOSE WEEKS WAS
PREMISED ON HAVING A POTENTIAL
TRANSFER READ TESTED FOR CARBON
NINETEEN AND THEN MOVED IF TEST
RESULTS WERE BEING NEGATIVE.
GIVEN THE SPEED WITH WHICH
GOVERNMENT TEAM TEST RESULTS
FOR BEING RETURNED AT THAT TIME
THE PRACTICAL EXPECTATION WAS A
PATIENT WOULD USUALLY BE MOVED
WITHIN SEVEN DAYS OF BEING TEST.
AND THEN RECEIVING INSTITUTIONS
WERE EXPECTED TO CHECK TRANSFER
RES FOR SYMPTOMS AND ISOLATE OR
QUARANTINE FOR FOURTEEN DAYS.
BOB HAS- MEMBERS KNOW THAT IS
NOT WHAT HAPPENED. ANOTHER
LANGUAGE WHICH APPEARED ON MAY
TWENTY SECOND MOVEMENT MATRIX.
COLIN SCREENING TEST IF PATIENT
IS TO TRANSFER MAY TRANSFER OF
COVERT SCREENING TEST NEGATIVE.
THAT LANGUAGE DOES NOT
EXPRESSLY PROVIDE AS A
MANDATORY REQUIREMENT THE
TESTING HAD TO HAVE OCCURRED
WITHIN SEVEN DAYS OF MOVEMENT.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT GAP IN THE
MOVEMENT MATRIX LANGUAGE WHEN
MOVEMENT FROM C. I AM THE
CORPORATE IN SAN QUENTIN BEGAN
THE PATIENTS HAD NOT BEEN
RETESTED IMMEDIATELY BEFORE
TRANSFER. WHICH RESULTED IN THE
TRANSFER OF MANY PATIENTS WHOSE
MOST RECENT NEGATIVE TEST WAS
TWO THREE AND FOUR WEEKS OLD.
AS IT TURNED OUT TO OF THE
SIXTY SIX PATIENTS MOVED TO
CORCORAN. TESTED POSITIVE UPON
ARRIVAL. OF THE RESULT THERE
WAS A MODERATE OUTBREAK THAT
PIZZA ONLY ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE CASES ON JUNE
SIXTEENTH. WITH THE REMAINING
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO PATIENTS
WHEN THEY ARRIVED AT SAN
QUENTIN OF SEVERAL SYMPTOMATIC
PATIENTS WERE ISOLATED BUT MOST
OF THE TRANSFER RES WERE PLACED
IN ORDINARY HOUSING. WHICH OF
SAN QUENTIN INMATE MANSON BEING
HOUSED IN MULTI TIERED OPEN
SELF ROUNDHOUSE. AT THE TIME OF
THE MOVE TO SAN QUENTIN THE
PREDOMINANT VIEW OF PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS WAS THAT OVER
NINETEEN SPREAD BY DROPLETS AND
CLOSE CONTACTS. BUT DID NOT
GENERALLY SPREAD BY AEROSOL IS
H. IF THAT HAVE BEEN TRUE SAN
QUENTIN'S MULTI TIERED CELLS
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A SAFER
HOUSING ENVIRONMENT THAN THE
OPEN AIR DORMS AT CIM. HOWEVER
SANDPLAINS EXPERIENCE AS WELL
AS OUR SUBSEQUENT EXPERIENCE
WITHOUT BREAKS AT FOLSOM AND
THE CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION
CENTER SUPPORTS THE CONTRARY
CONCLUSION. THAT KOBE NINETEEN
CAMERA IN FACT READILY SPREAD
THROUGH AEROSOLS ASIAN IN A
CORRECTIONAL ENVIRONMENT- WHERE
PATIENTS BREATHE THEN SHARED
AIR SPACE. THAT WAS THE
ULTIMATE CONCLUSION REACHED BY
DOCTORS BRIE WILLIAMS AND
STEFAN OVERDOSING IN THEIR JUNE
THIRTEEN REPORT. ON THE SAN
QUENTIN OUTBREAK. ON OCTOBER
FIVE. THE CDC OF FINALLY
ACKNOWLEDGED AEROSOL SPREAD OF
CLOVER. NINETEEN NOW AS SOON AS
WE REALIZE WHAT HAPPENED SAN
QUENTIN WE SUSPENDED FURTHER
UNNECESSARY TRANSFERS BETWEEN
INSTITUTIONS AND REDRAFT OF THE
TRANSFER PROTOCOLS TO MAKE SURE
THE SUCH A TRANSFER WOULD NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN. IT IS WORTH
NOTING- THAT PRIOR TO THE CIM
TRANSFERS CDCR HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY AND SAFELY
TRANSFERRED OME SIXTY EIGHT
HUNDRED PATIENTS BETWEEN
INSTITUTIONS. WITHOUT SPREADING
PROGRAM NINETEEN. AFTER THE RE
DRAFTING OF THE TRANSFER
PROTOCOLS AFTER SAN QUENTIN'S
OUTBREAK CDC ARE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY AND SAFELY
TRANSFERRED OVER SIX THOUSAND
PATIENTS BETWEEN INSTITUTIONS
WITHOUT INCIDENT. THAT'S GOOD
NEWS HOWEVER I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT I AM CONFIDENT WE WILL
ONLY SEE ONE OR MORE TRANSFERS
INTER INSTITUTION TRANSFER IS
TRIGGERING OUTBREAKS IN
RECEIVING INSTITUTIONS. BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH OUR TITAN PROTOCOLS
THE VIRUS IS A VERY GOOD AT
FINDING WAYS OF SPREADING AND
CIRCUMVENTING PROTECTIVE
MEASURES. AND HUMAN BEINGS WILL
INEVITABLY MAKE MISTAKES GIVEN
THE VIRUS THE OPPORTUNITY IT
NEEDS TO SPREAD. I WANT TO SKIP
AHEAD HERE IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME BUT IN CONCLUSION- NOTED
CDC R. AND C. C. H. C. UP STAFF
HAVE PERFORMED WITH COURAGE.
AND DEDICATION THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. AND OUR PATIENTS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR EFFORTS.
BASED ON WHAT WE SEE HAPPENING
IN CORRECTIONAL SETTINGS AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND BASED ON A
REVIEW OF THE CDC'S
CORRECTIONAL GUIDELINES- I CAN
REPRESENT YOU THAT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN WITHIN OUR
EXISTING ENVIRONMENT TO FIGHT
THE SPREAD OF OVER NINETEEN.
HOWEVER FROM A HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE. THE HOUSING
CHOICES AVAILABLE TO US WITHIN
THE CDC ARE REMAIN PROBLEMATIC.
CDC ARE ESSENTIALLY CONSISTS OF
LARGE CONGREGATE LIVING
FACILITIES A SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF WHICH ARE OPEN
DORMITORY SETTINGS. THESE
DORMITORY SETTINGS IN
PARTICULAR ARE THE WORST
POSSIBLE SETTINGS FOR
CONTAINING THE SPREAD OF THE
HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS DISEASE. SO
EVEN IF OVER NINETEEN VACCINES
BECOME AVAILABLE TO US NEXT
YEAR AS I BELIEVE THEY WILL. IT
IS I THINK INEVITABLE THE NEW
AND POTENTIALLY EVEN MORE
DANGEROUS VIRUSES WILL SOMEDAY
APPEAR. AND I THINK THE STATE
NEEDS TO KEEP THAT IN MIND AND
SHOULD CONSIDER WHAT TYPE OF
HOUSING OPTIONS NEED TO BE
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE CDC OURS
INSTITUTIONS. SO THAT WE CAN
AVOID THE HARM THAT THE NEXT
PANDEMIC IS OTHERWISE SHORT TO
COST. THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE SECRETARY
ALISON YOU SEE OUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN HEAR YOU GREAT THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON SENIOR REBELLION
SHARES OF. YOU CAN SEE JUST
RIGHT. VERY GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
EFFORTS. TO MITIGATE THE SPREAD
OF COPE WITH NINETEEN INSIDE OF
OUR FACILITIES. SINCE MR KELSO-
TESTIMONY PROVIDED AN OVERVIEW
OF WHERE WE ARE IN OUR EFFORTS
TO COMBAT KOBE IN NINETEEN
INCLUDING THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM SAN QUENTIN. I'M GOING TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE OFFICES
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL'S. REPORT
THE FIRST TWO REPORTS IN HIS
SERIES OF REPORTS SPECIFICALLY
SCREENING AND MASKS. COMPLIANCE
I WILL NOT BE COMMENTING ON THE
L. A. O.'S- AND DISCUSSION
REGARDING THE SAN QUENTIN AND
STAGE CREW COURT ORDER AS
THEY'VE HIGHLIGHTED. WE ARE
STILL EVALUATING OUR OPTIONS
AND WE HAVE UNTIL NOVEMBER
SIXTEENTH TO RENDER A FINAL
DECISION. WHETHER WE WILL BE
PETITIONING THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT FOR REVIEW IN
THAT CASE. WELL I WILL NOT
COMMENT ON PENDING LITIGATION I
WILL STRESS THAT IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE RECEIVER WE CONTINUE
TO IMPLEMENT A VARIETY OF CODED
MITIGATION STRATEGIES AT SAN
QUENTIN AND THROUGHOUT OUR
SYSTEM. TO KEEP ALL THOSE WHO
WORK AND LIVE WITHIN OUR
FACILITY SAFE. AS OF TODAY SAN
QUINN HAS THREE POSITIVE CASES.
WITH ELEVEN STAFF CASES OF I
THINK MR KELSO TALKED ABOUT THE
STATEWIDE NUMBER SO I WILL NOT
REITERATE THAT SO LET ME GO TO
TURN TO THE O. I. G. REPORT. WE
TAKE THIS VERY VERY SERIOUSLY I
WILL SAY KOBE REVOLVES AROUND
THE NATION AND WE PIVOTED- AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE TO THE EVER
AND- THE DEMANDS OF COBIT AND
HOW AND HOW WE RESPOND TO IT. I
WILL SAY NATIONALLY ARE
SCREENING DIRECTION WAS NOT
CLEAR. WE WERE FOCUSING ON THE
INMATE POPULATION WE'RE
FOCUSING ON OUR INTEREST IS A
SECURE PERIMETER AND THE
COLLECTING ARE- ADMINISTRATION
BUILDINGS. SO THAT WAS A
FAILURE- I WILL SAY THAT YOU
KNOW WITH MOST RECENT DIRECTION
AS FAR AS OUR SCREENING. ONE
POINT SEVEN TRENDS GENERALLY
OUT OF OUR OWN ENTRANCES AT OUR
GATES TO OUR FACILITIES HAS
PROVEN TO BE. DIABLE IN
IMPROPER SCREENING I WILL SAY
THAT OUR STATE OR SCREENING
MAJORITY OVER SPRING STUFF BY
BY NURSING STAFF. AND WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED SOME DIFFICULTY
WITH INITIAL EQUIPMENT THAT WE
OBTAIN FOR THE NON CONTACT
THERMOMETERS WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY THERE WE'VE TRIED A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS. AND MOST
RECENTLY SELECTED EVEN IF A
BETTER OPTION WITH THE BETTER
BETTER BATTERY LIFE. SO WE HAVE
SINCE SINCE THAT REPORT
OBVIOUSLY DONE EXTENSIVE
TRAINING TO ALL OF OUR STAFF
PROVIDING SCREENING. OF THE
DOCUMENTATION IMPROVE FOR
PRACTICE ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
THE THERMOMETER ISSUE AS IT
RELATES TO BATTERY LIFE THAT
HAS SINCE I THINK RESOLVED-
STAFF KNOW HOW TO EXCHANGE
BATTERIES INTO. IMPROVE THE
BATTERY LIFE WE'VE WE'VE GONE
TO IT A NEW MODEL THAT WE'VE
TESTED AT- BUT FOR VERY
INSTITUTIONS AND WE ARE
ANTICIPATING- ADDITIONAL SUPPLY
EACH AND EVERYONE OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
THAT THE NON TOUCH THE MONITORS
IT EVERYWHERE BUT WE ARE
ORDERING THESE ADDITIONAL UP
LONG BATTERY LIFE ONCE- AND
THREE. THE MOMENT WILL BE AT
EACH ENTRANCE POINTS OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND THEY WILL BE
DIRECTORSHIP TO OUR FACILITIES.
GOES ON- THE SECOND REPORT OF
NON COMPLIANCE AS IT RELATES TO
WEARING FACIAL COVERINGS. I
WILL SAY THAT WE'VE INVOLVED IN
THIS AREA AS WELL INITIAL
DIRECTION WAS NOT CLEAR IT WAS
ALMOST A RECOMMENDATION VERSUS
BEING MANDATORY WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY WITH THAT- SETTING
VERY CLEAR EXPECTATIONS BECAUSE
WE TAKE THIS VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY WE'VE LEARNED SO MUCH
ABOUT THE TRANSMISSION AND
SPREAD. OF THIS VIRUS AND MASS
MATTER. AND THAT'S THE MESSAGE
VERY CLEARLY THAT BOTH RECEIVER
KELSO AND I HAVE TAKEN A VERY
FIRST STAND ON THIS ISSUE.
THERE'S BEEN MULTIPLE MEMOS OUT
TO STAFF SOME WHAT CONFUSING
FROM ONE MEMBER TO THE NEXT IT
JUST. WE WERE TRYING TO EVOLVE
AS CODED WAS INVOLVED THE AND
SOMETIMES IT WAS NOT CLEAR- AND
EVEN THE COMMUNITY AS WE ALL
KNOW THAT THAT HAS INVOLVED AS
WELL. SO MOST RECENTLY THE MOST
RECENT MEMOS DATED OCTOBER
TWENTY SEVENTH WHERE. IT'S NOT
ONLY REINFORCES THE EXPECTATION
ABOUT WEARING MASKS BUT IT
REINFORCES MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS RESPONSIBILITY AS
IT RELATES TO MASK AND HOLDING
STAFF ACCOUNTABLE THROUGH OUR
CORRECTIVE DISCIPLINARY PROCESS
WE FURTHER EMPHASIZED THAT WE
WILL HAVE OUR REGIONAL HEALTH
CARE EXECUTIVES AS WELL AS OUR
ASSOCIATE DIRECTORS. DOING
RANDOM SPOT INSPECTIONS AT EACH
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS- AND ALSO
TO ENSURE THAT OUR PROGRESSIVE
DISCIPLINARY AND SHOULD TENANTS
ARE FOR NON COMPLIANCE ARE
APPROPRIATE. IN ADDITION KERR
CAN I HELP SKEWS ME RECEIVER
KELSO AND I HELD A CALL ON
FRIDAY AND OF WITH VERY CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS HOLDING BOARDS AND
CEOS RESPONSIBLE. FOR MASS
COMPLAINTS WITHIN THEIR
INSTITUTIONS. I WILL SAY THAT
THAT WAS WELL RECEIVED THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS VERY CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS AT THE END OF THAT
CALL I SAID I NEED YOU TO DO A.
B. AND C. AB WELL UNDERSTOOD
BUT THE EXPECTATION LAST. SO I
FEEL CONFIDENT AS THE DIRECTOR
GENERAL JUST STATED WE HAD A
100% I REALIZE THAT THAT IS ONE
INSTITUTION BUT I'M FREQUENTLY
AT THE INSTITUTIONS AND ICY-
INCREASE COMPLIANCE AT OUR
INSTITUTIONS I WILL SAY AN
INSTITUTION WITH OUTBREAKS
EVERYONE IS FULLY MPP WHEN
THEY'RE GOING INTO THOSE
BUILDINGS- THE INMATES UNIVERSE
WE STRUGGLED WITH GETTING TO
MAKE COMPLAINTS AS WELL THAT
COMES WITH PATIENT EDUCATION
FOR THEM TO UNDERSTAND THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS DISEASE.
AND MANY OF THEM I WILL SAY
HAVE BEEN A SYMPTOMATIC SO THEY
THINK IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL BUT
IT IS A BIG DEAL- BECAUSE THEY
MITCHELL FINE WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
THEY'RE SITTING AROUND IF THEY
TRY TO EXERCISE OR SOMETHING
THEN THEY QUICKLY REALIZED.
ADULT PROBLEM SO I. JUST WILL
SAY THAT WE'VE SEEN. INCREASING
COMPLIANCE WITH SEEN. AS WITH
THE REST OF THE WORLD WE
STRUGGLED EARLY ON WITH-
RECEIVE HAVING. HE AVAILABILITY
NOW WE HAVE OVER TWO YEAR
SUPPLY OF PP WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS SO VERY CONFIDENT
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO- MAINTAIN
THAT WE MONITOR THOSE VERY VERY
CLOSELY. A FEW OTHER THINGS I'D
LIKE TO MENTION IS THE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION OF OUR
POPULATION. CURRENTLY OUR
INSTITUTION CAMP POPULATION IS
AT NINETY FOUR THOUSAND THIS IS
THE LOWEST IN THREE DECADES.
THE REDUCTION OF THE POPULATION
HAS BEEN FROM A VARIETY OF
REASONS ONE OF THE EARLY
RELEASES WE'VE HAD OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND RELEASED BETWEEN JULY
FIRST OF NOVEMBER FIFTH. WAS
200-005-0080 TO BE SPECIFIC
MANY OF THOSE WERE EARLY
RELEASES OUT OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS FROM A VARIETY OF
METHODS. WE DID A TWELFTH MONTH
EARLY RELEASE FOR ALL OF THOSE
AT VERY SPECIFIC HIGH RISK
INSTITUTIONS AND WE ADDED A FEW
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAD A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF HIGH RISK INMATES.
BUT NOT NECESSARILY IT DOESN'T
HIGH RISK INSTITUTION. IN
ADDITION WE ARE CONTINUING SIX
MONTHS EARLY RELEASE FOR- ALL
OFFENDERS WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEX
OFFENDERS. AND OF THE WE ALSO
APPLY TO TWELVE MONTH POSITIVE
PROGRAMMING CREDIT TO ALL
OFFENDERS WERE DISCIPLINARY
FREE DURING A VERY SPECIFIC
ABOUT A TIME SO YOU KNOW THE
MARCH TO JULY TIME FRAME THEY
HAD TO BE DISCIPLINARY FREE AND
THEY RECEIVE TWELVE WEEKS AFTER
SENSE WHICH EQUATES TO EIGHTY
FOUR DAYS EVERYBODY RECEIVE
THAT THERE WERE NO RESTRICTIONS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF LIFE
WITHOUT POSSIBILITY PAROLE AND
CONTEMPT. OFFENDERS ALL OF THAT
HAS DRASTICALLY REDUCED OUR
POPULATION WITHIN OUR SYSTEM.
IN ADDITION- WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATIONAND THE COUNTY
JAILS. TO AFFORD THOSE
OFFENDERS WHO HAVE A- A SHORTER
SENTENCE THEIR TWELVE WEEK
CREDITS WHILE THEY'RE IN COUNTY
JAIL- TO BE ABLE TO AND APPLY
ANY ANY ANY PART OF ANY TYPE
OF. GOOD CONDUCT CREDIT EARNING
TO THEM SO THEY CAN RELEASE
FROM THE GELS VERSUS COMING TO
US AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY
RELEASING. SO WE HAD A GREAT
RESPONSE WITH THAT WE'VE ASKED
THE COUNTIES TO SEND US ALL OF
THEIR CASES THAT THEY THINK ARE
WITHIN TWO YEARS AND SO CASE
RECORDS ARE STILL PROCESS IN
THOSE CASES. IF THE COUNTY HAS
A CASE THAT THEY FEEL LIKE IS
UP FOR IT- IMMINENT RELEASE WE
IMMEDIATELY PROCESS OF THEIR
PAPERWORK TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
GET THEM OUT TIMELY. IN
ADDITION- I CURRENTLY- AND
CLARK IS HE EXPRESSED CONCERNS
AS IT RELATES TO OUR TYPES OF
HOUSING SO OBVIOUSLY WITH IT.
SALAS CELL FRIENDS MATTER
PHYSICAL PLANT MATTERS ARE OPEN
DORMS DESIGN VERSES ARE OPEN
CELL FRIENDS VERSES ARE SALAS
CELL DOORS ALL THAT MATTERS AND
GOES INTO. HOW WE HOW WE MANAGE
OUR POPULATION RIGHT NOW IN OUR
DORM SETTINGS WE ARE AT 81%
CAPACITY WHICH IS VERY VERY
LOW- IT'S THE LOWEST I'VE EVER
SEEN IT HONESTLY IN MY CAREER.
UP I WILL SAY WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE RECEIVERS OFFICE TO
OFFER HOUSING TRANSFERS OF
INMATES THAT ARE CONSIDERED
HIGH RISK FOR COGINT FROM A
DORM CITING TO A CELL ITSELF
AREN'T SETTING. UNDERSTAND MOST
OF THE OFFENDERS AND THE LOWER
OPEN DORM SETTINGS HAVE REDUCED
OUR POINTS DOWN TO WHERE THEY
NO LONGER REQUIRE CELL HOUSING.
BUT WE ARE OFFERING THEM TELL
HOUSING FOR THEIR HEALTH. SO
THAT IS STILL ONGOING. ANOTHER
EFFORT OF THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF IS THAT THE TESTING AND-
BOTH ARE INMATES AS WELL AS OUR
STAFF HAS BEEN VERY VERY ROBUST
WE DO SERIAL TESTING. AND
REYES- PUTS THE RIGHT WORKFORCE
NOT RANDOM TESTING THAT A
SURVEILLANCE TEST AND THAT'S
THE WORD THANK YOU. WE DO
SURVEILLANCE TESTING OF ALL OF
OUR STAFF AS WELL AS THE
POPULATION. AND WE'VE DONE OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND TESTS. IN
OUR SYSTEM AND- WELL ACCORDING
TO MY STAFF TWICE IN THE
AVERAGE AROUND AND THE KEEP IT
I THINK IN THE NATION. BUT I
WILL SAY THAT BECAUSE OF OUR-
TEST OF OUR STAFF WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY EARLY IF THERE'S AN
AND A POTENTIAL OUTBREAK.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR OUTBREAKS
ALSO NEAR WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE COMMUNITY SO WE MONITOR
THAT VERY VERY CLOSELY- SO IT
AS CLARK SAID WE DO STAFF
TESTING AND CONTACT TRACING.
FOR EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
POSITIVE CASES TO IDENTIFY THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT OF THOSE
CASES- WHO IT THEY POTENTIALLY
EXPOSED DURING THAT TIME. WE
HAD EVEN THOUGH ROBUST
SCREENING SO MANY STAFF ARE. A
SYMPTOMATIC SO THE COMING TO
WORK AND THEY JUST DON'T KNOW
THAT THEIR THAT THEY'RE SECOND
TO WE TEST THEM SO. I WILL SAY
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY WITH THAT
WE HAVE FOLLOWED THAT THE
GUIDANCE FROM. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH CDC
AS WELL AS OUR PARTNERS AND C.
C. H. C. S. WE ARE IN LOCKSTEP
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE- DOING
AMPLE TESTING OF OUR STAFF AS
WELL AS OUR VENDORS- AND I WILL
SAY EARLY ON THAT EVERYBODY
STRUGGLES WITH THE TEST
RESULTS- THERE WERE THERE WAS A
TIME EARLY ON IN CODED WHERE.
IT WAS TAKING TEN TO FOURTEEN
DAYS AGO TEST RESULTS WELL NOW
WE'RE DOING TESTING EVERY SEVEN
DAYS- SAME AS THE NURSING HOMES
THAT VERY SPECIFIC INSTITUTIONS.
AND SO I WILL SAY THAT OUR TEST
TURN AROUND TIMES HAVE REDUCED
TO TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY EIGHT
HOURS SO REMARKABLE DIFFERENCE-
IT'S IN OUR IN OUR TESTING
THROUGH THESE VIGOROUS TESTING
PROTOCOLS COMBINED WITH THE
VARIOUS CHANGES IN SCREENING AT
ENTRANCES. CONTACT TRACING.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GAIN A
BETTER- CONTROL OF THE
OUTBREAK- WE STILL STRUGGLE AS
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE A THOUSAND
CURRENT CASES WE WERE ALL VERY
EXCITED WE'RE AT THREE HUNDRED
AND WE SLOWLY SEE ARE RISING- I
TRY TO GO OUT TO OUT BRAKE
INSTITUTIONS MYSELF TO MONITOR
TO MAKE SURE THAT STAFF ARE
COMPLYING WITH- ALL THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS AS IT RELATES
TO PROPER PPE. FEEDING
PROTOCOLS AND THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS- SURVEIL ARE THE WE DO
TWICE A DAY NURSING ASSESSMENTS
HEALTH CARE DOES IS WE'VE COME
OFF WE'VE DEFINITELY COME A
LONG WAY. C. CURRENTLY ATTEND
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN
COATED FREE OF AND ANOTHER
ELEVEN HAVE LESS THAN FIVE
CASES. AND A CLOSE AND I WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE WORKED
DILIGENTLY THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC COUNTLESS HOURS FROM
ALL OF OUR STAFF AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH OUR
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS. I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITYSPEAK
TODAY AND WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE. THANK YOU RESTORED
OFF WITH MR COOPER. STE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MY FIRST
QUESTIONS ARE FOR- MISS ALLISON
SO YOU GOT THIRTY FIVE PRISONS-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WHAT I'M GETTING READING THIS
YOU'VE GOT THIRTY FIVE
DIFFERENT WARDENS AND REALLY
THIRTY FIVE DIFFERENT POLICY SO.
NO MATTER WHICH FACILITYI
WOULD I WOULD GO TO TODAY RIGHT
NOW. WITH THE SCREENING PROCESS
BE THE SAME. SO THEY'RE ALLOWED
VARIANTS DEPENDING UPON THEIR
PHYSICAL PLANT DESIGN- SO SOME
OF THE OLDER INSTITUTIONS HAVE
AN ABILITY TO- SCREEN OUTSIDE
THE SECURITY PERIMETER. SOME
HAVE ABILITY JUST SCREAM AT THE
GUARD SHACK COMING IN IT JUST
DEPENDS UPON THEIR INDIVIDUAL
PHYSICAL PLANT DESIGN. BUT THEY
HAVE ALL OF THEIR PLANS HAD
BEEN APPROVED BY OUR
HEADQUARTERS THE C. C. H. C. S.
AS WELL AS- THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
HAD APPROVED EACH OF THEIR
PLANS TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR
CONSISTENCY PURPOSES. OKAY AND
I KNOW YOU WERE LAST YEAR YOU
SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER OF MR KELSO
MAY HAVE NOT RELAXING THE-
GUIDELINES FOR FACE
REQUIREMENTS FOR STAFF AND
INMATES. BACK IN JUNE WHAT IS
THAT REQUIREMENT TODAY ON
WEARING FACE MASK IT HAS SINCE
CHANGED SO THAT THE CHANGE IN
JUNE. HAD TO BE RELATED TO
OUTSIDE SO THERE WAS AT THAT
TIME. AND OF COURSE WE'VE ALL
OF ALL. PEOPLE THERE WAS A FROM
A PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE
THAT IT WAS FINE IF YOU WERE
OUTDOORS AND COULD- HAVE SIX.
FEET DISTANCE THAT AMOUNTS WAS
NOT REQUIRED SO WE DID ALLOW
THAT WITHIN OUR INSTITUTIONS.
OF THAT HAS SINCE CHANGED SO
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO WEAR A
MOUSE THE ONLY TIME. THAT
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO WEAR A
MASK IS IF THEY'RE IN AN OFFICE
BY THEMSELVES WITH SOLID DOORS.
OF THAT THEY COULD CLOSE- IF
SOMEBODY WERE TO INTO THEIR
OFFICE THEY NEED TO DON A MASK.
OR IF THEY'RE IN THE TOWER
AGAIN ALONE. WE DID ALLOW THEM
WHEN THEY'RE RUN INTO AN ALARM
BECAUSE IT'S HARD WHEN YOU'RE
BREATHING HEAVILY THROUGH A
MASK. TO BE ABLE TO THE TO PULL
IT DOWN WHILE YOU'RE RUNNING
IMMEDIATELY- PUT IT OUT SO
THOSE WERE THAT THE MOST RECENT
CHANGES. THAT WE MADE TO OUR
VAST POLICY. AND WHAT IS A
COMPLIANCE ON INMATES WAS
PURSUED AFTER THE ALL
FOLLOWING. THE PROGRAM OR SOME
ARE SOME AREN'T. WELL YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF HAVING
TO SENDING YET ANOTHER
DIRECTIVE OUT TO THE INMATE
POPULATION. I MEAN IT'S A
STRUGGLE A LOT OF THEM LISTEN
TO THE NEWS SOMETIMES THEY
DON'T BELIEVE IT- I WILL SAY
WHEN I WALK INSTITUTIONS THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE WEARING
THEM UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES
ARE BELOW THE NOSE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T REALIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
COVERING THE NOSE. AND SO JUST
CONSTIPATED PATIENT EDUCATION
AS IT RELATES TO. PROPERLY
WEARING OF YOUR MASK SO WHAT
HAPPENS TO ME DOESN'T WEAR HIS
MASK WOOD WHAT DO YOU DO WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM. THEY COULD GO
THROUGH PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINE.
WE'VE TRIED NOT TO DO THAT YET
BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW IT WE'RE
VERY SENSITIVE RIGHT THIS IS
THEIR HOME. THEY DON'T SEE IT
THE SAME WAY WE DO BUT WE HAVE
TOLD THEM THROUGH PATIENT
EDUCATION AND THERE WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF DRAFTING A MEMO FOR
CONSIDERATION FOR. POTENTIAL
DISCIPLINE FOR NON COMPLIANCE
WELL I GUESS WE'RE NINE MONTHS
INTO THIS ALREADY IN THIS
PANDEMIC WE KNOW THAT MASK SAVE
LIVES. WERE DISAPPOINTING STAFF
NON SWORN AND NON SWORN COULD
NOT WEARING A MASK AND YET
WE'RE STILL RUNNING MAMMALS FOR
THE INMATES. THAT HEY YOU
SHOULD WEAR MASKING CALLING
THEM AT SOME POINT. YOU KNOW WE
SEEM BUT I'VE GOT WATER
GOVERNOR SAID ON TV'S. WHAT
THE- POSITIONS THE SAID YOU
NEED TO WEAR A MASK SO I WOULD
THINK WE'RE FURTHER OR FAR
BEYOND THAT POINT. WE'RE STILL
GOING TO SUGGESTED THAT YOU
WHERE ARE YOU COULD DISCIPLINE
FOR IT. IN THIS PRIVILEGES.
SUBS FOR AND FIGURE OUT NINE
LISTEN. TO THIS. WHY ARE WE
STILL. WRITING MEMOS PAPERS.
FOR THESE FOLKS. FOR THE MOST
RECENT DEMO IS TO TAKE. AND
DISCIPLINARY MEASURES IT HAS
NOT BEEN RELEASED YET. OKAY
WELL I GUESS MY POINT IS THAT
WE'RE WE'RE FAR TO THIS AND
EVERYONE KNOWS. KILEY LAN AND
I'M SURE MAMMALS HAVE BEEN SET
UP BEFORE. AND THEY'VE GOTTEN
EDUCATION MATERIALS THROUGH
YOU. AND THROUGH MR KELSO'S
OFFICE. SO THEY'VE BEEN TOLD
ABOUT THIS NUMEROUS TIMES
CORRECT. YES OKAY AND IT'S JUST
IT'S JUST AND I GUESS THE OTHER
ISSUE IS I KNOW CCAR. PART OF
THE ISSUE WITH WITH IT'S JUST
CONSISTENCY WITH THIRTY FIVE
PRESENTS THERE'S A LOT OF
AUTONOMY THERE A LITTLE THEIR
AGENCIES LARGE AGENCIES THAT
WERE IT'S MORE TOP DOWN
MANAGEMENT HOW YOU WILL DO THIS
IS NOT OPTIONAL AND I KNOW THAT
C. C. R. GIVES A LOT OF LEEWAY.
THAT MAY CONTRIBUTE TO SOME OF
THESE THINGS IN THE PRISONS ARE
YOU TRYING TO MORE RATED IN IT
AND WE'RE WHAT I'M SAYING
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE
SECRETARY SO THE BOOKS MAPS OF
THE BOOK. THE BUCK STOPS WITH
YOU. I'M NOT ABSOLUTE. YEAH SO
AND I WILL SAY THAT WAS THE
PURPOSE OF OUR CALL ON FRIDAY
WAS TO MAKE SURE IT WAS.
CRYSTAL CLEAR WHAT THE
EXPECTATION WAS. OF WITH OUR
INSTITUTIONS I MEAN I'M TIRED
OF RIGHT TO SIGN MY NAME TO
MEMOS. I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY CLEARLY
UNDERSTOOD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
ANSWER. TO ASK QUESTIONS. OF
AND BOTH CLARK AND I FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT OUR MESSAGE WAS
LOUD AND CLEAR. BUT IT STILL
COMES BACK AND I'M NOT A
BELIEVER THE POINT. WE'RE STILL
NINE MONTHS INTO THIS AND WE'RE
STILL DOING ALL THIS STUFF.
WHICH SHOULD'VE OCCURRED QUITE
A BIT OF TIME AGO. BECAUSE WE
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING IT
THROUGH ITS NEST AND HOSPITALS
AND- YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
PRETTY TIGHT ON IT. EVEN THE
CAPITAL I MEAN. YOU JUST HAVE
TO CHECK GO TO WEAR MASKS. THE
LAWLER STUFF IS MIND NUMBING
BECAUSE- YOU HAVE WHAT YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE FOR MONITORS OR THE
BATTERY GOES OUT. YOU'VE GOT.
TO DO THAT SO. SOME OF THE
STUFF I'M HEARING IS LAUGHABLE.
THAT PEOPLE CAN'T GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER ON THIS. BECAUSE IF
YOU CAN SCREEN SOMEONE
ENTRANCED LIKE IF YOU HAVE A
FLASHLIGHT YOU HAVE EXTRA
BATTERIES IT'S JUST THINGS LIKE
THAT. WE'RE IT'S AND I WILL SAY
THIS. YOU KNOW I THINK C. R. C.
C. R. CONTRIBUTED SOME THESE
ISSUES- I'M NOT GONNA BLAME YOU
WELL MAYBE I. DON'T KNOW. BUT
THROUGH THE- THROUGH
MANAGEMENT. AND IT THAT THAT
THAT'S THE MOST FRUSTRATING
PART THAT WE'RE IN THIS. AND
EVERYONE SHOULD WEAR A MASK AND
PERIOD IF THIS IS NOT OPTIONAL
IF YOU DON'T. GET THERE'S GONNA
BE REPERCUSSIONS. BUT IT'S JUST
THAT'S FRUSTRATION. IS A LOT OF
COULD HAVE BEEN PER. WITH AND
EVEN DOWN THE TREE. OF THE
INMATES THAT WERE NEVER TESTED
IT'S JUST. IT IT'S SO SAD THIS
COMICAL NOTHING COMICAL. THAT
HOW WE CHANGE THIS AND REALLY
GET IT BACK- I THINK IT IS
TOUGH FOR YOU GUYS BECAUSE
YOU'RE FACILITIES. THE ACTUAL
PHYSICAL PLANT. YOU GOT A LOT
OF ALL FACILITIES THAT ARE
CONDUCIVE FOR IT- THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR DO NOT
WANT TO BUILD PRISONS THEY
WANNA CLOSE PRISONS. THE
PROBLEM IS. WE'VE GOT A B. ONE
OH NINE PROP 47-57. WHEN YOU
KNOW AND I KNOW WHO'S LEFT IN
PRISON. VIA THE FENDERS. IS
THAT CORRECT. THERE WE CAN
PRODUCE SURE A TOTAL OF FULL
OUTBREAK OF OUR POPULATION BUT
YOU'D BE SURPRISED HOW MANY NOT
NON- VIOLENT LIKE SAY SECOND
STRIKERS THAT WE HAVE IN THOSE
TYPE OF THINGS BUT FOR THE MOST
PART WE DO HAVE A FAIR NUMBER
OF VERY SERIOUS AND VIOLENT
OFFENDERS WITHIN OUR FACILITIES
RIGHT. AND ALSO WE KNOW
OBVIOUSLY THAT SOME NONVIOLENT
CRIMES OR IF YOU'RE DOING A
WOMAN INTO HAVING A CHILD YOU
CONSIDER NON VIOLENT CRIMES BUT
IT STILL GOES BACK TO- IS MR
KELSO SAID THERE WILL BE MORE
OUTBREAKS AT SOME POINT LATER
ON AND HOW DO WE FIX THIS AND
WE DON'T FIX IT IN THE CURRENT
SET UP WITH PRISONS- THERE
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S OF THE
TECHNOLOGY IS LEAPT IS GONE BY
LEAPS AND BOUNDS. WHERE THEY
CAN BUILD MUCH BETTER FACILITY
BUT NO ONE WANTS TO DO IT SO- I
FEEL SORRY FOR YOU I KNOW
YOU'RE A TOUGH SITUATION AS THE
SECRETARY- DOING SOME OF THE
ISSUES IT'S THE. HAND YOU'RE
DEALT WITH. BUT AS WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SEE JUST MORE IN YOUR
TOP DOWN HE- HAS OVER GOING TO
DO IS NOT OPTIONAL AND- AND
QUIT GIVING SO MUCH TO TALK TO
ME- TO THE WARDENS BECAUSE MY
OPINION THEY HAVE TOO MUCH. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I HAD A QUESTION FOR CDC
ARE- IN THE STATEWIDE
POPULATIONS- WE'VE SEEN
SUBSTANTIAL PROBLEMS WITH
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL HEALTH AS
A RESULT OF THE LACK F SOCIAL
INTERACTION- IMPOSED BY SOME OF
OUR SHUT DOWNS- IN RESPONSE THE
PANDEMIC AND I'M WONDERING IF
YOU HAVE ANY DATA ABOUT THE
EFFECTS ON IN MADE THE MOTIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH THAT THE LACK OF
VISITATION HAS CAUSED AND I'M
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE- THE YOUTH TOWARD.
POPULATION WELL AS FAR AS DATA
I MAY HAVE TO- DIFFER OR GET
YOU SOME DATA ON THAT SIDE I
DON'T KNOW FOR SURE IF THERE'S
ACTUAL DATA I WILL JUST SAY IT
IS ABSOLUTELY HEARTBREAKING.
THAT OURVENDORS HAVE NOT HAD
FACE TO FACE VISITING. SINCE
MARCH. AND IT'S NOT LOST ON ME
THAT THE HOLIDAYS ARE COMING
IT'S GOING TO BE EVEN HARDER.
WE'RE WORKING VERY VERY HARD WE
WERE HOPING TO OPEN UP FOR FACE
TO FACE VISITING. IN THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE AND UNFORTUNATELY
AS OF YESTERDAY. I WAS INFORMED
THAT THAT WILL NOT BE HAPPENING
AND BASED ON HEALTH CARE'S
RECOMMENDATION PUBLIC HEALTH
RECOMMENDATIONS. WE ARE WORKING
VERY HARD VERY FAST TO GET AN
ELECTRONIC SOLUTION SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE TODAY.
FOR FAMILIES- I WILL SAY THAT
ON OUR JUVENILE SIDE WERE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT THAT FAIRLY EARLY
ON A COVERT I COULDN'T RECALL
THE EXACT DATE I WANT TO SAY IT
WAS APRIL TIME FRAME MAYBE MAY
THE WE ACTUALLY WERE ABLE TO DO
SKYPE BUSY NOW THEIR POPULATION
IS MUCH MUCH LOWER THAN OURS.
BUT I HAVE GIVEN A REALLY HARD
DEADLINE THAT I EXPECT THIS IS
IT THIS SOON AS HUMANLY
POSSIBLE IF NOT IF I HAVE TO
REACH OUT TO ANOTHER STATE
AGENCY LIKE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY FOR
SOME SUPPORT I'VE DEFINITELY
PREPARED TO DO THAT IF MY IF
INTERNALLY WE KEEP WE CANNOT
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET VISITING
I WILL SAY THAT OUR MENTAL
HEALTH. PARTNERS HAVE BEEN VERY
DILIGENT WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
TO OUR OFFENDERS IN OUR CARE-
BECAUSE IT'S VERY IT'S- IT'S-
IT'S BEEN DRAMATIC I WILL SAY
WE WERE BEEN ABLE TO INCREASE
OUR PHONE CALLS. WE ALSO HAVE
FREE PHONE CALL DAYS. OF BY OUR
VENDOR THAT PROVIDES OUR PHONE
CALLS THEY OFFERED I WANT TO
SAY IT'S AN AVERAGE OF TWO DAYS
PER MONTH THAT I COULDN'T TELL
YOU EXACTLY WHICH DAYS THEY
ARE. BUT THEY'RE TOTALLY FREE
CALLS. AND SO THAT HAS
CERTAINLY HELPED THE
POPULATION. THAT WAS REALLY ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY WE CAME UP
WITH THE TWELVE WEEK POSITIVE
PROGRAMMING CREDIT. WAS TO
REALIZE THAT THE POPULATION HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
KOVIC YOU AND I ARE IMPACTED
EVERY DAY. BY NOT BY OUR DAY TO
DAY LIVES BUT THEY DON'T BUT WE
HAVE OUR FAMILIES THEY DON'T.
AND SO IT'S THAT WAS ONE OF OUR
THOUGHT PROCESSES THAT THEY
BEHAVED. THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR
FAMILY THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR
VISITS THEY DON'T HAVE THE
PROGRAM IS THAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY HAVE. IN SO THAT'S
WHERE WE KIND OF CAME UP WITH
THE WHOLE THOUGHT PROCESS OF
PASTA PROGRAMMING CREDIT. AND
SO IT'S SOMETHING NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART. AND I WANT TO GET
IT FIXED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE TO
ENSURE. THAT FOR THE MIDDLE
HEALTH AS WELL AS JUST THEIR
BASIC WELL BEING- THE
LONELINESS OF KOPET RIGHT
THAT'S A REALITY IT'S LONELY-
WHEN YOU CAN'T LIVE YOUR NORMAL
LIFE SINCE SO WE'RE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO BOB THANK
YOU I'M GIVEN- YOU KNOW I CAN
TELL YOU THIS IS SOMETHING YOU
GIVEN SOME THOUGHT TO AS WELL.
I'M WONDERING I MEAN OBVIOUSLY.
THE RESTRICTIONS ON VISITATION
OF SOMETHING THAT HAD TO BE
IMPLEMENTED TO TRY AND STOP THE
SPREAD OF. THE VIRUS FROM
OUTSIDE THE INSTITUTIONS INTO
THE INSTITUTIONS BUT- I'M
WONDERING OF RAPID TESTING HAS
BEEN LOOKED AT AS A POSSIBLE
SOLUTION TO GETTING. SOME
VISITATION GOING AGAIN BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH THAT'S NOT FROM A
MEDICAL PERSPECTIVE THE MOST
ACCURATE OF TESTED SEEM LIKE TO
BE A USEFUL SCREENING TOOL. TO
ALLOW THESE VISITATIONS TO TAKE
PLACE. I KNOW THAT WE'VE WORKED
VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH PARTNERS AND WE
HAVE AMAZING STAFF I COLOR MY-
MY BFF MY BEST BEST FRIEND
FOREVER. BECAUSE I'VE GOTTEN TO
KNOW OUR DOCTOR OUR SO WELL AND
I THINK SHE TESTIFIED LAST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND SHE'S
PHENOMENAL. ALONG WITH DOCTOR
BACK- WILL BE UP HERE SHORTLY
ADDRESSING THAT. AND I DID GET
THE FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I
I'M NOT A 100% SURE IF THEY
LOOKED AT RAPID TESTING. I WILL
SAY THAT THE AVAILABILITY OF
THE ANTIGENS THAT THE ACTUAL
TEST KITS THEMSELVES HAVE
SOMETIMES BEEN PROBLEMATIC TO
ATTAIN. A AND OPEN UP THOSE FOR
VISITING I DON'T I HONESTLY
DON'T KNOW IF THEY ASSESS THAT
BUT I THINK DOCTOR BIG SEASON
AUDIENCE. AND WILL BE SPEAKING
AT. SHORTLY ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU IT SOUNDS LIKE MORE
OF THE SAME OPINION OF THIS
BUT- IF WE AGREE THAT. OUR GOAL
HERE IS REHABILITATION. THEN I
IT IT'S CLEARLY COUNTER PURPOSE
TO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. TWO OUT TO PREVENT
THIS VISITATION FROM TAKING
PLACE AND- I FOR ONE WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE US GET TO A
POINT WHERE. WE CAN RESTORE
THOSE VISITATION. RIGHTS TO THE
PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR. THANK
YOU. FOR THANK YOU MAY LIVING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HI
SECRETARY ALISON IT'S NICE TO
SEE VIRTUALLY AGAIN WE DON'T
YEAH WE DON'T GET TO MEET A LOT
OF NEW PEOPLE DURING THE
PANDEMIC SO I APPRECIATE- THE
ACCESSIBILITY THAT YOU'VE HAD
FOR. US AND FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY DID I DID WANT TO TALK
ABOUT YOU'D MENTIONED NOT
WANTING TO DIED. COMMENT ON THE
COURTS- DECISION BUT I DO WANT
TO TALK ABOUT- THE VOLUNTARY
TRANSFER. A CHALLENGE THAT YOU
HAVE AND IN PARTICULAR. AT SAN
QUENTIN BUT ALSO HOT AS IT
APPLIES TO OTHER. FACILITIES IT
SEEMS AS THOUGH YOU'VE YOU'VE
OFFERED TRANSFER TO PEOPLE AND
THEY THEY DECLINE IT. AND I
UNDERSTAND THE SAN QUENTIN IS A
DESIRABLE- FACILITY FOR THE
INCARCERATED BECAUSE OF THE
ACCESS TO REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS. IS THE TRANSFERRED
DECLINE RATE AT SAN QUENTIN
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER FACILITIES
OR OR- IS IT MORE IN LINE WITH
OTHER FACILITIES IN THE SYSTEM.
I WILL SAY WERE SUCH IN THE
INFANCY STAGE OF OFFERING THOSE
TRANSFERS I DON'T THINK I COULD
BARELY ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
BUT AS WE GO FORWARD- I WILL
ENSURE THAT WE TRACK SOME DATA
ON THOSE. OKAY YEAH THANK YOU
WE'VE WE'VE ALSO HEARD ABOUT
YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO DOCTOR
BURKE. VERY EARLY ON YEARS AGO
COMMENTING ON HOW PRISON DESIGN
IS NOT MADE WITH A PUBLIC
HEALTH- PERSPECTIVE. AND THAT
THERE CERTAINLY ARE INVESTMENTS
THAT MUST BE MADE AT PRISONS
LIKE FOLSOM AND SAN QUENTIN
THAT ARE ANTIQUATED- BUT ALSO
OTHER PRISONS THAT ARE MORE
DORM LIKE IN THEIR SETTING
WHICH- FROM A- PRISON
MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE MAY BE
DESIRABLE IN IN MODERN
THINKING. AS OPPOSED TO HOW WE
TREATED PEOPLE IN THE PAST WHAT
TYPE OF INVESTMENT WOULD NEED
TO BE MADE SYSTEM WIDE. TO YOU
KNOW BETTER PREPARE FOR. AND
DOMINIC'S AND IN FACT JUST AT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT WERE NEVER
PROBABLY GONNA GO BACK TO A
NORMAL- WITH REGARD TO- HOW WE
NEED TO HOUSE PRISONERS THERE
AND BUT THE POPULATION OF THE
INCARCERATED SHOULD BE.
OBVIOUSLY AS I SAID EARLIER I
DO THINK PHYSICAL PLANT MATTERS
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO SOCIALLY
DISTANCE WITHIN OUR FACILITIES
IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL. YOU
KNOW I'M JUST. I WILL SAY THAT
FORTUNATELY WE WERE NOT AT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND OFFENDERS WHEN CO THAT
HIT. A TRIPLE BONTA GEMS AND
ALL OF OUR HOUSING UNITS. OF
OUR OPEN DOOR HOUSING UNITS
SPECIFICALLY- YOU KNOW
FORTUNATELY WE WERE NOT THERE-
IN OUR POPULATION HAS
DRASTICALLY DROP SINCE
REALIGNMENT PROPOSITION. THIRTY
SIX FORTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN.
DRASTIC REDUCTIONS IN OUR
POPULATION. SO THAT IS
FORTUNATE- I WILL SAY THAT- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO DO SOME LONG
TERM ASSESSMENTS ALL AS FAR AS
OUR FACILITIES. OF THE OPEN
CELL FRONT DESIGNS THE- VERSUS
ALL ITSELF FRONT WE KNOW THAT
THAT MATTERS IN A PANDEMIC- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW OPEN
DORM SETTINGS THAT. YOU KNOW IF
YOU CAN GET SOME DISTANCE IN
BETWEEN THAT MATTERS AS WELL SO
OBVIOUSLY ALL OF THAT GOES INTO
CONSIDERATION AND IF THERE'S
ANY. IT STILL HAS TO BE
ASSESSED AS FAR AS OUR ABILITY
AND- YOU KNOW HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PLACE LIKE SEGWIT LET'S
SAY OR FULSOME. RIGHT I MEAN
MAYBE YOU YOU UTILIZE LOWER
RISK POPULATION. VERSUS A
HIGHER RISK MEDICAL POPULATION-
MAYBE THAT'S AN OPTION I MEAN
WE STILL HAVE TO EVALUATE ALL
THE OPTIONS GO GOING FORWARD
NOW WE HAVE SINCE STOPPED. ALL
HIGH RISK IN TAKEN TO SEGWIT
WITH EXAMPLE QUITS PROBABLY
STILL CLOSED. TO ANY KIND OF
INTAKE BUT DEFINITELY HIGH RISK
MEDICAL INTAKE BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY THE COMBINATION OF HIGH
RISK MEDICAL. PLUS THE PHYSICAL
PLANT SO THAT'S REALLY THE
BIGGEST COMBINATION AND THEN.
DECISION MAKING SO FISCAL PLAN
TO CAPITAL EXPENDITURES THERE'S
NOT GOING TO BE ANY CHANGE AS
WE MOVE INTO THE NEXT BUDGET
CYCLE AS FAR AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE NEED TO PUT THOSE
INVESTMENTS- TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. THOSE ARE STILL UNDER
EVALUATION OKAY THANK YOU. THE
EARLY ON IT AND TO RAISE DR
BURKE'S NAME AGAIN I SPOKE WITH
HIM IN APRIL ASKING FOR SITE
SPECIFIC PLANS FOR ALL OF OUR
PRISON FACILITIES TO PLAN- IN
ANTICIPATION OF- AN OUTBREAK OF
KOBE NINETEEN WITHIN OUR PRISON
SYSTEM IN EACH OF THE THIRTY
FIVE FACILITIES. I WAS REFERRED
TO I THINK AN EIGHTY FOUR PAGE
SYSTEM WIDE PLAN BUT THERE IS
NOTHING SPECIFIC TO ANY
PARTICULAR FACILITY OR PRISON.
IN CALIFORNIA- AND SO I NEVER
REALLY HEARD OF ANY PLAN
ALTHOUGH I CALLED FOR IT-
PRETTY MUCH SHOT. INCESSANTLY
SINCE APRIL UNTIL JULY WHEN
YES- LANDED UPON SAN QUENTIN
STATE PRISON AND CREATED- YOU
KNOW TENTS TO CREATE A SPACE
FOR PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN. AS
WELL AS A PLAN FOR AN ALTERNATE
CARE SITES TO ALLEVIATE
PRESSURE ON LOCAL HOSPITALS
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH. LEVEL OF
HOSPITALIZATION OF THE
INCARCERATED. IN LOCAL BAY AREA
HOSPITALS. AND SO IN IN THE
PRIOR CONVERSATION THIS TWO OF
US HAD. YOU HAD SURE THAT EVERY
PRISON FACILITY NOW HAS BEEN.
MEASURED IN SIZE STOP AND THE
TYPES OF TENTS THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE AND SPACES FOR
ALTERNATE CARE HAVE BEEN
EVALUATED AND SO ALL THIRTY
FIVE. PRISON FACILITIES DO HAVE
PLANS TO MANAGE AND MITIGATE
AND AN OUTBREAK OF COVER
NINETEEN. SO WE'VE IDENTIFIED
ISOLATION QUARANTINE SPACES
THAT EACH AND EVERYONE OF OUR
THIRTY FIVE FACILITIES. IN
ADDITION TO VERY SPECIFIC
FACILITIES WE'VE HAD FIRE
MARSHAL AS WELL AS ATTEND
MANUFACTURE GO OUT AND PROVIDE
ASSESSMENT SO WHERE THEY PUT.
AN ALTERNATE HOUSING SITE
FORTUNATELY THE MAJORITY OF OUR
GYM SPACES AROUND THE STATE
HAVE HAVE NO LONGER- ARE NOT
OCCUPIED FOR CURRENT HOUSING
BUT ARE AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING.
A POTENTIAL OPTIONS SO- THERE
ARE CONTINGENCY PLANS I WILL
SAY EARLY ON ALL OF US- WE'RE
ALL FOLLOWING THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL GUIDELINES AS
IT RELATED TO- PRISONS AND
JAILS WITHIN OUR SYSTEM BUT I
WILL SAY THAT WE'VE EVEN LEARN
MORE. THAN WHAT THAT THAT
ORIGINAL GUIDANCE HAT AND MANY
STATES LOOK TO US FOR THE
LESSONS THAT WE'VE LEARNED I
GET CALLS FREQUENTLY. ON HOW
HOW ARE YOU GUYS HOW ARE YOU
HANDLING COBIT IN YOUR SYSTEM-
SO WE SHARE ALL OF OUR LESSONS.
LEARNED WITH AROUND THE NATION.
HI YOU SECOND. ON ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT REALLY WAS A
CONCERN EARLY ON THIS IS WHY I
SPOKE WITH CDCR IN APRIL AND
KEPT ON WAVING- WARNING FLAGS
ABOUT THIS WAS THE- CONCERN FOR
HOSPITALIZATION NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF AN OUTBREAK IN
PRISONS BUT SO THAT WAS A
CONCERN NATIONWIDE ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAD ENOUGH I SEE
USE ENOUGH. VENTILATORS THIS
WAS A MASSIVE CONCERN GLOBALLY
AND- AND SO ALONG WITH
MEASURING FOR TENTS AND CARE
SITES AND QUARANTINE- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A HOSPITALIZATION PLAN
AS- MISTER TEEN HAD NOTED- THE
INCARCERATED FROM SAN QUENTIN
ENDED UP. GOING TO HOSPITALS
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA
PRIMARILY- OF COURSE IN THE
NORTH BAY BUT ALSO IN IN MR
KING'S DISTRICT AND THEN OF
COURSE SPREAD ACROSS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS THERE A PLAN FOR
HOSPITALIZATION FOR EACH OF THE
THIRTY FIVE FACILITIES. I WOULD
HAVE TO DEFER TO EITHER MR
KELSO OR DOCTOR BACK ON THAT
ISSUE I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
VERY. STRONG UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT UNIT THAT HAS ALL
THE BEDS AVAILABLE AROUND THE
STATE BUT IT'S REALLY NOT FOR
ME TO DISCUSS THAT OKAY I'D BE
GLAD TO HEAR FROM THEM ABOUT
THAT- IT. ADDITIONALLY. AND I
WANNA I WANNA MAYBE I'LL SAVE
MY NEXT COMMENT FOR WHEN MR
KELSO APPEARS AGAIN THANK YOU.
OKAY OKAY SO HE'S- MISTER TIM
JUST TOLD ME I'M I'M ABLE TO
ASK. WHILE YOU'RE ON THAT THE
CAMERA SO THAT'S FINE. MR CALL
SO HAD- STATED IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS. ABOUT HIS
UNDERSTANDING OF CODED NINETEEN
AND KIND OF THE- MEDICAL
UNDERSTANDING OF CODE NINETEEN
AND HOW IT COULD SPREAD. AND
HOW TESTING SHOULD BE CONDUCTED
HI HI MR CALLS TO GET TO SEE
YOU AGAIN- AND SO I WANTED TO
JUST. KIND OF CHECK IN ON THAT
THINKING BECAUSE- THAT'S IT'S
NOT THE WAY THAT I REMEMBER-
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF COVE ED IN
PARTICULAR IN PARTICULAR. THOSE
WITH EXPERTISE EXPERTISE IN
EPIDEMIOLOGY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SO I REMEMBER
EXTRAORDINARILY VIVIDLY THE
NIGHT OF THE TRANSFER TO SAN
QUENTIN FROM CHINO- I WAS IN
THE STATE CAPITAL LATE THAT
EVENING- I RECEIVED A PHONE
CALL FROM MY PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER FOR MARIN COUNTY DR
MATT WILLIS WHO'S BEEN. A
GUIDING LIGHT ON UNDERSTANDING
COVET NINETEEN FOR ME AND FOR
MANY IN MY COMMUNITY AND HE HE
UNDERSTOOD THE GRAVITY OF THE
SITUATION- THAT NIGHT AS PEOPLE
WERE COMING IN- ON THE BUSES
SYMPTOMATIC. AND WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT TESTS HAD NOT
OCCURRED FOR WEEKS. AND THE
DANGER THAT THIS SPARK. WOULD
CREATE AT THE DISTANT
INCREDIBLE AN UNMANAGEABLE
WILDFIRE IN FACT DR WILSON'S
CONCERNS BECAUSE OF THE SCIENCE
BEHIND HIM TO UNDERSTAND THE
SCIENCE BEHIND COVER NINETEEN.
WORD THE MOTIVATION BETWEEN BUT
BEHIND MY EARLY CALLS FOR
PLANNING BACK IN APRIL BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTOOD HOW CODE NINETEEN
COULD SPREAD LIKE WILDFIRE AND
SO. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PUSH BACK MR KELSO ON YOUR
COMMENTS NOT A TESTING
PROTOCOLS- IN UNDERSTANDING OF
WHETHER OR NOT- VAPOR DROPLETS
VERSUS- SOLICITATION- WERE
UNDERSTOOD WELL BECAUSE WHEN I
TALK TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER I TRUSTED BACK THEN HE
UNDERSTOOD IT QUITE CLEARLY.
WELL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR THE QUESTION- I THINK IF
YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT ON THE
GENERAL UNDERSTANDING OF
THROUGH MARCH APRIL MAY. JUNE
PERHAPS I THINK WHAT THE RECORD
SHOWS IS THAT THERE WERE
GLOBALLY- ONLY ISOLATED-
EXAMPLES WHERE YOU COULD SAY
WELL THAT COULDN'T HAVE BEEN BY
DROPLETS SPREAD. I THINK
EVERYBODY MAY RECALL THERE WAS
A ON AN EXAMPLE OF A SPREAD IN
A RESTAURANT. WHERE THE PERSON
WENT UP AFFECTED WAS. ACROSS
THE RESTAURANT AND I HAD
OTHERWISE HAD NO CONTACT. BUT
THE NOTION OF SUPERSPRINT OR
EVENTS I WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT
WAS BEING- DISCUSSED WIDELY- IN
MARCH APRIL MAY UP. AND I GUESS
ALTHOUGH WHAT I. IT'S FAIR FOR
ME TO SAY I DIDN'T MAKE THIS UP
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S THE- THE
EPIDEMIOLOGY OF THE SPREAD OF
CODE I'M RELYING UPON AND WAS
THEN RELYING UPON ADVICE OF OUR
TOP MEDICAL LEADERSHIP.
INCLUDING PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS- I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
THERE WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF AEROSOL SPREAD.
OUT BUT I SIMPLY DON'T- MY
RECOLLECTION IS DIFFERENT THAN
YOURS- MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT
AT LEAST AS OF MAY THAT WAS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WAS WIDELY
RECOGNIZED- IN ANY EVENT- THE
WEATHER WAS OR WAS NOT WIDELY
RECOGNIZED WHAT HAPPENED IN SAN
QUENTIN I WAS A DISASTER AND I
THINK YOU AND I AGREE ON ON
THAT- AND WE NEED TO LEARN THE
LESSONS FROM THAT. UP GOING
BACK YOUR HOSPITALIZATION
QUESTION THE QUICK ANSWER THERE
IS YES WE HAVE FOR EACH
INSTITUTION THEY UNDERSTAND
WHERE. THEIR HOSPITAL RESOURCES
ARE. EVEN WITH CENTERPOINT THE
FOR THAT WE MOVE TO A HOUSE UP
ALONG THE I. EIGHTY CORDER-
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS A
PART OF A- OF A PLAN FOR WHEN
YOU HAVE THIS NUMBER OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS YOU DON'T
WANNA OVER BURDEN- EVERYBODY IN
THE BAY AREA. YOU HAVE TO START
MOVING UP THE CORNER- MA'AM WE
MONITOR AVAILABILITY OF
HOSPITAL BEDS AND ICU BEDS ARE
PRETTY MUCH ON A DAILY BASIS-
BECAUSE THAT IS A LIMITING
RESOURCE- THAT WE SHARE WITH
THE COMMUNITY. I THINK THANK
YOU MISTER CALCITE I'LL JUST
CONTINUE TO PUSH BACK ON THE
IDEA THAT WE DIDN'T THINK THAT
WE NEED TO DO MORE FREQUENT
TESTING AND THAT SAN QUENTIN
COULD HAVE BEEN. IN A PROVIDE
SERVICE FOR PUTTING ONE TO BE
AFTER WITH KOBE NINETEEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I AGREE WITH
YOU THE WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING WAS TESTING WITH THEM
AT THE TIME OF THE MOVE TO SAN
QUENTIN. TESTING NO LONGER THAN
SEVEN DAYS BEFORE I AGREE WITH
THAT COMPLETELY. THE AND THE
CURRENT RULE THE CURRENT ROLE
WE HAVE IS YOU HAVE TO BE
TESTED WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS
OF THE MOVE. I AGREE WITH YOU
ON THAT POINT THANK YOU AND I
AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR RADIC
WHAT I CALL RADICALLY CO
HOARDING PEOPLE ISOLATING THEM
AFTER THOSE TESTS BEFORE ANY
TYPE OF MOVEMENT. THE WITH
SOMETHING THAT ALARMED ME YOU
KNOW LATE STAGES OF THE SPREAD
OF COVERT NINETEEN AT SAN
QUENTIN. WAS THE UTILIZATION OF
NINE ONE ONE. TO CALL FOR AN
AMBULANCE FOR- FOR EMERGENCIES-
AT THE PRISON. AND THAT- IN
THAT IT TOOK A WHILE. FOR A
MORE REGULAR MANAGEABLE SYSTEM.
TO BE UTILIZED- AND INSTITUTED.
BESIDES JUST CALLING NINE ONE
ONE FOR AN AMBULANCE TO SHOW UP.
LET ME LOOK AT DOCTOR BACK HERE
WHO IS OVER THE SCREEN- ARE
WHAT WE USE NINE ONE ONE
ROUTINELY AROUND THE STATE
DON'T WE TALKED A BIT. YES.
AMERICORPS SURE THERE ARE A
REACH THE ZERO ARE. YEAH THAT
ACTUALLY BUT THE MAKES A YOU
PROBABLY COULDN'T HEAR OF
UTILIZATION OF MINE WERE ONE IS
WE DO STATE BECAUSE IT'S IN THE
BEST WAY OF ENSURING THAT OUR
PATIENTS GET- BUT BOTH PROBABLY
PICKED UP AND DELIVERED TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM SURE AND IN AT
WHAT POINT DO YOU. YOU KNOW
CREATE A DIFFERENT SYSTEM A
MORE EFFECTIVE SYSTEM BECAUSE
AS I UNDERSTOOD THE LOCAL
HOSPITALS WERE OVERWHELMED WITH
THE CALLS FOR SERVICE LOCAL
EMERGENCY FIRST RESPONDERS WERE
OVERWHELMED YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
EMERGENCIES ON A DAILY BASIS.
IN THE COMMUNITY. THAT THESE
AMBULANCES WOULD OTHERWISE BE
SERVICE SCENE BUT YOU KNOW
TWELVE PLUS TIMES A DAY. GOING
TO SAN QUENTIN WAS. A BURDEN
BOTH ON THE HOSPITALS BUT ON ON
COMMUNITY FIRST RESPONDERS SO
HOW DO WE PLAN AND FOR PLANNING
FOR HOSPITALIZATION FOR
PLANNING FOR. ADEQUATE SPACE
SEEN AN ALTERNATE CARE SITES IN
OUR PRISON FACILITIES HOW DO WE
ALSO PLAN FOR THOSE CALLS FOR
FOUR FIRST RESPONDERS IN THESE-
HI CALL. IT'S THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND ON
THAT ONE I DO WANT TO CONSULT
WITH DOCTOR BACK ON AND IT OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AS WELL
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH BECAUSE THAT RELATES TO
OVERALL UTILIZATION OF
HOSPITALS AND I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT IS- AND ARE PARTICULARLY
VERY LARGE OUTBREAKS SOME OF
THEM WE DON'T HAVE VERY :Y
HOSPITALIZATIONS AT ALL. OTHERS
WE HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS SURE AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN THAT
ARE RIGHT NOW- WE DON'T HAVE A
SURGE CAPACITY OTHER VAN NINE
ONE ONE. AND WE MAY BE
OURSELVES OVERWHELMING THE NINE
ONE ONE RESOURCES SO I WON-
RAISE THAT ISSUE WITH MY TEAM
AND WE'LL GET BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CALL SO THIS WAS A
HUGE A MASSIVE CONCERN ONE
BECAUSE OF COURSE- SECOND STATE
PRISON IS SERVICED BY THE
NEAREST HOSPITAL MARIN HEALTH
MEDICAL CENTER WHICH WAS.
GREATLY OVERBURDENED- WITH VERY
FEW FEW BEDS AVAILABLE TO THE
COMMUNITY LET ALONE A COMMUNITY
SPREAD EVENT AND A PRISON
SPREAD EVENT. ABOUT THAT THEY
THEN NEEDED TO COORDINATE WITH
THE OTHER COMMUNITY HOSPITALS
AROUND MARIN COUNTY AND THEN OF
COURSE INTO SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY AND- AND OTHER
NEIGHBORING. HERBAL COMMUNITY
IN IN BOTH IN THE COUNTY BUT
ALSO BECAUSE OF AGE ALSO IN IN
THE STATE PRISON. THAT PERHAPS
IS NOT AS BAD AT OTHER PRISONS
OF COURSE WE HAD A HUGE. SPREAD
OF KOBE NINETEEN AB AND ALL
WHICH DID NOT GET. THE
ATTENTION THAT IT PROBABLY
DESERVED- FOR MANY DIFFERENT
REASONS- BUT- BUT PERHAPS WHAT
DIDN'T HAVE AS HIGH A
PERCENTAGE OF MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE. PEOPLE WHO- DID END
UP WITH COVETED THE THESE HAVE
TO BE PART OF. OF THE OF THE
HOSPITALIZATION PLANS REACH
PRESENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR READY. THANK
YOU AND- MY QUESTION IS CAN BE
FOR SECRETARY ALLISON BUT I'M
GOING TO USE IF I MAY UM
RECEIVER KELSO'S- HANDOUT AND
WHILE I HAVE YOU FOR A SECOND.
MR CAL SO I ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN.
IT'S A PAINTING MEETING YOU FOR
A WHILE I WORK IN THE HEALTH
INSURANCE SPACE AND REALLY
WANTED TO TALK WITH YOU AT SOME
POINT OFFLINE ABOUT HOW WE CAN
MEET THE NEEDS OF- CALIFORNIANS
BUT REALLY WANTED ACTUALLY
THANK YOU FOR THE DATA THAT
COMES IN YOUR HAND I'M ONE OF
THOSE WHO LOVES READING AND
GETTING INTO THE DETAILS. AND
YOU PROVIDE A LAYER OF
GRANULARITY THAT'S ACTUALLY
YOUR BOARD THAT I THINK IS
QUITE IMPORTANT AND I DIDN'T
WANT TO MISS A THEME OR A
THOUGHT THAT YOU HIGHLIGHTED IN
YOUR PAPER WHICH IS THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OPEN. CELLS
AND THOSE THAT ARE CLOSED AND
SO WHAT WE'VE SEEN AS THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN THOSE OPEN CELLS
WE'VE SEEN 81% OF THE DEATHS
HAVE OCCURRED IN THOSE CELLS
AND 84% OF THE DEATHS PER YEAR
DATA HAVE OCCURRED WHEN WE HAVE
A CO OP ED REST OR GREATER THAN
THREE. NOW YOUR CONCLUSION IS
THAT WE SHOULD BE TRANSFERRING
THOSE- PEOPLE WHO HAVE COVERED
RISK OR GREATER THAN THREE.
INTO CLOSED CELLS WHETHER OR
NOT THAT AT THE INSTITUTION ARE
WITHIN THE INSTITUTIONS. AND MY
QUESTION FOR SECRETARY ALISON
IS. OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
BEEN FOLLOWED IS THIS SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ACTIVELY WORKING ON. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
MEETING WITH YOU AND- MY OFFICE
WILL BE IN TOUCH WITH YOURS I
THINK I CAN ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION- THE- CDCR HAS AGREED
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION TO-
OFFER A MOVE TO THOSE HIGH RISK
PATIENTS. SO THAT WE CAN GIVE
THEM AS MANY OF OUR WILLING OUT
OF THE DORMS AND OPEN US SELL
FRONTS- INTO SAFER HOUSING AND-
WE HAVE A TEAM OF. BOTH CDCR
AND CCHS HAS A TEAM THAT IS
WORKING- ON PLANNING HOW TO DO
THOSE MOVES ARE IT IS A CONCERN
I'LL BET IT WOULD INVOLVE
MOVING A LOT OF PATIENCE. AND
GIVEN THE EXPERIENCE FROM SEE I
AM THE SAN QUENTIN EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THESE PLAN ON THE MOVES
CAUSES. ME TO HAVE A SLEEPLESS
NIGHT- BUT I THINK OVERALL. IT
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER FOR THESE
PATIENTS IF THEY WERE MOVES. TO
ANOTHER LOCATION. AND YOUR DATA.
ROUGHLY THERE'S A TWO. PEOPLE
WHO KNEW TO BE MADE. AND AS WE
SEE THAT- COVERT MIRRORS WHAT
OCCURS IN GENERAL SOCIETY THE
FEAR IS AS WE GO INTO THIS DARK
WINTER. THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO
HAVE ANOTHER OUTBREAK AND SO I
WOULD JUST. YEAH EMPHASIZE THAT
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE FOR US
TO GET AHEAD OF THIS. MAKE SURE
WE'RE HOUSING PEOPLE ON THE
APPROPRIATE SUBSTANCE. YEAH I
AGREE WITH THAT AND I BELIEVE
WE'RE STARTING WITH- OF THE
EVEN THE HIGHER REAL THE SIX.
LITTLE THE RISK FOR SIX AND
ABOVE I BELIEVE WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THOSE AND GO BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE MOST AT RISK ARE
DATA IS VERY CLEAR. THAT THE
HIGHER YOUR RISK SCORE THE MORE
LIKELY IT IS THAT IFYOU GET
OPEN- YOU YOU YOU HAVE A HIGHER
DEATH RATE. I'D LOVE TO FOLLOW
UP WITH OUR OFFICE DOES WITH
MINE REGARDING THE EXACT-
DETAILS OF THAT CODE WOULD RISK
SCORE I'M INTERESTED ACTUALLY
TO. FIGURE OUT OF FOR USING IT
ANOTHER CONGREGATE SETTINGS
LIKE SNAPS SO WOULD LOVE TO.
INFORMATION THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU BURKE MISTER. JUST
FOLLOWING UP FOR I GUESS THE
SECRETARY ON THIS ISSUE- GOING
BACK TO PATIENTS WITH THIS
RESTORE THREE OR HIGHER NOW
MISTER KELSO JUST TALKED ABOUT
IT BUT THEY'RE GIVEN THE OPTION
TO MOVE. WHY IS IT OPTIONAL AND
NOT MANDATORY IT SEEMS TO ME
THE SAFETY OF BOTH THE PATIENT
AND REDUCING THE RISK OF SPREAD
TO OTHERS IN THE FACILITY STATE
PRIORITY. OVER THE CONVENIENCE
OF THE PATIENT IN MAY. SO WE'RE
STARTING WITH. WITH MAKING IT
OPTIONAL- AT THIS POINT IN TIME
I WILL SAY THAT INMATES GET
MOVED AROUND THE STATE EVERY
SINGLE DAY INVOLUNTARY. SO
WE'RE TRYING THAT KIND OF THE
SOFTER GENTLER APPROACH OF
TRYING TO A PATIENT EDUCATE AND
TRAIN THAT THE OFFENDERS
UNDERSTAND THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THEIR OWN HEALTH. MODE THE HOW
DO I SAY THIS IT'S ONLY
SPECIFIC INSTITUTIONS THAT WITH
THE RICHNESS OF PROGRAM DON'T
WANT TO. SO IT'S A BECOME POP
ART CONNOR TO TRYING GET THAT
SAME BRIDGES APPROACH. ERROR
LOCATIONS SO THAT IT'S THE SAME
SAME FOR THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE JUST IN
THEIR HEALTH NEEDS AS WELL AS A
PROGRAM NEEDS. NUMBER ONE YOU
SEE IMAGE GET MOVED EVERYDAY
LEVELS OF DISCIPLINARY PROBLEMS
HERE WE HAVE A PANDEMIC WITH A
LOT OF ISSUES AND YOU GUYS ARE
SECOND ONLY THE SNIFFS. IN
NUMBER OF DEATHS SO. HELP ME
UNDERSTAND WHY MAKING OPTIONAL
NOT MANDATORY TO HELP DEFEAT
THIS PURPOSE OF THIS SITUATION
AFTER ALL YOU ARE THE SECRETARY
SALUTE TO MENTALLY YOU HAVE TO
SAY SO IN THAT SO HELP ME
FIGURE OUT WHY YOU'RE NOT
MAKING THAT MANDATORY VERSUS AN
OPTION TO THESE FOLKS. BECAUSE
OF HELP STOP TO HELP THIS
PREDICT THAT THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE SO I WAS THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THEIR SITUATION.
THEY MAY NOT WHILE THE FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS. BUT
MEDICALLY IF THAT CAN PREVENT
THAT PERSON FROM YOU'LL
ACQUIRING COBIT AND KEEP
MAINTAIN THEIR HEALTH. WHY WE
NOT MAKE THE MOVE. SO I JUST
WANT TO- CLARK WNTS TO MAKE A
COMMENT TO THAT BECAUSE THAT
WAS HIS ONE OF HIS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MAKE IT
VOLUNTARY PENSION EDUCATE
CORRECT BUT BUILT IN NINETY
MINUTES. NO NO JUST ONE SECOND
ALTERNATELY AS THE SECRETARY.
IT'S YOUR CHOICE I MEAN I GUESS
I GET I GET CARP CLARK'S
POSITION. IS THE- IS YOU
WHATEVER THE- RECEIVER I GET
THAT. BUT ON THAT ISSUE YOU
HAVE THE ULTIMATE SAY SO IN
THAT. IN MY NAME IS THAT
CORRECT IF I'M WRONG TELL ME SO.
OKAY IN. TYPICALLY THAT WOULD
BE CORRECT IN A CO THAT
ENVIRONMENT AS OF APRIL. OF
TWENTY TWENTY MR KELSO DRAFTED
A MEMO TO THE THEN SECRETARY MR
DEUS THAT HE- THAT ALL MOVEMENT
WITHIN THE FACILITIES WILL BE
GOVERNED BY THE RECEIVERS.
HEALTH CARE POPULATION
MANAGEMENT UNIT OKAY SO OUT OF
OUT OF ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION WE
DEFER TO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS AS IT RELATES TO MOVES
WITHIN OUR FACILITIES. NOW YOU
ARE CORRECT IN THE FACT THAT IF
I NEED TO MOVE SOMEBODY I WOULD
CONSULT WITH THE RECEIVERS
OFFICE AND WE WERE TRYING TO
GET BY. WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN TO
THE POINT AND I WOULD HAVE TO
MESSAGE THIS VERY VERY CLEARLY.
IF WE HAD TO DO MOVES AND DO
YOU CAN UTILIZE FORCE IN ORDER
TO DO THOSE MOVES. RIGHT THAT
ALSO BECOMES DANGEROUS AND SO
RIGHT NOW AND I'M ELECT CLARK
SPEAK TO IT. BUT THE DECISION
WAS MADE TO AFFORD THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE OUTCOMES OF ANY
REFUSAL RIGHT THAT'S WHY I
THOUGHT. EARLIER COMMENT WAS
WELL WILL TAKE AND WE NEED TO
COLLECT DATA ON THOSE REFUSALS
AND FIGURE OUT A WAY TO ADDRESS
THOSE REFUSALS. SHORT OF
UTILIZING FORCE TO DO IT BUT
BEING I GUESS IT COMES BACK TO
BEING NINE MONTHS INTO THIS. AT
SOME POINT THE REST OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SOMEONE'S GONNA
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT
HAPPENED TO IT IN. RIGHT NOW.
RAMOS MIDWAY NOVEMBER. SO RAMOS
IS THIS SOME POPULOUS INTO THIS
AND WE'RE STILL TRYING TO TAKE
A DOG CHASING ITS TAIL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER IF I
MIGHT. THE VIDEO- THE REASON TO
DO THE MOVES OUT OF DORMS AND A
SAFER HOUSING IS NOT BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO SLOW THE SPREAD.
THE REASON TO THE MOVIES
BECAUSE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUAL
PATIENTS IT IMPROVES THEIR IT
REDUCES THEIR RISK OF DEATH.
AND THAT MEANS THAT THE MOVE IS
VERY MUCH AN INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
CARE DECISION BY EACH PATIENT
AND IN CDC ARE- WE ARE VERY
PROTECTIVE OF LETTING OUR
PATIENTS A MAKE THEIR OWN
HEALTH CARE DECISIONS UNDER AND
THEN. CONSENT RATIONALE NOW I
THINK IF IT TURNS OUT THAT
ALMOST NOBODY WANTS TO DO A
MOVIE WE WILL RECONSIDER
WHETHER A BILL SHOULD BE
VOLUNTARY OR NOT. OR FOR
EXAMPLE IN SAND POINT WHERE AT
THIS POINT THE COURT ORDER SAYS
YOU NEED TO REDUCE THE
POPULATION TO UP SLOW THE
SPREAD OF. WELL THE SET HAS
MOVED OUT OF SAN QUENTIN MIGHT
PRESENT A DIFFERENT. THE
RATIONALE WHERE THERE IT MAY BE
THE INVOLUNTARY MOVES MAKE A
GREATER DEAL OF SENSE BUT BUT
THAT'S WHY WE STARTED WITH THE
NOTION OF INVOLUNTARY AYE I
SHOULD ALSO ADD- WE NEED TO BE
DOING THINGS OF THAT. GENERATE
TRUST THAT OUR PATIENTS WILL
TRUST US WHEN WE SAY THIS IS
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN. AND IT
SEEMS TO US THAT MAKING THIS
THIS PROGRAM VOLUNTARY IS A WAY
OF HELPING TO BUILD SOME
UNDERSTANDING AND TRUST. AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT ONE OF AXING COMES
ON- BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO OVERCOME RESISTANCE.
THAT EXISTS WITHIN OUR PATIENT
POPULATION TO TAKING VACCINES.
SO IT IT IT'S A MULTI FACETED
DECISION- I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERNS THOUGH AND MY HEALTH
TEAM IS LISTENING TO THIS
HEARING. SO I'M SURE THAT-
THEY'LL BE SOME RECONSIDERATION
OF OUR POSITION THANK YOU MR
COLOSSAL SO HOW LONG HAS IT
BEEN OPTIONAL FOR THEM. WELL
THIS THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM IS
JUST STANDING UP WITHIN THE
LAST THREE OR FOUR WEEKS. AND
AT WHAT POINT DO YOU ANTICIPATE
IF YOU DON'T HAVE PEOPLE THAT
TRANSFER THAT YOU WILL MAKE IT
MANDATORY. I DON'T HAVE A
SCHEDULE FOR THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IT'S UP THERE THAT'S
GOING TO DEPEND ON HOW QUICKLY
WE CAN STAY ON THE PROGRAM UP
AND THEN HOW. QUICKLY A WERE
ABLE TO- EDUCATE ALL OF OUR
PATIENTS OF WITH THE HELP OF
THEIR LEGAL REPRESENTATIVES THE
PRISON LAW OFFICE- AND GET
DECISIONS I DON'T HAVE A
TIMETABLE WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
BECAUSE IT IS A DARK WINTER
THERE WERE FACING SO WE'RE
TALKING POSSIBLY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND NOT THAT LONG NO I HAVE
NOT- BUT THIS MOVE PROGRAM HAS
TO. MAKE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
WITHIN THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS.
OKAY THIS THOUGHT IS NOT MY
GUESS MY LAST THIS POLICY THAT
YOU'VE GOT OF THE SITE ON. THE
PATHWAY. INSTEAD OF MAKING IT
MANDATORY MAKE DOING OPTIONAL
THING THAT THAT'S THE PATH
YOU'VE CHOSEN CORRECT. YES.
THANK YOU ALL NEED OF MY ONLY
ADVICE OF MY A MEDICAL
LEADERSHIP AND PUBLIC HEALTH-
EMMETT IS A TOPIC OF KONKAN
GENUINE CONVERSATION LOW-
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THE
PROBLEM THAT IF YOU MAKE A
VOLUNTARY AND THERE ARE TOO
MANY PEOPLE WHO REFUSE- WE'VE
GOT A PROBLEM NOW WE DID HAVE A
SIMILAR SORT OF MOVES VERY
RECENTLY- AND I BELIEVE IT WAS-
CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION.
FACILITY C. R. C. WAY ARE THEY
WERE VERY SIX IN GETTING PEOPLE
OF OUT OF IN INTO ATTEMPTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PLACED ON THE GROUND
SO YOU KNOW IT MAY BE THAT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE THIS
PROBLEM OF A HIGH REFUSAL RATE-
BUT I THINK WE WANT TO GIVE OUR
PATIENTS A CHANCE TO MAKE THE
FIRST DECISION. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER COUNCIL HAVE A GREAT
DEAL OF RESPECT FOR YOU AND ALL
YOU'VE DONE I GUESS IT'S JUST A
PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREEMENT ON.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE AT RISK. YOU
KNOW WHO'S TO BETTER TO MAKE
THAT DECISION. THOSE FOLKS ARE
THE FOLKS WITH THE MEDICAL
KNOWLEDGE IN DOING THAT I THINK
SOMETIMES THEY WE GIVE TOO MUCH
LEEWAY AND WE JUST DO WHAT'S
MAYBE NOT THE POPULAR THING AND
MAKE PEOPLE DO THINGS. BUT WE
DON'T DO THAT IS TO THE
SOCIETIES OF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTIN NOW FOR A GREAT PRICE
THE IDEA OF A COUPLE QUESTIONS-
IS OUR IG STILL THERE. BUT HE'S
A DIFFERENT ALSO YES YES I'M
STILL HERE WONDERFUL COULD
COULD YOU TALK US THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT OF YOUR FINDINGS I
THINK. THE SECRETARY MENTIONED
THAT SHE FOUND THEM HELPFUL OF
THE CAN YOU KIND OF GIVE US A
SENSE OF THE- A BETTER SENSE OF
THE TIMING BECAUSE- IT IS A
LITTLE BIT SURPRISING THAT WERE
IN OCTOBER AND A STATE AGENCY.
WOULD HAVE TO REITERATE WHAT
APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN. FURLEY
COMMON KNOWLEDGE NOT JUST
WITHIN THE STATE- AGENCIES BUT
WITHIN ALSO THE PUBLIC WHERE
WE'VE KNOWN FOR NOT JUST WEEKS
BUT MONTHS THAT WEARING MASKS
ARE CRITICAL TO STOPPING THE
SPREAD OF. UVID SO. WHEN YOU
HAVE AN AGENCY- YOU KNOW ONE OF
TWO PLACES WILL SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND STATE PRISONS
BEING PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE SPREAD. OF FOR THE SPREAD
OF CALLED IT IN FOR THE MAIN
SOURCE OF DEATHS OF CORPORATE
WITHIN THE STATE. YOU TO HELP
US UNDERSTAND HOW THAT WASN'T
CLEAR TO THIS PARTICULAR AGENCY
AND WHY IN YOUR OPINION IT
WASN'T BEING IMPLEMENTED. THREE
THE FREE SCORING ISSUE WAS.
WELL FIRST OF ALL OUR OUR- THE
AREA THAT WE THE TIME PERIOD
THAT WE LOOKED AT WAS A
PARTICULAR TIME PERIOD AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS EVOLVED SINCE THEN. BOB BUT
OF WHAT WE FOUND HIM AND ALL I
CAN COULD COULD YOU RESTATE AS
WELL. COULD YOU RESTATE THE
TIME PERIOD JUST FOR EVERYBODY.
YEAH WE START ROUGHLY- IN MARCH
TWO TWENTY TWENTY TWO ROUGHLY
JULY. TWENTY TWENTY. OUR OUR
METHODOLOGY NECESSARILY
REQUIRES US TO GATHER DATA AND
DATA TIME PERIOD AND THEN DRAW
THE CONCLUSIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
DATA IS TELLING US SO. WE WERE
AWARE AND HONESTLY I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT WAS AWARE THAT THE
ONLY GIRL IN THEIR QUIVER FOR-
THAT WAS THAT WAS PROVEN TO
HELP STOP THE SPREAD WAS THE
WEAR MASKS HOWEVER I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE- US DEPARTMENT
MANAGEMENT- I KNOW THAT THE
THAT THE HEADQUARTERS
LEADERSHIP. UNDERSTOOD THIS BUT
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT EVER GOT
DOWN TO THE LOCAL SUPERVISORS
AT- AT AND THE WORDS THAT THIS
WAS A SERIOUS ISSUE THAT THEY
NEEDED TO RESOLVE IN FACT ONE
COMMENT WE HAVE. AND I'LL READ
IT- ONE COMMENT FROM A STAFF
MEMBER AT ONE OF THE PRISONS IN
RESPONSE TO OUR SURVEY WAS THE
MAJORITY OF CUSTODY STAFF
REFUSED TO WEAR PP EVAN WHEN
THIS WAS REPORTED TO
SUPERVISORS THEIR REPEATED
RESPONSE WAS THAT THE MANDATES
WERE UNDER FOR UNENFORCEABLE.
BECAUSE THESE WERE ADULTS. HI I
AM AT A LOSS TO UNDERSTAND WHY.
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE- HAVE
GENERATED- A MORE SERIOUS
RESPONSE BUT IN FACT EVEN IN
SOME TO SOME OF THE WORDS THAT
I SPOKE PERSONALLY TO. THEY
DIDN'T TAKE THE SAME THEY DID
TAKE THIS UP WITH THE SAME
SERIOUSNESS THAT I THINK A LOT
OF THE- OF HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
AND CERTAINLY OF THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE ISSUE-
TOOK IT- I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
THERE WAS. OF A LOT OF.
UNDERSTANDING OR ACCEPTANCE
THAT MASKS WERE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS. AND OF. I DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT ELSE TO TELL
YOU ABOUT IN THE MIDDLE WELL
LET ME LET ME HAVE AS THE
RESULTS BUT WE REALLY DIDN'T
BEGIN TO WATER. ONE SECOND
YOU'RE I MEAN I'M I'M ASKING
YOUR OPINION WHY RIGHT I MEAN
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE. ON WITH THE SYSTEM
AND THE FACILITIES. I'M JUST
GONNA JUMP OFF YOUR QUOTE
BECAUSE I APPRECIATE THE-
QUESTIONS MY COLLEAGUE MEL
GROVE US. ON IT IS IT IS IT IN
YOUR OPINION. THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DIFFICULTY
ENFORCING RULES WITH ADULTS. NO
I DON'T THINK THEY I DON'T
THINK THEY DO I THINK THERE ARE
SOME. ISSUES THAT THEY ARE VERY
CLEAR AND VERY ABLE TO ENFORCE.
ARE THERE ARE ALSO SOME ISSUES
THAT THEY SIMPLY DON'T LOOK AT
WITH THE SAME SERIOUSNESS THAT-
THAT WE MIGHT LOOK AT IT MY
OFFICE FOR. SO RIGHT. MY
IMPRESSION AND PERHAPS MY
IMPRESSIONS INCORRECT RIGHT. IS
THESE ARE FACILITIES WHERE
THERE ARE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF RULES IF YOU GO TO PRISON
BECAUSE FREEDOM IS RESTRICTED
NOT BECAUSE YOU HAVE. GOTTEN
INCREASE LIBERTY YOU'VE YOU
LOSS OF LIBERTY AND FREEDOM SO
I AM STILL TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. HOW THIS MAJOR
RULED THAT WE ENFORCE OF THE
PUBLIC RIGHT WITH IF THE PUBLIC
WANTS TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS WHICH THEY
HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO DO. IF THEY
WANT TO DO IT IN PERSON.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO COME
INTO THE CAPITOL BUILDING
WITHOUT A MASK. AND THAT HAS AS
AS SOON AS WE CAME BACK AND
REOPEN THE CAPITAL I BELIEVE IN
EARLY. MAY THAT WAS. THAT WAS
SO THE PROTOCOL. LET ME ASK A
DIFFERENT QUESTION SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENTLY. THE. I'M WONDERING
WHETHER IT WASN'T THAT ARE
PEOPLE DIDN'T TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
WHETHER THE WARDENS AS WELL AS
THE SUPERVISORS AT THE
FACILITIES DIDN'T WANT TO AMASS
PERIOD. BECAUSE THEY CLEARLY
DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE IN FORCING
RULES IN FACT IN MY EXPERIENCE
WITH THE FACILITIES ON THE
RULES ARE CREATED TO PROTECT
PEOPLE'S SAFETY THE SAFETY OF
BOTH THE OFFICERS THE STAFF BUT
ALSO OF THE INMATES AND SO YOU
HAVE SOMETHING THAT AGAIN. WE
WERE ASKING PEOPLE TO WEAR A
MASK BECAUSE IT WAS FASHIONABLE
OR SOMETHING IT WAS IT WAS FOR
PEOPLE'S PHYSICAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY. SO HI I CAN ONLY COME
TO THE CONCLUSION THAT. THEY
DON'T DO IT. WELL I'LL I WOULD
BE IN ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION I
WOULD PROBABLY- MIRROR WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER- NOTED
EARLIER IS THAT THESE WORDS
HAVE. A LOT OF DISCRETION THAT
IS GRANTED TO THEM THROUGH FROM
THE DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP AND-
WHAT THAT LEADS TO. IS IN SOME
INSTANCES THIRTY FIVE DIFFERENT
WAYS OF DOING THINGS AND THIS
WAS ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT
DID NOT RECEIVE. A LOT OF
HEADQUARTERS- NOTICES UNTIL
JUST VERY RECENTLY. WHEN YOU
SEE RECENTLY WOULD YOU TALK
ABOUT LIKE LAST WEEK LAST MONTH
I'M TALKING LAST WEEK- WE WERE
OUT AND WE WERE OUT OF IT
INSTITUTION- ON MONDAY
YESTERDAY. FOR MONDAY AND- WE-
I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH THE
WARDEN WHO. WHO THEN TOLD US IT
WAS NOW CRYSTAL CLEAR TO HIM
WHAT HIS JOB WHAT'S- AND THAT
WAS MADE CRYSTAL CLEAR. BY THE
BY THE SECRETARY AND THE
RECEIVER WHO LEFT THEM NO DOUBT
WHAT THEIR EXPECTATIONS WERE I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT HAPPENED
EARLY ON. SO I KNOW THAT THIS
ISSUE VERY MASS IS BEING BEEN A
POLITICAL ISSUES IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY I REALLY
APPRECIATE OUR STATE I MEAN. IT
HAS NOT BEEN AT LEAST AT LEAST
JUST MY PERSONAL OPINION IS NOT
BEEN. OF POLITICAL- SITUATION
IN OUR- IN OUR GOVERNOR OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT- WE- WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE. DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION ABOUT OPENING UP AND
YOU KNOW WHAT THE WEATHER TURNS
YOU KNOW THE ECONOMY AND I
THINK THOSE ARE ALL- EXTRA
THINGS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
DELIBERATE AND HEALTH POLICY
DISCUSSIONS BUT REALLY THOUGH
THE WORD OF THE MASS HASN'T
BEEN. OUT A MAJOR POLITICAL
ISSUE- BUT I. I MEAN I COME TO
COULD I CAN ONLY COME TO
CUSHION I AGREE WITH YOU I
THINK THE WARDENS HAVE. AN
IMMENSE AUTHORITY EACH OF THEM.
AND IF THEY- WARRANT- ENFORCING
THE PROTOCOLS. I CAN ONLY SORT
OF IMAGINE THAT THEY JUST.
AGAIN COME TO CONCLUSION THAT
IT DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT IN THIS
SEEMS GIVEN THAT THE GOVERNOR-
YOU KNOW SENSE COVERT STARTED
HAS PRETTY MUCH BEEN ON TV
EVERY DAY EVERY OTHER DAY EVERY
THREE DAYS. AND ONE OF HIS
CONTINUING MESSAGES TO THE
PUBLIC INCLUDING ALL THE STATE
AGENCIES BUT JUST TO THE PUBLIC
HAS BEEN TO WEAR A MASK- THE
SUIT SO WHY DO YOU THINK IT
TOOK SO LONG FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. MANAGEMENT TO COME.
DELIVER THE MESSAGE THE
GOVERNOR'S BEEN DELIVERING
PRETTY MUCH SENSE I DON'T KNOW
ROUGHLY MARCH OR APRIL. WELL IN
IT IN FAIRNESS TO THE
DEPARTMENT THEY'RE DEALING WITH
A LOT OF WITH THE OUTBREAKS AND
SO FORTH BUT I THINK THEY
SIMPLY DIDN'T HAVE. OF THE
WHERE WITH ALL FOR WHATEVER
REASON TO MAKE THIS A PRIORITY
AND NOW THAT SOME ATTENTION HAS
BEEN. FOCUSED ON IT AND WAS
FOCUSED BECAUSE OF THE HOW THE
RESULTS THAT WE REPORTED I
THINK THAT THEY HAVE OF.
THEY'LL COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
REQUIRES SOME- UPPER LEVEL
LEADERSHIP INVOLVEMENT AND
THAT'S HAPPENING WE'RE WE ARE
WE WILL WE NEED TO SEE WHETHER
THAT STICKS BUT- AT THIS POINT-
I THINK THAT BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT WE PRESENTED
OUR REPORT. WE HAVE THE
ATTENTION OF THE LEADERSHIP AT
THE DEPARTMENT AND HALF CCH YES
AND I'M HOPING THAT THAT WILL
DRIVE SOME OF THESE. SOME OF
THE ENFORCEMENT OF THE POLICIES
WHICH ARE THERE. IT'S SO SOUNDS
LIKE YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR
FEELING OR I'M JUST
PARAPHRASING WHAT I HEARD YOU
SAY. IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT RE
OR SORT OF RE ITERATING THE
FACE COVERING PROTOCOLS LAST
WEEK WERE A DIRECT RESULT OF
YOUR REPORT AND YOUR YOUR
INVESTIGATION I. I DON'T KNOW
FOR SURE BUT- I HAVE HAD
SEVERAL DISCUSSIONS WE'RE
SECRETARY ALISON ABOUT THE
RESULTS THAT WE FOUND. AND
WE'VE HAD GOOD DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AND I THINK THAT- WHAT THE
SECRETARY AND THE RECEIVER DID
LAST FRIDAY AND THEIR
DISCUSSION WITH THE WARDENS WAS
A DIRECT RESULT OF SORT OF
HEARING THIS DRUMBEAT OF THIS
IS ONE THING YOU CAN DO IT IT'S
NOT BEING ENFORCED. I'M IN AND
WHOSE WHOSE PURVIEW IS THIS
HELP ME CLARIFY IS IT THE
RECEIVERS PURVIEW. BECAUSE OF
THE HEALTH RELATED MATTER WAS A
REALLY THE SECRETARY'S PARTY
YES I WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO
THEM BUT I WOULD THINK THAT IS
A JOINT PURVIEW THE- OF THE
SECRETARY CLEARLY HAS.
AUTHORITY FOR THE CUSTODY STAFF
IN THOSE PRISONS THE RECEIVER
CLEARLY HAS SOME AUTHORITY FOR
THE HEALTH CARE PEOPLE- AND
THAT. THAT PRISON POPULATION OF
STAFF IS A IS A MIXTURE OF
THOSE SO I DON'T I DON'T THINK
IT'S ONE OR THE OTHER
PERSONALLY- BUT I'D HAVE TO I'D
HAVE TO DEFER TO THE FOOTBALL
NUMBER. YET HOW OFTEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET ME JUST STOP YOUR
WITH MY QUESTIONS FOR YOU BUT
LET ME JUST EXPRESS MY PERSONAL
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR WORK.
YOUR CONTINUED WORK- WITHIN
THIS DEPARTMENT- YOU CONTINUE
TO RAISE ISSUES FORWARD ON
BEHALF OF THE SPEAKER OF THE
PRO TEM THE LEGISLATURE. ISSUES
THAT IN MY OPINION IF YOU
WEREN'T. CABLE TO DO YOUR-
WOULD REMAIN. UNDERGROUND AND I
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT WITHIN
THIS PARTICULAR DEPARTMENT JUST
BECAUSE- YOU HAVE A GROUP OF
INMATES WHO. REALLY I CAN'T
REALLY COMMUNICATE WITH US
OUTSIDE OF THROUGH THEIR
FAMILIES CAN REALLY GIVE US A
SENSE OF- WHAT'S GOING ON- YOU
HAVE A LOT OF OFFICERS WHO ALSO
I'LL TELL YOU FEEL IN THAT
SAME. HEY IN THAT SAME ROOM IN
THE SAME- WORLD AS WELL AS SELF
SO I THINK I REALLY YOU JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
WORK AND REALLY- DOING THIS
PARTICULAR PART PASSED THE
SPEAKER BUT JUST THANK YOU FOR
REALLY- YOUR YOUR WORK AND
AGAIN DURING YOUR CONTINUED HER
ENTIRE STAFF AND ALL EVERYTHING
THEY DO FOR A TO REALLY HELP
IMPROVE THIS DEPARTMENT. SO LET
ME JUST GO BACK TO. SECRETARY
ALISON OR MR KELSO WHOEVER
HAPPENS TO BE SITTING IN THE
CHAIR MAKE IT EASY SO NO ONE
HAS TO MOVE. WHAT OKAY. YEAH
FONG. YES SIR THANK YOU
SECRETARY OWN SO WE ARM. YES
FROM FROM SCRATCHING MY HEAD A
LITTLE BIT TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHY IT TOOK TELL LAST WEEK TO
REITERATE OR YOU KNOW GOVERNOR
NEWSOM SECTOR GALLEY- HAS BEEN
NOT ONLY DEMANDING OF THE STATE
AGENCIES BUT REALLY THE ENTIRE
PUBLIC OF CALIFORNIA. L. Y.
TOOK TO LAST WEEK TO- REINFORCE
THAT MESSAGE AND WHAT WAS THE
IMPETUS FOR THAT COMMUNICATION.
SO THERE'S BEEN MULTIPLE
MEMORANDUMS FROM BOTH THE
DIRECTOR OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
AND- DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THIRTY SINCE THE
BEGINNING HI I'M TRYING TO I
WAS TRYING TO GET AN EXACT
NUMBER I WANT TO SAY IT'S
APPROXIMATELY FIVE DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS AS IT RELATES TO
MASKS EACH OF THEM INCREASING
EVERY SINGLE TIME SOME OF THOSE
ARE SUBTLE NUANCES AS IT
RELATES TO OKAY YOU'RE IN AN
OFFICE BY YOURSELF SOMEBODY
WALKS IN. AND OFTENTIMES AND WE
FOUND THIS ON BOTH THE CASTING
SIDE AS WELL AS THE MEDICAL
SIDE. TO REALIZE- JUST BECAUSE
OF AN OFFICE. IN SOMEBODY WALK
SAID I HAVE TO WERE PUT PUT ON
A MASK. AND FOR THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT STAFF AS THEY
WERE WALKING IN THE GATE THEY
HAVE A MONTH UNDER THEIR NECK
VERSUS POINT UP OVER THERE
KNOWS WHAT THEY'RE WALKING
DESERT THINKING WHILE I'M
OUTSIDE. BUT YET THEY WEREN'T
SIX FEET APART AND SO THAT'S
WHY WE ARE OUR MASS MEMO'S BEEN
EVER CHANGING- I WILL SAY THAT-
BOTH CLARK AND I TAKE THIS VERY
VERY SERIOUSLY WHEN I WALK INS.
I SEE STAFF WEARING MASKS. YOU
KNOW I WHEN I GO TO AN
INSTITUTION- AND- I HONESTLY I
PERSONALLY HAVEN'T. EXPERIENCED
LARGE NUMBERS OF STAFF NOT
WORRY NOW SOMETIMES IT'S SO
IT'S A ONE OFF I WAS RECENTLY
AN INSTITUTION I WAS CHASING
DOWN SOME STAFF OF THE SONG. I
JUST TOOK OFF MY IN NINETY FIVE
AND I WAS GET READY TO PUT ALL
MY- PERSONAL MASK AND I'M LIKE.
OKAY BUT IT'S NOT. AND SO- YOU
KNOW AND SHE SHE RAN OVER TO
SHOW ME THE TRASH AND WE SHOULD
THROW IT AWAY TEN FEET BACK NO
I'M NOT NO I'M I'M PRETTY SURE
THAT SO COULD LOSE THEM YOU
JUST. TRY TO GET AN ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION SO- I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'VE HAD FIVE FIVE MEMOS
LET'S JUST SAY THERE IS
NUMEROUS. MEMORANDUMS AND
NUMEROUS COMMUNICATIONS AND
THEN I'LL JUST USE AND USE THE-
EXAMPLE THAT I USE WITH MY
STAFF. HI I HAVE STAFF- YOU
KNOW THAT OUR OUR YOUNGER RIGHT
HE YOU KNOW LIKE I I'M OLDER SO.
SOMETIMES ALL EMAIL OTHER TIMES
I WILL MAKE A PHONE CALL- I
HAVE A RULE OF MY STAFF THAT IF
YOU SEND ME AN EMAIL AND YOU
DON'T GET A RESPONSE. ASSUME
WHAT ASSUME IT'S NOT BEEN READ.
OR IF I ASK YOU TO SOMETHING.
TO DO SOMETHING IS INTO. IT HE
IS TO WHATEVER JOB WAS DONE. SO
I GUESS MY QUESTION BACK TO YOU
IS. THE FOR THE MEMOS WERE SENT.
DID YOU HAVE EVIDENCE THAT THE
MEMOS WERE BEING IMPLEMENTED.
YES WE DID HAVE EVIDENCE THAT
THROUGH TRAINING DOCUMENTS THAT
THEY WERE BEING IMPLEMENTED- WE
INCREASED THAT TO PROVIDE.
DISCIPLINARY ACTION WHEN
NECESSARY AND THEN ONSITE
INSPECTIONS. WHAT WE ME THROUGH
TRAINING DOCUMENTS THAT THEY
WERE BEING COMMITMENTS ARE IF
YOU COULD ELABORATE FOR I'M
SORRY I PREFER PRACTICE THAT WE
PROVIDED TRAINING TO OUR
INSTITUTIONS. WHEN WE SEND OUT
A MEMBER WE GENERALLY I WILL
PUT- A TRAINING CODE ON THEM TO
MAKE SURE ALL STAFF ARE TRAINED.
OKAY SO THE STAFF WERE TRAINED
BUT HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT THEY
WERE. WEARING THE MASKS. SO THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY INSTITUTION HEADS
NEED TO TOUR FACILITIES
MANAGERS AND SUPERVISORS NEED
TO TOUR FACILITIES AND SET VERY
CLEAR EXPECTATIONS. OF I WILL
SAY THAT WE REQUIRE
DOCUMENTATION NOW THAT THEY
TOUR AND PROVIDE VERIFICATION
THAT PEOPLE WORK STAFF FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH MASK WEARING.
TO INCLUDE NOW WE HAVE THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTORS AND
REGIONAL HEALTH CARE EXECUTIVES
ALSO DOING THOSE ON SITE-
UNANNOUNCED INSPECTIONS. IT
WOULD THESE UNANNOUNCED
INSPECTIONS START. THEY JUST
BEGAN WITH THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS GOT IT ON. WAS WITH THE
MOST RECENT COMMUNICATION TO
THE- STAFF IN RESPONSE TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S FEEDBACK TO
YOU BUT WHAT HE HAD BEEN
FINDING. YES ON IN JUST ACROSS
IT IS THERE A REASON WHY- THERE
WEREN'T INSPECTIONS. GOING ON
PREVIOUS TO A FEW WEEKS AGO I
FOR EXAMPLE WE HEARD THE SAME
SITUATION WITH THE NURSING
HOMES AND SO THE NURSING HOMES.
ON THE- THE STATE SET UP A
STRIKE TEAM AND THEY HAVE
STRIKE TEAMS THAT WERE-
HITTING- ALL THE VARIOUS
NURSING HOMES DILLON SURPRISE
VISITS I ENSURING THAT THEY
WERE- YOU KNOW ENFORCING THE
OTHER VARIOUS PROTOCOLS IT AND
THAT WAS BECAUSE AGAIN. NURSING
HOMES WERE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
SPIKE OF. LOADED WITH IN THE
STATE JUST LIKE THE- PRISONS
ARE SO I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY- IT
DIDN'T APPEN SOONER TO HAVE A
STRIKE TEAM PER SE WAR WAR IN
INTROSPECTION TEAM ENSURING
THAT. PROTOCOLS ARE BEING
FOLLOWED ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE
WAS. THE BASIC ONE POINT WHERE
I MASS. RIGHT I WILL SAY THAT.
AS IT HAS EVOLVED ALL THE
VARIOUS MEMOS WE CAN SEARCH BY
G. COPIES OF THE I THINK FIVE
POSSIBLY MORE I BELIEVE THE
MEMBERS WERE THERE I'M JUST NOT
BELIEVING THAT THEY WERE
IMPLEMENTED. IT HONESTLY WHEN
YOU READ THAT L. Y. G. REPORT
YOU REALIZE THAT. SO YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR SYSTEMIC FAILURE IN
A IN A IN A IN A DEPARTMENT- I
WILL SAY AT MOST INSTITUTIONS I
TOWARD I HAVE NOT SEEN OR
WITNESSED ANY- DIRECT CONCERNS
SYSTEMICALLY RIGHT MEANING LIKE
THE MAJORITY STAFF REFUSING TO
WEAR MASKS AND I'VE GONE
INSTITUTIONS IN REMOTE
LOCATIONS. WHERE YOU KNOW THE
SOME PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE IT'S
CO THAT OUR COMMUNITY THAT
NEVER BEEN HIT BY COBIT BUT OUR
STAFF WERE TAKEN SERIOUSLY TO
WHERE THE IT TOOK TO WEAR
MASKS. SO I WILL SAY THAT TOO I
THINK IT'S A SYSTEMIC ISSUE
MAYBE EARLY ON YES BUT I WILL
SAY AS AS TIME ROLLED ON AND
ARE FURTHER EXPANSIONS OF KOBE
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENTS KINDA
LATE IN IN ACTUALLY GETTING
CODED. YOU KNOW. MASS OUTBREAK
THAT WE SEEN WE WERE SEATED
CHAU WAS OBVIOUSLY OUR FIRST-
AND I. WOULD NOT BEEN THERE BUT
I WILL SAY THAT THE SUBSEQUENT-
AND I APOLOGIZE KIND OF GET.
LOST IN MY THOUGHTS HERE SAYS
GIVES ME. I WILL SAY THAT THE-
IG REPORT HIGHLIGHTED VERY
SPECIFIC THINGS THAT COULD BE
ADDRESSED AND THOSE HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED NOW MANY OF THEM HAD
BEEN PREVIOUSLY ADDRESSED IN
SOME MEMORANDUM. BUT I WILL SAY
THAT WITH- EMPHASIS ON THOSE
YOU KNOW WE DID HAVE MANAGERS
AND SUPERVISORS RESPONSIBLE TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE. LOCALLY WE
TOOK THAT OUT YOU KNOW WE NOW
HAVE EXPANDED THAT TO INCLUDE
OUR REGIONALS. JUSTIN AS LIKE
EXTRA PRECAUTIONARY MEASURES.
WHY LET ME FIRST FAN THANK YOU
FOR YOU KNOW ONCE. YOU HEARD
FROM THE I. G. THAT HOW YOU
TOOK- YOU KNOW IN MY OPINION
FAIRLY SWIFT ACTIONS I REALLY
DO. APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK
THAT THAT IS THAT THEY SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE RECOGNIZED. I
WOULD ALSO SAY JUST LIKE WHAT
WHEN I GO TO THE FACILITY I'M
SURE JUST LIKE WHEN YOU GO
VISIT FACILITY EVERYONE SORT OF
ON THEIR BEST BEHAVIOR. SO I
DON'T THINK THAT'S REALLY A
TRUE INDICATION AS TO WHAT IS
REALLY GOING ON I DON'T THINK I
CAN VISIT ANY FACILITY AND
REALLY GET US REAL IDEA OF.
WHAT'S GOING ON ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS I DON'T APPLY TO GET
EVERYBODY ON THEIR BEST
BEHAVIOR AND- EVERYTHING'S BEEN
CLEANED AND XCERRA. SO I
THOUGHT I WOULD URGE YOU TO-
YOU KNOW EXPAND THAT TEAM THAT
IS GOING AROUND AND- DOING
VISIS TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
THAT THERE IS- YOU KNOW
INSPECTIONS OCCURRING ON. IT IN
TERMS OF- SYSTEMIC FAILURE WHAT
I WOULD SAY IS WHILE THERE IS A
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE E. COLI
OUTBREAK IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
THE COVERT OPERATE WITHIN. THE
CORRECTIONS SYSTEM AGAIN THE
REASON WE'RE HAVING THE HEARING
IS AS WELL THE HEARING THAT WE
HAD ON SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IS. FAR AWAY
INSTITUTIONALLY THESE TWO TYPES
OF INSTITUTIONS LONG CREATED
DISPROPORTION NET NOT NUMBER OF
KOBE CASES IN SO. I DON'T I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT
GOING AGAINST ALL THE VARIOUS
PRISON FACILITIES BECAUSE OF
HOW PEOPLE ARE HOUSED IN THE
CROWDING EXCITER CENTER ACCENT
REAL SPENT DODD THAT'S WHY WE
ARE. SO CONCERNED- I THINK
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT ARE
OUT OF YOUR CONTROL WHICH IS
THE PHYSICAL PLANT WE CANNOT
CHANGE THAT VERY EASILY. BUT
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE WITH
IN ON YOUR CONTROL AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT WORKING YOUR
CONTROL. THAT COULD HAVE
REDUCED WOULDN'T HAVE MITIGATED
EVERYTHING BUT COULD HAVE
REDUCED THE SITUATION. ON WAS
NOT WAS NOT DONE AND WAS NOT
DONE IN A SYSTEMIC FASHION. SO
THAT THE FACT THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH DATA. TO SHOW PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INCONSISTENCY
THROUGHOUT THE INSTITUTION-
DOES POINT OUT THAT THERE WAS-
SOME SOME SOME SOME LEVEL OF
SYSTEMATIC FAILURE AND IN MY
OPINION. ON WHETHER WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION ON THAT. ON
IT. JUSTIN I ASKED THE SAME
QUESTION FOR THE IG BUT IS IT
IS A REALLY UNDER YOUR PURVIEW
WERE SUS UNDER THE- THE
RECEIVERS PURVIEW THIS THIS
PARTICULAR. BECAUSE I GUESS YOU
BOTH SIGNED THE MEMORANDUM. THE
MEMORANDUM THIS I HAVE TO I
HAVEN'T OF ME. SO THERE'S
MULTIPLE MEMORY. YES IT IS A
JOINT EFFORT BETWEEN- C. C. R.
A C. C. H. C. S. SO WE'VE HAD A
VARIETY OF MEMOS. THAT HAVE
BEEN SIGNED EITHER BY AT THE
DIRECTORATE LEVEL. OR ADD OF
THE SECRETARY AND RECEIVER
LEVEL. SO IS DOCTOR BIXEL THEIR-
YES OF COURSE BUT TO HAVE THE-
FOR THE JOINT RESPONSIBILITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY. THANK
YOU FOR GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE SO JUST SET
UP A SIMILAR QUESTIONS RIGHT I
MEAN YOU'RE- THE YOUR YOUR
DOCTOR I IMAGINE LOOK DO YOU
LIKE- ALL THE VARIOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN THE
STATE. DISCOVERED EARLY ON THAT
WEARING A MASK WAS WELL ONE OF
THE BEST WAYS TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF COVERT IS THAT A FAIR
STATEMENT. I THINK PRETTY EARLY
ON WE KNEW THAT IT WAS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF OUR
RESPONSE YES- DO. IN THE END
WHY WHY IN YOUR OPINION WAS IT
NOT UNIFORMLY IMPLEMENTED
THROUGHOUT THE- SYSTEM. SO
ACTUALLY I DON'T THINK IT WAS
AN ISSUE SO MUCH OF NOT BEING
UNIFORMLY IMPLEMENTED IT'S JUST
THAT WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PATIENTS ARE
GETTING ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE ON
THE SAME PAGE AND COMPLYING CAN
BE CHALLENGING. WHAT WHAT DO
YOU THINK THAT START WITH A
PIECE PEOPLE. YOU HAVE PEOPLE
DYING IN FACILITIES A PRETTY
PRETTY HIGH NUMBERS. WHY DO YOU
THINK THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN
THAT AS A CUE TO. TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY. WELL I THINK WHAT WE
SEE IN OUR SYSTEM REALLY
MIRRORS WHAT WE'RE SEEING
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY FOR A
VARIETY OF. REASONS WHERE THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE SELLING
DOUBT AND CONFUSION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT MASKS ARE
HELPFUL OR WHETHER THEY'RE
HARMFUL- THAT'S BEEN IT AS
YOU'VE NOWN A TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION- IN OUR IN OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEM FOR SOME TIME
AND- SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE
SEEING INSIDE OUR INSTITUTIONS
IS IN MANY WAYS JUST A
REFLECTION. OF THAT SAME
ARGUMENT- THE DEPARTMENT REALLY
ACTED QUITE PROMPTLY EARLY ON
IN IN CONVERTING PIAA FACTORIES
TO CREATING FACE COVERINGS AND
PROVIDING THEM TO ALL OF OUR
PATIENTS AND TO ALL OF OUR
STAFF. AND ESTABLISHING THE
EXPECTATION THAT THOSE WOULD BE
USED TO SO I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT ACTED PROMPTLY- BUT
AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ALL ARE.
FREE THINKERS SOMETIMES- IT
DOES NOT GO THE WAY THAT YOU
WOULD HOPE I TOTALLY TOTALLY
AGREE AND I COULDN'T DOWN. I'M
I'M NOT GONNA ARGUE THAT BUT-
WE DON'T HAVE FREEDOM IN ARE.
YOU YOU ARE A DEPARTMENT. YOUR
YOU DON'T RUN A PUBLIC HOSPITAL.
YOU DEPARTMENT WERE FREEDOM HAS
BEEN. TAKEN WORK. SO WHAT WAS
SO DIFFICULT ABOUT IMPLEMENTING
THE GOVERNOR AND SECRETARY
COLLEAGUES DIRECTIVE IT WASN'T
IT WASN'T I'M A LITTLE BIT
SURPRISED SECRETARY ALISON
CHARACTERIZES IT AS IT WASN'T
CLEAR I THINK IT WAS PRETTY
CRYSTAL CLEAR. HIGH EVER SINCE
I'VE RETURNED BACK TO WORK AND
WE'VE MY FIRST RETURN BACK TO
WORK IN THIS ROOM I GOT MY
COLLEAGUES HERE WE ALL. SHOWED
UP WITH THE MASS WHEN WE RETURN.
SO WHAT. WHY WERE STATE
EMPLOYEES ALL STATE EMPLOYEES
LET'S JUST YOU KNOW STATE
EMPLOYEES. WHY WERE STATE
EMPLOYEES ALLOWED. TO DISREGARD
BUT THE GOVERNOR AND SECRETARY
KHALID. REALLY KIND OF ORDERED
EVERYBODY TO DO. WELL FIRST I'D
LIKE TO SAY THAT I DON'T WANT
TO HAVE ANYTHING I'M SAYING BE
INTERPRETED AS SUGGESTING THAT
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT FACE
COVERINGS ARE AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PART OF WHAT WE DO.
IT'S BEEN PART OF OUR PLAN FROM
VERY EARLY TIMES IN FACT WHEN
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
OUTBREAKS IN INSTITUTIONS WE'VE
GONE BEYOND STANDARD FACE
COVERINGS AND IN SOME
SITUATIONS ABOUT BREAKS HAVE
PROVIDED N. NINETY FIVE MASKS
TO BOTH OUR EMPLOYEES AND TO
THE RESIDENTS WHO ARE AN
OUTBREAK FACILITIES AND UNABLE
TO- WE FEEL PROTECT THEMSELVES
WITH JUST STANDARD FEE. THAT
BEING SAID- MY EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN THAT WEARING A FACE
COVERING IS A SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN IN YOUR DAY TO DAY
ACTIVITIES MANY OF FACE
COVERINGS ARE- FICK THERE THEY
MAKE YOU ARE HOT SOME PEOPLE
SAY THEY'RE HARD TO BREED WITH
AND JUST THINK FOR A MOMENT
ABOUT WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR YOU
AND I TO WEAR THE FACE COVERING
THROUGH OUR DAY AND THEN TRY TO
EXTRAPOLATE THAT FOR OUR
PATIENTS- WHO BASICALLY ARE
BEING ASKED TO WEAR FACE
COVERING. TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
THREE SIXTY FIVE BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY REALLY CANNOT GET AWAY BY
THEMSELVES IN A CLOSED ROOM
WITH NO ONE ELSE IN THEIR AREA
IT'S REALLY A HEAVY LIFT AND SO
MY EXPERIENCE IS BAD I MEAN I
SPENT TIME IN IN DISABILITIES
ON A REGULAR BASIS. AT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF OUR
PATIENTS AND OUR STAFF ARE
DOING A PRETTY DARN GOOD JOB OF
WEARING THEIR FACE COVERINGS UP
THERE NOT BEING PERFECT THEY'RE
FALLIBLE AS MANY OF YOU HAVE
POINTED OUT OUR PHYSICAL PLANT
IS NOT VERY CONDUCIVE- TO
PEOPLE BEING PERFECT BUT THEIR
FACE MASKS STAFF DON'T HAVE
BREAK ROOMS WHERE THEY CAN GO
EAT ON A REGULAR BASIS. IT'S
NOT EASY FOR THEM TO JUST STEP
OUTSIDE AND GET A QUICK BREATH
OF FRESH AIR SO THEY CAN TAKE
THEIR MASK OFF FOR FIVE MINUTES
DURING THEIR SHIFT MANY OF THEM
WORKED DOUBLE SHIFTS THERE IS
ONLY FOR A LOT OF TIME SO I
COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS I.
JUST THINK WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT. WE IT IS THAT WERE. ARE
IN CENTER STAFF DO. I DON'T
THINK THAT'S VOCAL AND I THINK
WE- I TOTALLY APPRECIATE THAT
AND- THIS IS BEEN A PANDEMIC
THAT'S AFFECTED EVERY SINGLE
PERSON THE STATE THERE'S NO
QUESTION AND IN YOUR RIGHT IT
IS A IT IS A BURDEN. ON THE
FOLKS THAT WE ARE ASKING. TO DO
THAT. BUT BASED ON WHAT YOU
JUST SAID WHAT I WHAT I HEARD
YOU SAY WAS IN GENERAL
SYSTEMICALLY WE ARE. ENFORCING
THE ARMS WE ARE ENFORCING THE
MASK PROTOCOLS. BUT IT'S REALLY
JUST EVERY NOW AND THEN YOU
KNOW LIKE YOU SAID THERE'S
FALLIBILITY AND ABSOLUTELY.
EVERY NOW AND THEN- PEOPLE
AREN'T FOLLOWING- FROM THE
RULES THAT THAT'S SORT OF. WHAT
I HEARD BECAUSE OF. BECAUSE
PEOPLE JUST GET TIRED RIGHT
WE'LL GET WE ALL GET TIRED OF
WEARING THESE MASTERS NO
QUESTION DOES NOT DEMAND
ALTHOUGH I WOULD BE THE FIRST
PERSON TO ADMIT THAT. ON BUT
THAT'S SORT OF WHAT. I HEARD
YOU SAY THAT FOR.
CHARACTERIZATION WELL WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS WE'VE GOT FOLKS
WERE ARE WORKING REALLY REALLY
HARD IN A DIFFICULT ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY'RE BEING EXPOSED TO-
THE POSSIBILITY OF CORBETT-
EVERY DAY AT WORK- THEIR FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE PEACE OFFICERS
ARE NURSES ARE PHYSICIANS I
THINK THEY'RE ALL DOING A
PRETTY DARN GOOD JOB OF TRYING
TO COMPLY. I THINK PERHAPS THE
PART THAT HAS BEEN LACKING INTO
RECENTLY IS THE DISCIPLINARY
COMPONENT OF WHAT WE WILL DO
WITH FOLKS WHO WE JUST ARE NOT
WILLING TO COMPLY I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO TAKE%
THEIR MASK DOWN TO EAT THEIR
SANDWICH IN THEIR TEN MINUTE
BREAK PEOPLE WHO FOR WHATEVER
REASON DECIDE IT'S JUST NOT
IMPORTANT. THAT COMPONENT IS
NOW BEING STRENGTHENED AND. AND
I THINK THAT BY DOING THAT IT
HERE IT'S IS GOING TO EAT
IMPROVE THE THOUGH LET ME UNDER
THIS YOU YOU'LL FOR MR CAL
SOUTHERN RIGHT YOUR PER OF HIS
OPERATION. THAT'S CORRECT. IT
AND HE- TRULY BROUGHT A FOR IN
THIS. CORRECT COULD YOU EXPLAIN
WHAT YOU MEAN WELL HE HE ARM
WITHIN WITHIN THE HELP HE'S
BEEN HE'S BEEN ASKED BY A JUDGE
TO. OVERSEE THE HEALTH OF THE
INMATES WITHIN THE CORRECTIONS
SYSTEM AND HE IS VERY BROAD
AUTHORITY TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
HEALTH IS BEING TAKEN CARE OF.
IS THAT CORRECT YES I WOULD I
WOULD AGREE AND YOU YOU AS THE
DOCTOR ARE I WOULD IMAGINE THE
HEAD MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL IN
CHARGE OF THE. THAT'S CORRECT
SO YOU HEALTH WE ARE WE ALL TO
GIVE NO ONE'S ARGUING HERE THE
IMPORTANCE OF WEARING MASKS-
NEW ONES ARE ARGUING. WHAT WHAT
IT DOES. SO WHY IS IT THAT YOU
AND MR KELSO. DIDN'T USE ALL
YOUR AUTHORITY TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYBODY WAS WEARING A MASK TO
PROTECT THE SAFETY OF. THE
INMATES BUT ALSO THE SAFETY OF
EVERYBODY WHO WORKS IN THE
FACILITY I'M NOT JUST GIVING
EXAMPLE I MEAN. IF YOU WORK AT
A NUCLEAR POWER PLANT YOU HAVE
TO WEAR CERTAIN SUIT DO YOU
HAVE A YOU HAVE A CHOICE. THE
THEFT AND THAT'S IT THAT'S IT
IS NOT BECAUSE IT LOOKS GOOD
IT'S BECAUSE- IT'S FOR YOUR
OWN. SAFETY FOR YOUR OWN HEALTH
AND SAFETY. SO YOU HAVE A
PANDEMIC THAT IS SPREADING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS MASK
AS UNCOMFORTABLE AS IT IS- A
BIT IS THERE TO PROTECT. YOUR
YOUR SAFETY IS NOT THAT'S NOT
BECAUSE IT LOOKS GOOD IT'S
THERE TO PROTECT YOUR HELP JUST
LIKE. THE JUST LIKE THE
OFFICERS. I IMAGINE THEY HAVE A
CERTAIN UNIFORMS AND THEY GO
IN. THEY HAVE TO WEAR ICE I
SEEM CERTAIN KIND OF VAST THEY
HAVE TO WEAR CERTAIN. THE
DISBURSEMENT OF EQUIPMENT
BEFORE THEY ENTER THE PRISON
WHITE BECAUSE TO PROTECT THEIR
SAFETY. THEY DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE IN THE MATTER. I'M STILL
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW ALL IN
A ENVIRONMENT WHERE PEOPLE
REALLY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
CHOICES HOTEL THIS WAS SOMEHOW.
PEOPLE GIVEN A CHOICE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE BROAD
AUTHORITY TO TELL THEM YOU
BETTER WEAR A MASK OR ELSE.
WELL ASSEMBLY MAN I THINK I
WOULD JUST DISAGREE
RESPECTFULLY WITH YOUR
CHARACTERIZATION OF GIVING
PEOPLE A CHOICE I THINK THERE
WAS A VERY. FIRM AND CONSISTENT
MESSAGE FROM THE SECRETARY AND
FROM THE RECEIVER. OF
EXPECTATIONS REGARDING FACE
COVERINGS- WE HAD PEOPLE DOING
SURVEYS TOURING FACILITIES I
PERSONALLY BENDER FOURTEEN
FACILITIES ESSENTIAL JULY. A
PART OF WHAT I DO WHEN I WALK
AROUND IS REMIND STAFF TALK TO
STAFF TALK TO PATIENTS ABOUT.
FACE COVERINGS I THINK THERE'S
BEEN A REALLY CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS- THE PART AGAIN
THAT I THINK- I WAS NOT THERE
WAS A PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINARY.
PROCESS I THINK WE ALL HOPED
THAT PEOPLE WOULD DO THE RIGHT
THING. AND MOST PEOPLE I
BELIEVE HALF. GOT IT GOT IT SO-
YOU USE YOUR OPINION. THAT IT
WAS MADE CRYSTAL CLEAR TO
EVERYBODY. IN THE STATE AND
YOU'D HOPED THAT THERE WOULDN'T
BE NEED FOR ENFORCEMENT BUT
THAT. DID NOT NOW IT IS CLEAR
THAT MAYBE THAT THAT TIME HAS
COME. I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
CHARACTERIZATION OF SACRAMENTO
OKAY. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
OUR TIME IS TO COOPER JUST TO
FOLLOW UP DOCTORS MY MOM'S BEEN
HOSPITAL I'VE BEEN THERE
LEICESTER YES QUITE A BIT MY
DAUGHTER IS A NURSE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND HOSPITALS I
WATCHED ALL THE MEDICAL STAFF
WERE MASK IS NOT AN OPTION SO
FOR YOUR EMPLOYEES. BEING
MEDICAL STAFF IT IS NOT AN
OPTION THEY SHOULD BE WEARING
MASK I'M IS STILL OPEN TO
DEBATE IS THAT CORRECT. YES I
WOULD AGREE C. C. IS A PARA
MILITARIZATION IF THE CHP
COMMISSIONER SAYS MASTERS YOU
TO DO THIS THEY DO THAT JUST
LIKE THE MILITARY DOES SO IF
THE SECRETARY SAYS HEY. YOU
WILL DO THIS IT'S PER MILITARY
THERE'S THE FALLOUT ORDER. I
MEAN IS THAT CORRECT WELL YOU
YOU EXPECT WAS IN PLACE TO DO
THAT CORRECT. IDEALLY THAT'S
WHAT IS WHAT WOULD HAPPEN. SO
IN. I GRANT WITH THE INMATES
YOU GOT SOME INMATES ARE
STRUGGLING YOU GOT THE PRISON
LAW OFFICE BUT FOR THE MOST
PART. YOU KNOW I'M SURE YOU GET
A LARGE QUALITY THAT. WILL
FOLLOW THE RULES AND DO IT. SO
WHAT JUST I'M WITH MR TING
STRUGGLING I MEAN. YOU KNOW IN
THIS PARTICULAR MASK OFF ONCE A
WHILE ON THEIR BID I GET THAT
PART OF THAT. BUT WE COME THIS
BUILDING EVERY DAY WE WEAR A
MASK- SOLICITOR AT NINE THIRTY
WE WEAR A MASK IS NOT OPTIONAL.
TO BE HERE AS EMPLOYEES SO. THE
INMATES I'LL GIVE YOU SOME WE
ON THAT BUT AS FAR AS STAFF
GOES- THERE'S NO LEEWAY. AND
HERE WE ARE NINE SOON TO BE TEN
MONTHS INTO THIS. AND AS
MEDICAL MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL. I
JUST I HOPE I HOPE I HEAR YOU
SAY THAT IT WAS OKAY BECAUSE-
IF THEY'RE IN A HOSPITAL IN
THEIR HOSPITAL STAFF. MEDICAL
STAFF. THERE'S A CERTAIN
EXPECTATION. FOR THAT SO I MEAN
I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE. HAVING A
BLOW THEIR NOSE BECAUSE IT
DURING MY TIME IN THE HOSPITAL
WITH MY WITH MY FAMILY MY
MOTHER. EVERYBODY WERE CORRECT
I DIDN'T I NEVER SAW THAT ONE
PERSON. NOT WEARING YOUR
PROPERTY SO THAT THAT'S THE
HARD PART BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF
LIKE. WITH C. C. R. SAYS DO
WHAT YOU WANT. IT IS SOME
ASPECTS AND THEY ARE STATE
EMPLOYEES THEY HAVE A CERTAIN
OBLIGATION TO FOLLOW ESPECIALLY
THE MEDICAL FIELD YOU'RE HELD
TO HIGHER OBLIGATION FOR YOUR
STAFF SO. IT'S JUST IT'S HARD
FOR SYSTEM IN AND DO THAT
BECAUSE LIKE I SAID WE COME
HERE. YOU GET YOUR TO PROTECT
IN THE GARAGE. AND YOUR MASK IN
THE COMMISSION OF A MASK ON.
AND IT'S BEEN. TIME AND TIME
AGAIN AND EVERYBODY IS BEEN
INDOCTRINATED ABOUT HOW WE DO
IT HERE. NOT JUST FOR OURSELVES
BUT FOR OTHER PEOPLE. SO WE
WANT TO HELP YOU GUYS GET HERE
BUT IT'S FRUSTRATING BECAUSE
I'LL BE HONEST IF IT'S A
LEADERSHIP ISSUE. IT STARTS AT
THE TOP IF YOU DON'T FOLLOW
RULES IS ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
YOU GET SO MANY CHANCES IN
PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINE STARTS
AT A LOWER LEVEL. DOCUMENT
COUNSELING THAT WORKS ITS WAY
UP TO MORE SERIOUS THINGS. THAT
SHOULD BE GOING A LONG TIME AGO
SO WHICH IS. I'LL BE HONEST
WITH YOU IT'S SAD BUT IT'S FILL
THE SHIP. WELL I HEAR YOUR
FRUSTRATION MISTER COOPER AND-
EVERYTHING I'VE HEARD FROM THE
SECTOR IN THE RECEIVER- LEAD ME
TO BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE TAKING
THE NEXT STEPS AT THIS TIME TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY COMPLIES.
THANK YOU OTHER OTHER QUESTIONS.
NO SONORA QUESTIONS ARE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND
PANEL. THANK YOU I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE PANELISTS
FOR BEING HERE PRETTY YOU
TAKING ALL YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR- BEING VERY YOU
KNOW FORTHRIGHT AND OPEN AND
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED AND WE DO
WE ALL DO KNOW YOU'RE A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB SO WE ALSO DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR
SECOND PANEL ROADMAP TO
INSTITUTIONAL REOPENING OF THE
ABILITY TO PROGRAM. THIS IS
REALLY TO. FOCUS ON ONE CONCERN
HAS BEEN THE LACK OF
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AT THAT
THE FACILITIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC- SO. WE ARE HEARING
FROM KIM SIEBEL ADOBE DIRECTOR.
OF DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS. DIPPY DOCTOR
SABLE. HEY. OKAY CAN YOU GUYS
HEAR ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. RIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR ME GOOD MORE OR
GOOD EVENING OR AFTERNOON OR
CLOSE TO EVENING OUT. OF THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION'S ROADMAP THREE
OPENLY. SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
COVERT NINETEEN WE'VE TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THOSE
LIVING AND WORKING WITH OUR
INSTITUTIONS. AS COVER NINETEEN
TOUCHED OUR INSTITUTIONS WE
IMPLEMENTED EXTREME MEASURES
FOR THE PROTECTION OF EVERYONE
ALL PROGRAMS ARE SUSPENDED TO
INCLUDE VISITING EDUCATION
VOLUNTEER AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION PROGRAMS. BECAUSE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT EACH OF THESE
AREAS ARE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
FOR THE- POPULATION WE DID NOT
MAKE THESE DECISIONS LIGHTLY AS
TIME PROGRESSED WE REALIZED
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WE WILL NEED
TO FIND WAYS TO WORK WITHIN A
NEW NOR. A NORM THAT ALLOWS FOR
INCREASED MOVEMENT AND ACCESS
TO PROGRAMS THUS BEGAN THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF A HIGH LEVEL
ROADMAP TO RE OPENING. THE ROAD
MAP TO RE OPENING WAS CREATED
AS A TOOL TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
DIRECTOR. OPTIONS TO OUR
WARDENS AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS. TO REVIEW WHEN AND
HOW TO LESSEN RESTRICTIONS.
MANY STAKEHOLDERS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS SUCH AS- THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH INNER CITY SEATS YES
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS WERE
CONSULTED AND PROVIDED.
VALUABLE FEEDBACK IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE ROADMAP. IT
WAS JUST THAT THE WAY TO
MANAGED OVER NINETEEN IN THE
POTENTIAL OUTBREAKS WAS
IMPLEMENTED A PHASED APPROACH
TO REOPEN. PHASES PROVIDED
HIGHER AUTHORITIES THE BEST
OPTION FOR INCREASING MOVEMENT
AND PRO OFFERED. WHILE MODEL
ANY IMPACTS HOUSE. WHY DOES THE
ROAD IS PRO DOWN TO FOUR. PHASE
ONE OF OUR MOST. FACE FACE TO
EASE PHASE RUSHED. PHASE THREE.
OPPORTUNITIES OUTSIDE OF
HOUSING UNITS AND FACE FOR IS A
RETURN TO OUR NEW NORMAL FOR
ALL. EACH DAY INSTITUTIONS
DOCUMENT THEIR CURRENT FACILITY
FACE STATUS AND PROVIDE
COMMENTS RELATIVE TO THEIR
CURRENT STATUS AND ANY PLANS TO
MOVE TO THE NEXT PHASE AND AN
INTERNAL TRACKING SYSTEM. WORK
AND CEOS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE COLLABORATIVE COLLABORATIVE
DECISION FOR WHICH THEIR
INSTITUTIONS OR INDIVIDUAL
FACILITIES WILL MOVE BETWEEN
PHASE PHASES BASED ON CURRENT
CODE BUT POSITIVES OF THEIR
LOCAL INSTITUTION. WARDENS AND
RADIO SHARE THEIR PLANS BUT
THEIR RESPECTIVE ASSOCIATE AND
REGIONAL CARE EXECUTIVES. ICAL
ITEMS FOR HIGHER AUTHORITIES TO
ENSURE IS THAT THERE'S NO NEW
CO CASE ON A FOURTEEN DAY TOO
LITTLE PERIOD TO MOVE FOR PHASE
ONE TO PHASE TWO. NO NEW COBIT
CASES ON A ROLLING OF DAYS TO
MOVE FACE TO FACE THREE AND NO
NEW CODE CASES ON A ROLLING
NINETY DAY PERIOD. TO MOVE FOR
PHASE THREE TO FOUR. STAFF A
INMATES ARE WORKING TO KEEP CO
DATA THE INSTANT. OF THE
MULTITUDE TRAGEDIES EMPLOYMENT.
VARIOUS FACILITIES WITHIN A
PRISON MAYBE IN DIFFERENT
PHASES AT DIFFERENT TIMES DUE
TO THEIR DESIGN AND POPULATION
NEEDS. CURRENTLY WE HAVE 46% OF
OUR FACILITIES ARE PHASE ONE
AND ACTUALLY 54% ARE FACE TO.
BY MOVING TO FACE TO THE
FACILITIES HAVE BEGUN TO
IMPLEMENT LIMITED OUT OF SELF
PROGRAMMING I RECENTLY
WITNESSED AN EDUCATION
CLASSROOM WITH SIX INMATES
SOMEONE TEACHER A FURTHER
WITNESSED A LIBRARY WITH INMATE
WORKERS AND INMATES CONDUCTING
RESEARCH AND AN INMATE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT PROGRAM IN ACTION
WHILE WE'RE TAKING PLACE WITH
APPROPRIATE MASKING. AND
MAINTAINING SOCIAL DISTANCING
ALBEIT WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
OPERATE AT THE SAME LEVEL WERE
PRIOR TO COPE WITH NINETEEN BUT
WE ARE OPERATING SAFELY WITH
THE TIERED APPROACH WHICH IS
VERY SIMILAR TO THE COMMUNITY
TO WHICH THE INSTITUTIONS
RESIDE. THE INSTITUTION ARE
BEING. AND THEIR CONTINUED TO
KEEP COBRA NINETEEN OUT OF THE
INSTITUTE. VISIT IS AN IMPORT
PART OF REHAB. AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE FAMILIES CAN ONCE
AGAIN FOR PERSONAL CONNECTION
WITH THEIR LOVED ONES. WELL
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF VISITING
PROTOCOLS FOR IN PERSON
VISITING. THOSE PLANS WERE
SHARED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND OUR HEALTH CARE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS. HEEDING ADVICE FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT IN PERSON
VISITING WOULD NOT BE THE BEST
SOLUTION AT THIS TIME. BASED ON
THE INCREASING COVERT NINETEEN
POSITIVITY RATE IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THEREFORE
INSTITUTIONS WILL NOT BE
IMPLEMENTING VISITING INTEL
PROTOCOLS HAVE BEEN APPROVED
HOWEVER WHEN VISITING RESUMES
IT WILL BE RESTRICTED OF CALLS
RELATED TO SCREENING SOCIAL
DISTANCING MASK WEARING AN
ENHANCED SANITATION AND IN A
PHASED APPROACH. SENSE WE WILL
NOT BE IMPLEMENTING IN PERSON
VISITING AT THIS TIME WE ARE
PROMPTLY PRO ACTIVELY WORKING
TOWARDS A VIDEO VISITING
SOLUTION THAT WILL BE ROLLED
OUT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. OUR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY WORKING
OUT THE LOGISTICS GROUNDWORK TO
ENSURE APPROPRIATE
INFRASTRUCTURES IN PLACE TO
BEGIN IF VISITING A VIDEO
COMMUNICATION SOLUTION.
UNDERSTANDING THE CONCERN OF
FAMILY AND LOVED ONES WE
ESTABLISHED A WEBSITE DEDICATED
TO EMAIL ADDRESS. A DEDICATED
EMAIL ADDRESS TO KEEP THEM
INFORMED IN RECOGNITION OF THE
NEED FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE
HAVE CONTACT WITH THEIR LOVED
ONES WE ALSO PARTNERED WITH OUR
PHONE CONTRACTOR TO PROVIDE.
FREE CALLS TO EACH MONTH AND
EXPANDED PHONE ACCESS TO
CERTAIN PRIVILEGED GROUPS WE
ALSO PROVIDED VIDEO GRANTS FOR
FEMALE INSTITUTIONS. OF DURING
THE MOTHER'S DAY WEEKEND. WE
HAVE A PROGRAMS WILL BETRAY AS
A ONE SIZE ALL JUST AS EACH
PRISONERS MAKES TOO ARE THE
PROGRAM THAT OFFER WITHIN THEM.
WHEN CAN WHICH PROGRAMS TO
ACTIVATE AN INSTITUTIONAL
LEADERSHIP WILL CONSIDER SUCH
FACTORS AS THE FEASIBILITY OF
REDUCE CLASS SIZE. STAGGERED
SCHEDULES AND ALTERNATIVE SITES
SUCH AS OUTDOORS OR OTHER
NONTRADITIONAL SPACES. ALL
STUDENTS IN ACADEMIC CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND COLLEGE
PARTICIPATING PROGRAMS USING
INDIVIDUALIZED INSTRUCTIONAL
PACKETS. LITERACY TUTORING PRE
RECORDED VIDEO LESSONS FOR
TEACHERS AND EDUCATIONAL VIDEOS
AVAILABLE ON THE VIEWING OF OUR
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS TELEVISION CHANNELS.
COLLEGE COURSEWORK WAS MADE
AVAILABLE BY STATE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ENROLLED
STUDENTS USING DISTANCE
LEARNING VIDEO CONFERENCING E.
READERS AND OTHER SCHOOLS.
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING CREDITS
FOR PROGRAM HOURS COMPLETED AS
POSSIBLE GIVEN THE CODE
RESTRICTIONS THAT IT EACH
PRESENT STUDENTS ARE TAKING
TESTS TO EARN MILESTONE CREDITS
FOR ACADEMIC COURSEWORK AND
PARTICIPATING IN BLENDED
LEARNING SOME INSULTS OF FACE
TO FACE. TO ACHIEVE THEIR S. C.
T. PROGRAM MASTERY. AS WE MOVE
FACED FACE THREE FOR
EDUCATIONAL WILL BE A BLENDED
INSTRUCTION- AND THEN WE FROM
THERE. AND THEN LITTLE WORLD IS
WITH THE- ALL PROGRAMS WHEN
SAFE TO INFER WILL SHOULD PRO
REALLY DISK. SOCIAL DISTANCING
MASK WEARING AN ENHANCE. SO
WHAT CONTINUE TO COME COME BACK
CO WE EVERY DAY QUICKLY
ADAPTING AND ARE HEADED IN THE
RIGHT. AND I THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
THE EFFORTS TO DEPARTMENTS. AND
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU DEBORAH CANAL GO TO HELL.
CORRECT THE RECORD MISTER BUSH
MARACAY. THANK YOU NIKISCH THE
L. A. WE WONDER IS A FEW ISSUES
FOR CONSIDER FOR THE
LEGISLATURE RECALL THE ROAD TOO
REAL. AT KNOW IT IT IS BASED ON
DIFFERENT WITH ONE BEING I'M
RESTRICTIVE AND FACE FOR THE-
WELL. ALONG BACKED NORMAL.
ALLEN AND INTO TO MOVE. IT IS
BASED ON THE OF AMONG INMATES
AND AVAILABILITY RESOURCES TO
MONITOR AND CONTAIN NINETY IN
VENT OR IS AN ALPHA. LEADERSHIP
INSTITUTIONS HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO APPLY THE
MOVEMENT BETWEEN PHASES TO THE
ENTIRE INSTITUTION OR TO
INDIVIDUAL FACILITIES WITHIN
pCOULD RESULT IN INTERVIEWS WITH
FACILITIES AT DIFFERENT PACES
OF RE OPEN. AND IN SUCH A
SITUATION HOW CITIES ARE
MINIMIZE CROSS CONTAMINATION.
FOR EXAMPLE WILL STAFF MEMBERS
BE RESTRICTED TO FACILITIES IN
THE SAME FACE. MOVING ON TO
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DURING
PHASE ONE ONLY HEALTHCARE PLANS
ARE DEEMED ESSENTIAL CRITICAL
ALLOWED AND A FACE TO CERTAIN
SERVICES CAN RESUME SUCH A
SERVICES FOR PATIENTS AT HIGH
RISK FOR CHRONIC CONDITIONS- AS
WELL AS TELEMEDICINE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND I PICKED A
THREE OPERATE MARGIN RESUMES
NORMAL. ALLEGED MIGHT WANT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON WHAT
SOURCES ARE ALLOWED IN PHASE
ONE AND HOW THESE DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE IN ADDITION THEY
MIGHT WANT TO KNOW. WHAT IS
BEING DONE FOR PATIENTS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
CONSIDERED TO HAVE MEDICAL
RESTORE AND- WHO HAVEN'T FOR
SORT THAT SUSPENDED ON BASED ON
MOVING ON TO INSTITUTIONAL
OPERATIONS- ON. THE ROADMAP
DOES NOT SPECIFY. WHAT THE
DENSITY OF INMATE POPULATION
THAT SHOULD BE MAINTAINED IN
INSTITUTIONS. HOWEVER WE NOTE
THAT CITIES ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCED IN THE POPULATION
DENSITY IF YOU'RE ONLY RELEASES
AND THE SUSPENSION OF INTAKE.
THE DEPARTMENT IS CONTINUING TO
RELEASE SOME INMATES ARE LATE.
BUT I TOOK A DOOMED UNLIMITED
AMOUNT OF INTAKE. LETITIA MIGHT
ONE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
TV START TARGET POPULATION
DENSITY DON'T COVER NINETEEN
AND HOW THIS INTERACTS WITH THE
ROAD MAP. FOR EXAMPLE AT
INSTITUTIONS MOVED TO THE
PHASES WHAT FUTURE BEGAN TO
INCREASE THE INMATE POPULATION
DENSITY AT THOSE INSTITUTIONS.
MOVING ON TO INMATE PROGRAMS
INSTITUTION CAN ADOPT VARIOUS
OPTIONS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
PROGRAM THE CITIES ARE
MENTIONED INCLUDING INDEPENDENT
STUDY POCKETS AND FOR
INSTITUTIONS ARE FACED YOUR
HIGH ARE PHYSICALLY. DISTANT IN
PERSON PROGRAMS. THE NOT NO TO
IN SOCIAL BEST PRACTICES AND
RATIONALES FOR PROGRAMMING
DECISIONS. POLITICAL MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER HAVING TO TEACH
YOUR PROVIDE ROUTINE UPDATES ON
THIS INFORMATION AS WELL AS
WHAT PROGRAMS ARE BEING OFFERED
IN PROGRAM I IN PERSON BY
INSTITUTION. IN ADDITION THE
LOGIC- I WOULD ASK WHY THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NOT DEVELOPED A
STATE WIDE STRATEGY SEARCHES
DIRECT IN PERSON TO PRIORITIZE
RE OPENING PROGRAMS BASED ON
INMATES NEEDS. DEVIC'S TENTH
OCTOBER NINETEEN IS EVER SALAI
THREE STAR MIGHT WANT TO ALSO.
LET YOU MIGHT ALSO WANT TO IT.
QUESTION WHAT FUTURE IS DOING
TO FURTHER PREVENT. THE
OUTBREAK OF COVER NINETEEN
THROUGH IN PERSON PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE ART IMAGE BEING
REQUIRED TO WORK AND NINETY
FIVE MASCOT AND COST NOT GOING
THOSE IMPORTANT PROGRAMMING.
ALL RIGHT SEVEN TAKEN TO
INCREASE. VENTILATION WITHIN
THOSE CLASSROOMS. LETTER TO MY
ALSO MY YOU CAN IF THERE ARE
PRO THAT COULD BE USED CHECKS.
ACCESS TO PROGRAMMING. FOR
EXAMPLE THERE TO BE CITY LOST
YOUR THAT WAS WITHDRAWN THAT
WOULD HAVE EXPANDED ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY AND WIRELESS
NETWORKS FOR INMATES. AND I'VE
NOTED THAT BUILDING A
PROGRAMMING IMPACT CREDIT ON
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INMATES MY
NAME IS PARTICIPATING THE
PROGRAMS ARE TYPICALLY ON
CREDITS WHICH REDUCE THE TIME
IN PRISON AND THE BILL IT WILL
BILL THE OF THESE CREDITS VARY
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
PROGRAM. CHUCK CHEESE ARE MIGHT
WANNA OF ILLEGITIMATE WHEN
ASKED HE SHOW WHAT'S BEING DONE
TO MAXIMIZE AMOUNT OF CREDITS
INMATES CAN AREN'T AND HOW
THAT'S BEING FACTORED IN THE
DECISION OF WHAT PROGRAMS TO
OFFER BY INSTITUTION. IN JULY
HE'S ALRIGHT A ONE TIME PUBLIC
CREDIT TO INMATES THAT DID NOT
HAVE A RECENT RULES VIOLATION
WHICH HELP OFFSET SOME OF THE
CREDITS. LOSS DUE TO THE
SUSPENDED PROGRAMMING. TO THE
EXTENT THE CREDIT ON AN
OPPORTUNITY FROM PROGRAMS
REMAIN LIMITED. EXCEEDED YOUR
CONSIDERING MAKING OTHER ANY
OTHER CHANGES TO CREDITS. AND
LASTLY WE KNOW THAT THOUGH IT
LIKELY INTERACTION BETWEEN
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS AND
COVE IN NINETEEN. AND IN
PARTICULAR NOTE THAT THE
HUSBAND LARGER THAN. DEMAND FOR
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
WITH NCC ARE WITH SIX THOUSAND
PATIENTS CURRENTLY WAITING TO
BE TREATED. I'M SOME WAITING
SEVERAL MONTHS. FOR ALLEGED
FROM MY WONDER CHOIR ABOUT WHAT
STEPS HE STARTS TAKING TO
ADDRESS THE SOMETIMES USES
ORDERS AND DEMAND FOR M. A. T.
TRYING THIS TIME. THANK YOU I
HAVE AN ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU JUST COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR NOT. I'D BE INTERESTED IN
THE REACTION OF THE CDC ARE TOO
WHAT THE L. A. O. JUST SAID
ABOUT THE METRICS NOT IN A
INCLUDING. IT MADE. A DIAGNOSIS
WITH COVE IT BUT NOT INCLUDING
STAFF DIAGNOSIS. SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE TO BE A REPEAT IT
JUST TO MAKE SURE I ANSWER SO
WEIRD SO YOU'RE ASKING. WHY
DIDN'T WE USE STAFF. POSITIVE
METRICS INTO THE PHASE
APPROACHES THAT'S CORRECT YEAH
IN ADDITION TRAINING WITH THE
INMATES STATISTICS. SO IT- WITH
OUR CURRENT POLICY- OVERLOOK
PROCEDURES IF WE HAVE STAFF
THAT ARE OUT SICK- LET'S SAY
WITH CO BID WE WOULD FILL THE
POSITIONS EITHER WITH OVERTIME
OR WITH OUR CURRENT- STAFF THAT
WE USED TO FILL VACANCIES.
HOWEVER AT ANY GIVEN TIME- AND
IT WOULD NOT HAVE TO BE PRIMARY
EVEN COVERT RELATED IT COULD
JUST BE OTHER REASONS WE HAD
STAFF VACANCIES AND WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO- PROVIDE PROGRAMMING WE
WOULD GO INTO A MODIFY FOR. ON
THAT FACILITY SO- USING STAFF
PHYLLIS'S IF AT ANY GIVEN TIME
THAT WAS IMPACTED THAT WOULD
JUST ON THE NATURAL- WE MIGHT
HAVE TO REVERT TO ANOTHER PHASE
ARE JUST GOING TO A MODIFIED
PROGRAM. JUST FOR THAT DATE BUT
NOT NECESSARILY FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME. I UNDERSTAND
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THE METRIC IS
THERE TO TRY AND MEASURE THE
PREVALENCE OF CODED IN THE
PRISON COMMUNITY. I AM TO GATE.
A PROGRESSION NAY ALL IT.
ACCORDING TO THE NUMBER OF
POSITIVE CASES THAT YOU FIND SO
WHAT MAKES SENSE IN THAT SENSE
TO INCLUDE STAFF IN THAT METRIC.
I'M IT MIGHT HOWEVER IT IF WE
WERE ABLE TO FILL ALL OF OUR
POSITIONS WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION AND STILL BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES WITH
THE STAFFING LEVELS. ALL
FILLED- I CAN'T SEE- NOT
PROVIDING SERVICES IF I'M ABLE
TO FILL ALL OF MY POSITIONS AND
PROVIDE- ANY PROGRAMMING- AT
WHAT IT DEPENDING ON WHATEVER
PHASE WERE AT WITH THE STAFFING
THAT WE HAVE. NOT A LOT OF WORK
ONE FURIOUS AGREEMENT ON THAT
I'M JEFF JUST. YOU KNOW WHEN
WE'RE WHEN WE'RE GAUGING HOW TO
PROGRESS THROUGH THE VARIOUS
STAGES. ART SHOULD WE BE USING
A BLENDED METRIC THAT INCLUDES
ALL OF THE CASES WITHIN THE
PRISON COMMUNITY. SO WAS
REMOVED FROM FACE TO FACE WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT OPENING UP
FROM THE DIFFERENT PHASES SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT- LET'S SAY
FACE TO WERE OR PHASE THREE
WERE LOOKING AT- ALLOWING
OUTSIDE ENTITIES. VOLUNTEERS IF
YOU WILL COMING INTO THE
INSTITUTIONS WILL DEFINITELY BE
LOOKING INTO WHAT IS THE CODE
RED. WELL I MET IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY FOR THAT INSTITUTION.
OKAY THE BUTTON THE L. A. O.
JUST SAY THAT THAT WAS ONE OF
THE THAT THE- COPE IN SPREADING
THE IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY WAS
NOT A PART OF THE METRIC. YES
AND WE WROTE I WROTE THAT DOWN.
OKAY SO I'M CONFUSED BECAUSE
YOU YOU APPEAR TO JUST
CONTRADICT THAT. YES HE MADE
THE COMMENT HE DID MAKE THE
COMMENT THAT WE DID NOT HAVE IT
IN OUR PHASED APPROACH AND- I
WROTE IT DOWN TO TAKE IT BACK
BECAUSE THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING
WE MIGHT WANT TO ADD AS AN
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION. OKAY.
WELL I MEAN THAT THAT FOR. THE
STAFF IN FRONT RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU CAN YOU
GIVE US A SENSE OF THE-
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING AS
WELL AS PERHAPS THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE PROGRAMMING. WHAT PERCENT
HAS HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO BRING
ONLINE OR WHAT PERCENT IS BEING
OFFERED ACROSS THE SYSTEM. SO
WE CURRENTLY FOR OUR- AS
FEEDBACK- CURRENTLY ARE IN MAY
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROGRAMS
ARE OPERATING AT THIRTY THREE
PRESENCE IN A REMOTE IN PERSON
OR BLENDED MATH IT- WE ACTUALLY
HAVE ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE INMATES ARE
RECEIVING PROGRAMMING AND THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN CLASSES TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE OF THOSE
ARE INTENSE ABOUT PATIENT
FOURTEEN OUTPATIENT AND SEVENTY
FIVE LIFE SKILLS- WE HAVE ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT OF THOSE- ARE
RECEIVING CLASSES IN PERSON.
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE- OF THOSE PARTICIPATING IN
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN A PACKET
PROGRAMMING AND THAT'S FOR- IN
MAKE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER I
WOULD HAVE TO GET YOU NUMBERS-
ON THE OTHER COURSES. DO YOU
HAVE A SENSE WHETHER YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO. DO ANY OF THE
REHABILITATIVE COURSES I KNOW A
LOT OF THOSE ARE OFFERED BY. A
NON PROFITS COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IN PERSON SO. DO YOU DO YOU
HAVE ANY SENSE FOR THE YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO. HAVE ANY OF THEM
BE OFFERED LITTLE. SO WHAT
INSTITUTIONS WERE WERE AT PHASE
TWO WE HAVE HAD SOME OUTSIDE-
CONTRACTORS COMING IN AND
PROVIDING SOME OF THOSE
COURSES- AND THEY HAVE BEEN
BENEFICIAL. WHAT YOUR WHAT YOUR
PLAN OF FOR THE PHASE ONE
FACILITIES THAN. SO PHASE ONE
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR- WELL FOR
SUBSTANCE USE WE ARE DOING IT
IN PHASE ONE- IT'S VERY
LIMITED- THE CLASS SIZES ARE
LIMITED THE- INSTRUCTION IN THE
METHOD AND THEN ALSO WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING ARE NOT OF COURSE
IN OUR ISOLATION OR QUARANTINE
AREAS. NEW NOTHING YOU I THINK
LET ME JUST RESTATE MY
QUESTION- I UNDERSTAND YOU IN A
PHASE ONE YOU HAVE RESTRICTIONS
FOR PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
FACILITY SO ARE THERE
ALTERNATIVES BEING EXPLORED TO
OFFER EITHER VIRTUAL.
OPPORTUNITIES OR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE PEOPLE DO
NOT HAVE TO COME FACE TO FACE
WITH SOMEBODY. WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT OPTIONS-
WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING AT WAYS
TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM IS WHETHER IT'S- VIA
KIND OF LIKE WHAT WE'RE DING
NOW OR PUTTING THEM DOING IT IN
A SO. WHERE YOU HAVE DISTANCE-
TO WHERE. JUST TRY TO YOU JUST
HAVE A SMALLER GROUP SIZE AND
SO YOU CAN HAVE EXPANDED SOCIAL
DISTANCING BUT WE ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT WAYS
TRYING TO BE CREATIVE AND THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX AND USE
ALTERNATE LOCATIONS SURE LET ME
OF THE QUESTION DIFFERENTLY.
ARE YOU ARE YOU ARE YOU DOING
AT ANY OF YOUR FRIENDS ONE
LOCATIONS. ARE WE DOING YES WE
ARE WE ARE DOING PROGRAMMING AT
SOME OF OUR FACE WITH LOCATIONS.
I WOULD HAVE TO I WOULD HAVE TO
LOOK ON THOSE NUMBERS SO LET ME
RETRACT THAT. NO I'M JUST
DUMPED ME TO ME JUST TO THE
BEST INTERESTS. I GUESS I DON'T
WANT TO MISS YOU SO I WOULD
HAVE TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
BECAUSE I DEFINITELY DO NOT
WANT TO SPEAK ON UNDERSTOOD. SO
ON. THIS THROUGH LET'S. LET'S
LET'S SAY YOU ARE WHAT IS YOUR
PLAN TO EXPAND THE PROGRAMMING
AT THE PHASE ONE FACILITIES
KNOWING THE LIMITATIONS THAT
YOU HALF SO I UNDERSTAND YOU
SAID YOU'RE LOOKING INTO THINGS
BUT- WHAT'S THE TIME FRAME TO
POTENTIALLY. IMPLEMENTING SOME
OF THOSE PROGRAMS. SO I CAN'T
GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC TIME FRAME
ON WHEN THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED- I KNOW WE
CURRENTLY HAVE EIGHTEEN
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE DOING IN
PERSON PROGRAMMING NINER DOING
INSTITUTIONS ARE A HIGH OR IN
PERSON ARE ANY OF THESE
EIGHTEEN THINGS ONE. I WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK I WOULD I DON'T
HAVE A LISTING OF ALL THE
STATE'S MARKS RIGHT IN FRONT OF
ME. AND I AM BEING TOLD SOME OF
THEM ARE FACED CRUNCH AND GOING
TO THE PHASE ONE SO IT YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE A PHASE ON THE
WHOLE ENTIRE INSTITUTION YOU
MIGHT HAVE ONE FACILITIES FACE
ONE. ANOTHER FACILITY MIGHT BE
IT FACE TO AND THEN YOU MIGHT
HAVE ANOTHER FACILITY PHASE ONE
OF THAT BACK TO ONE BEING A
PHASE TWO. SO IF YOU'RE ASKING
THAT INSTITUTION MIGHT HAVE-
MULTIPLE FACILITY SUMMIT PHASE
ONE SUMMIT FACE TO BUT THEY ARE
RUNNING EIGHT I S. U. T. T. E.
PROGRAM. GOT GOT IT SO WHEN YOU
SAY FACILITY YOU MEAN LIKE
YARDS OF ONE YARD MAYES.
BUFFETS WERE ANOTHER GUARD
MAYBE FACE TO. BUT AGAIN YOU DO
NOT MOVING INMATES FROM YARD TO
YARD SO IF I LIVE. IN A YARD
THAT'S PHASE ONE THEN I MIGHT
AS WELL BE IN A PRISON THAT'S
PHASE ONE IT DOESN'T MEAN I
DON'T GET ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAMS OF NEXT YEAR. THAT'S
CORRECT THEIR PROGRAMMING AND
THEIR COHORTS- AND WHEN SMALLER
NUMBERS. SO THAT WE DON'T CROSS
CONTAMINATE. YES SIR EXTRA I
GUESS IN THE BOOKS OF.
DISTINCTIONS I THINK EVEN
BELIEVE MORE READ. GOING BACK
DO YOU YOU I SAID LIKE YOU
DON'T HAVE A PLAN RIGHT NOW. TO
EXPAND PROGRAM APPS ONE.
FACILITIES. HEY. WE'RE WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING AT THE EXPANDING.
WELL YOU KNOW THAT'S HOW THE
STOCKS LIKE SOME SORT OF
INTERRUPT YOU I'VE I'VE HAD
THAT LINE. THE DEPARTMENT EVER
SINCE I'VE BECOME BUDGET
CHAIRMAN I'M STILL WAITING FOR
A FACILITIES PLAN THAT DOESN'T
EXIST THAT'S BEEN FOUR YEARS OF
LOOKING INTO IT SO. I'D RATHER
JUST FOCUS ON WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND WHAT YOU'RE NOT DOING
RATHER THAN WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
INTO BECAUSE- WHAT I FIND IS
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT TOLD ME
THEY'RE LOOKING INTO SOMETHING
IT MEANS THERE. NOT DOING. SO
NOT THAT THAT'S TAKING THAT.
SOMETIMES YOU'RE NOT DOING THAT.
WE CAN PROVIDE A LIST OF
EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DOING EVERYTHING GET
THAT LIST TO YOU RIGHT AND WHAT
I WOULD WHICH I WHICH I
APPRECIATE WHAT I'M ABOUT. WHAT
IS THE DEPARTMENT DOING. TO YOU
KNOW BRING BACK THE PROGRAMMING
IT ALREADY HAD I MEAN. THIS
THIS IS. A MAJOR CHALLENGE AYE
AYE YOU KNOW YOU HEARD THE
SECRETARY TALKED ABOUT HOW
DIFFICULT THIS IS FOR THE
INMATES IN THE HOLIDAYS. YOU
EXPRESSED- THE CHALLENGES WE
KNOW ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
INMATES DON'T WANT TO BE MOVED
IS BECAUSE OF THE PROGRAMMING.
SOUL YOU KNOW WHAT BUT THE
RECEIVER SAID AS WELL PROGRAM
IS CHIEF FOR THE EQUITY BILITY
WITHIN THE FACILITY AND BETWEEN
THE DIFFERENT YARDS. SO WHAT
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO KIND OF
BRIDGE THAT GAP. SO. SO I DON'T
FACE WITH THE EXPANDING
PROGRAMMING I KNOW THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOU WANT TO HEAR- WHAT WAS
ME JUST TELL YOU WHAT I HEAR
YOU SAY THAT AND IT TELLSME WE
HAVEN'T GOT AROUND TO IT THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHAT I'M HERE. AND
THAT'S WHAT THE INMATES ARE
PROBABLY FEELING. BUT WE
HAVEN'T. GOTTEN TO THAT YET.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S WHAT YOUR
WORDS TRANSLATE TO ME. SO WE
ARE LOOKING AT DEVELOPING
CREATIVE DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS-
AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
SPENDING EXPANDING BECAUSE WE
CAN'T- IN INSTITUTIONS WERE
REAR A PHASE ONE WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO BRING INMATES
TOGETHER BECAUSE IT'S NOT SAFE
FOR THEM. SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
OTHER SOLUTIONS WHERE WE CAN
INCREASE PARTICIPATION WHERE WE
PROVIDE MORE IN CELL TYPE-
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
WAYS TO POSSIBLY MAKE THESE
REHABILITATED WHICH READING
READING TYPE PROGRAMS. BUT
pTHOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEING WORKED ON WHERE
AND WHEN WOULD YOU ANTICIPATE
BEING ABLE TO. START TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE.
PERHAPS. HOPE TO. SOON AS THE
TIME FRAME FOR ME I MEAN SINCE
MY STAFF KNOWS WITH THROUGH
MEANS TO ME WAS YESTERDAY. I
DON'T KNOW WITH WHOM IS TO USE
SO MAYBE WE COULD WE COULD USE
A DATE RIGHT BY. DECEMBER BY.
JANUARY FEBRUARY WHAT AS SOON.
WE CAN GET J. O. A TIMELINE OF
WHAT WE WILL BE LOOKING AT- BUT
I WOULD NEED TO WORK WITH MY
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATIVE
GROUNDS- PERSONNEL AND WE CAN
GET YOU A TIMELINE THAT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL WHEN DO YOU THINK
YOU COULD. PROVIDE A TIME WENT
BY. OUR HOW WAS A WEEK A WEEK
SOUNDS WONDERFUL I WOULD I
WOULD THAT WOULD BE PERFECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FROM WHAT
ONE THING OF NOTE IS WE KNOW
THAT SOME OF THE NONPROFIT THEY
CAN DO PROGRAMMING THROUGH MAIL
OR A DIFFERENT TACK
CORRESPONDENCE IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT. YOUR DEPARTMENT
IS A POTATO IT WOULD WOULD BE
WILLING TO IMPLEMENT. YES WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR- OTHER WAYS-
CURRENTLY WE ARE LOOKING AT
WORKING WITH SOME OF OUR-
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND SOME OF OUR VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS ON EXPANDING SOME
INCEL TYPE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES- AND
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT CURRENTLY
RIGHT NOW GREAT THANK YOU WHAT
WHAT'S WHAT'S YOUR WHAT'S
HINDERING THAT BECAUSE- WHAT WE
HEAR FROM THE OUTSIDE IS THERE.
THESE GROUPS ARE READY TO GO
THEY'RE THEY'RE READY TO ROLL.
SO THIS IN YOUR OPINION WOULD
BE WHAT'S WHAT'S STOPPING IT IS
IT IS IT A BUDGET ISSUE IS
THAT. TO ISSUE WAS WITH THE
ISSUE. I DON'T SEE IT AS A
BUDGET ISSUE I DO KNOW THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE REACHING
OUT TO OUR GREAT RECIPIENTS TO
SCHEDULE MEETINGS TO GO OVER.
THERE PROGRAMS AND- WHAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SOLICIT OR SUBMIT
TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND WITHOUT
OUR INSTITUTIONS AND I KNOW
THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKING PLACE
IN THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS THAT'S
CORRECT AND WE JUST WANT TO
REITERATE OUR OUR SUPPORT. ON
THIS ALL I WILL I WILL READ ANY
OF MY PERSONAL SUPPORT WORKER
MEET ANYBODY ELSE POOR BUT
THAT'S MY- THE- BOTH PROGRAMS
MICE TO. IN THIS BY DURING THIS
VERY CHALLENGING TIME WHEN
PEOPLE CAN'T SEE FAMILIES AND-
HAVE VERY LITTLE INTERACTION
WITH. THE OUTSIDE WORLD- I JUST
URGE YOU TO. SORT OF MOVE MOVE
THAT ALONG WITH ALL DUE SPEED
OKAY I THINK I THINK THAT THOSE
ALL NIGHT QUESTIONS I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE PRITCHETT
PRESSURE YOUR WORK THANK YOU IT
WILL BE AWAITING YOUR RESPONSE
IN A WEEK. I'M WE ARE NOW GOING
TO. PUBLIC ON THAT WE HAVE SOME
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SOME OF THE
VERY STATION FOR START YES.
WHAT UP WE HAVE SOMEBODY IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO SO LET'S START
THERE WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU A
MINUTE AND A HALF. YOU CAN
START. ANYTIME SOON. ACTING I
SHOULD SAY MUCH I YOU AND YOU
SEEM LIKE A MAN WITH PRACTICAL.
AND I'M A- CLARITY SO I I'M
ABOUT. I BEFORE AND I WAS HAVE
A DIFFICULT TIME CERVANTES MUCH
FOR MY ME TO SPEAK AT THE REST
OF HIM OUT SOON. I MORRELL VERY
MUCH. I'M SORRY BUDDY I DO WANT
A WANNA SAY THE I KNOW THE- ON
I FEEL LIKE OUR- IS. THESE ON
IS. AS ALL OF US. I KNOW IT'S
COMPLICATED FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT'S FOR DARN SURE. AND I CAN
CERTAINLY ADMIRE THAT. AND I
THINK THAT ONE THING WE ALL
HAVE IN COMMON IS THAT WE ALL
OF OUR FAMILIES WELL OF OUR
FAMILIES WHILE THE CHILDREN.
AND PEOPLE WITH ME I LIKE TO
OFFICIALS LEADERS. LEADERS WHO
HAVE FIRE IN THEIR HEARTS AND-
AND- THOSE WHO HAVE PARENTS WHO
HAVE. A THIRTY IN THIS ROOM.
AND EVEN PEOPLE YOU KNOW
PROTECT MY PRISONS I THINK THAT
PEOPLE IN PRISONS HAVE FAMILIES
TOO AND WE ALL HAVE CHILDREN.
AND CHILDREN OF THE MAGIC IN
THE BEATING A LOT OF OUR LIVES.
AND I'M JUST A SIMPLE FORM AND
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ANYBODY
ELSE DOESN'T KNOW BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO ME
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT SOME
OF THE DIFFICULTIES THAT ARE
GOING ON- I KNOW PERSONALLY FOR
ME IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT FOR ME
BECAUSE- SOME OF THE
DIFFICULTIES GOING ON A TOWN
HAVE BEEN CAUSED BY. BASICALLY
PUTTING ON HERE NOW TECHNOLOGY
AND IS AFFECTING ME IN A VERY
SERIOUS WAY AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY BECAUSE I'M
NOBODY SPECIAL AT ALL. AND YOU
KNOW I'VE BEEN TORTURED. FOR
ELEVEN STRAIGHT TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN SIX MINISTRY TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN FIVE MONTHS YOU KNOW
TORMENT- PHYSICALLY AND-
PSYCHOLOGICALLY. AND I JUST
THINK IT'S SO INCREDIBLY UNFAIR
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON I'M NOT MET ANYBODY I DON'T
BLAME ANYBODY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT HAVE COMPASSION FOR
H. AND R. SANTA FE IS SO MUCH I
CAN LEARN FROM OTHER PEOPLE AND
TO SO MANY THINGS I ADMIRE.
ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE. AND YOU
KNOW IT IS REALLY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE OF ALSO
BROKEN MY APARTMENT PUT I THINK
SENTENCES ON THE FLOOR. AND USE
MY COMPUTER. FOR SOME KIND OF
TOPICAL DRUG ON MY. DOORKNOB
BECAUSE- RIGHT. PLEASE THANK
YOU. PEOPLE THROUGH WE'LL-
MOVING FROM. WINNING IDEA IN.
AND IT'S JUST BEEN SO.
INCREDIBLY BASED. TO MY BY.
THEY BY. EVERYTHING ON. IN YOU
KNOW A PRIVATE. EVERYTHING ON
SOME. TO SAY. THERE'S BEEN
Sí
HERE. THE HEART OF. IS WORK
HARD MY- TO TRY TO. WORK.
FAMILIES KNOW. FEED YOU KNOW
THOSE. FORTUNATE TO UNDERSTAND.
FAN IN. SOME AS I DO. SINGLE
DAY. THANK YOU. IF YOU COME ON
THE WAY I KNOW. TO THANK YOU
FOR. LAST PRETTY SHALLOW. THANK
YOU. SO I WHEN I THINK. CAN YOU
PLEASE. CONTACTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OR THE ATTORNEY.
ATTORNEY IN PRAGUE. THESE
PEOPLE. THANK YOU. I'M WE CAN
GO TO PUBLIC COME AT THE VERY.
THE VERY SO SUBTLE IFISA. THANK
YOU GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS IVANA- LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN ON
THE WHICH NONE OF MY FAMILY YOU
CALL AND I'M WHO REFER. FAMILY
A LARGE AFFECTED BY THE CLOSING
OF VISITS IN THE US CDCR
INSTITUTIONS CHILDREN'S AND
TEENS WANT TO BE ABLE TO TOUCH
AND HUG THEIR PARENTS AND
INCARCERATED LOVED ONES
RELATIONSHIPS ARE SUFFERING
THERE ARE HURTING IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER. NOT SEPARATING THEM
MENTAL HEALTH IS THAT ARISE IT
IS A BIGGER ISSUE HERE IT IS
AFFECTING LOVED ONES INSIDE AND
FAMILIES OUTSIDE. WE CANNOT
PUNISH THE FAMILIES OF
INCARCERATED LOVED ONES AND THE
CHILDREN FOR CDCR STAFF
NEGLIGENCE ON TAKING AND
FOLLOWING SAFETY. COLBERT
PRECAUTIONS TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF COALBED TO THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION. IT IS
OBVIOUS BY THE HERE TODAY. DODD
STAFF. FOUNDED AN OPTION TO
FOLLOW COALBED REGULATIONS AND
HAVE SPREAD ON A HAVE BEEN THE
ONES TO SPREAD THE COLD WITH
INSIDE OF INSTITUTIONS FAMILIES
ARE USED TO ABIDING BY COLBERT
SAFETY PROTOCOLS IT IS IT HAS
BECOME A PART OF OUR DAILY
LIVES WE FOLLOW CALVIN SAFETY
REGULATIONS AT SCHOOL A CHURCH
AT RESTAURANTS WORK. COURT
HOUSE ANY BEEN AROUND DOGS
TENDED FAMILIES WHY WOULD IT.
NOT OF. WHAT WE NOT FOLLOW ALL
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS GOING INTO
C. B. C. R. TO SEE OUR LOVED
ONES INSIDE. OUR O. IT IS THANK
YOU THAT C. B. C. HUSBAND ONE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SPREADING THE
COLBY TO INCARCERATED
POPULATION BUT IT IS OUR LOVE.
ONES WHO ARE BEING PUNISHED FOR
IT. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE. CVS ARE MA'AM THANK
YOU. YOU CAN GO AHEAD PLEASE. I
SEE SOMEBODY I THINK IN LOS
ANGELES IF YOU COULD GO AHEAD.
YOU HAVE TO START TALKING.
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS TIME I JUST WANT TO EXTEND
MY GRATITUDE FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DELORES GUNS ALICE I AM
WITH THE YOUNG ONES FREEDOM
CENTER AND I AM ALSO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AND HAVE A
FORMALLY INCARCERATED LOVED ONE
WELL I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT IT WAS A VERY
REST TIME FRAME AND SO MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS. ARE NOT EVEN
ABLE TO LISTEN IN TODAY OR SHOW
UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
KNOW THAT THEY WOULD BE HERE IF
POSSIBLE. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
MAKE SYSTEMS SOME SUGGESTIONS
TO BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT ASSEMBLY
IS ANY PROCEDURES- WE ALL KNOW
JUST. EVERYBODY'S REALIZING
JUST HOW ISOLATED ALONE WE ARE
ALL FEELING THERE'S MANY FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT HAVE SPENT DECADES
OF HOLIDAYS. VISITING THE
PRISON SO NOW YOU HAVE THEM
INSIDE THE PRISON BETTER
FEELING ISOLATED AND ISOLATED
AND ALONE DURING THE HOLIDAYS.
BUT ALSO THE SEVERE SEPARATION
OF FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE OUT
HERE NOW IT WHERE THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN SITTING IN PRISON
VISITING ROOM WITH THEIR LOVE
ONE. AND IF WE COULD START TO
JUST START LIKE A PILOT PROGRAM
WITH THE FAMILY VISITING IF
THEY GET A CALL THE TEST BEFORE
THEY GO TO THE FAMILY VISIT.
AND THEN THE INDIVIDUAL THAT'S
GETTING THE VISIT GOING TO A
FOURTEEN DAY TYPE QUARANTINE
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS THAT WE
CAN BEGIN TO SUGGEST TO START
TO IMPLEMENT PILOT PROGRAM
VISITING. TO START TO IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMMING AND I THINK THE
PART OF THE PROBLEM HERE IS
THAT AS I'M LISTENING TO
EVERYBODY. EVEN IF EVERYBODY
WAS GOING ON AND ON ABOUT THE
MASS AND I THINK IT'S ASSEMBLY
COOPER EVEN MENTIONED AT ONE
POINT WHERE LIKE A DOG CHASING
A TALE. AND I FEEL THAT THAT'S
CONSTANTLY GOING TO BE THE WAY
THAT IT IS BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS
TRYING TO RUN THESE CORRECTION
FACILITIES WITHOUT EVER HAVING
ACTUALLY LIVED IN THEM. SO
WHILE WE BLAME EVERYTHING ON
THE HOUSING STAFF AND NOW
CAUSING MORE FRUSTRATION WITH
THE HOUSING DEFICIT WE SUGGEST
YOU WRITE THEM UP. RIGHT NOW WE
TRY TO HAVE A HEARING A LAST
WEEK AND- ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSING STAFF IS HAVING TO GO
THROUGH THEM AND- PRISON. ALL
THE CLEANING SUPPLIES. AWAY YES
EIGHT TAKING ALL THE WAY CLEAN
SUPPLIES AWAY IN. CENTRAL CAL.
WILL FOR. RIGHT NOW. SO THAT
THEY CAN BEGIN TO LOG WHEN THEY
CHECK OUT THEIR CLEANING
SUPPLIES. SO THEY'RE TAKING OUT
THEIR CLEANING BOTTLES IF WE
COULD JUST AT. START TO WORK
AROUND SOME REAL SOLUTIONS WITH
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY. ARE
LIVING IN THESE SITUATIONS AND
THAT HAVE LIVED IN THEM THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
SUGGESTION YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO
EMAIL US THAT'S THEM IN THE
AGENDA THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE IT. NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. YOU CAN GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ASHLEY THANK YOU FOR
HEARING MY COMMENT TODAY I MEAN
AN AUDITORIUM IN OAKLAND AND
THERE AREN'T VERY MANY PEOPLE
HERE BUT THE WORDS I SAY
REPRESENT MORE THAN ME I
REPRESENT MY FRIENDS INSIDE
PRISON AND MY FRIENDS OUTSIDE
WHO HAVE LOVED ONES INSIDE FOR
YEARS WE'VE BEEN COMING
TOGETHER AGAINST THE DISMAL
CONDITIONS ABUSIVE PRISON
GUARDS NEGLIGENT MEDICAL CARE
FACILITIES AND OVERALL
CRUMBLING PRISONS ALL UPON
WHICH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS CLAIMS TO HAVE
RESPONDED TO A GLOBAL VIRUS
PANDEMIC TO. FIRST OFF I WANT I
WANT TO SAY I'VE BEEN SITTING
IN THIS EMPTY AUDITORIUM AND MY
HEART GOES OUT TO EVERY FAMILY
MEMBER OF A PERSON IN PRISON
WHAT TO WATCH THIS LIVE STREAM
OF FALSE OF LIFE AND
OBFUSCATION AND FALSEHOODS BY
CDC I WANT TO SAY THAT YOU
CAN'T TRUST ANY DATA THEY HAVE
BECAUSE EVERY TIME THERE'S SOME
SORT OF WALK THROUGH THE PEOPLE
IN PRISON THINK THAT THEY ARE
THREATENED AND TO PUT THEIR
MOUTHS ON BY THE GUARDS AND
THEY SAY THEY THEY HAVE TO
FOLLOW MY WITH BEHAVIOR- OR
SUFFER PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE OF
CONSEQUENCES. EVERY PRISON IS
RUN LIKE A LITTLE KINGDOM THE
OVERSIGHT THAT SECRETARY
ALLYSON CLARKE HEALTH OF THINK
THEY HAD DOES NOT EXIST THERE
IS NO PLAN THEY ARE LIKE
CHICKENS RUNNING WITH HER HEAD
CUT OFF INSIDE THIS PRESENTS
BUT THEY HAVE THEIR LIVES OF
REAL PEOPLE IN THEIR HANDS SO
MANY TO NO REAL PLAN LIKE WHY
HAVEN'T PEOPLE WITH HIGH RISK
MEDICAL CONDITIONS BEING
RELEASED WHY ARE PEOPLE BEING
DENIED PAROLE DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WHY IS ALISON LYING
ABOUT PROGRAMMING TAKING PLACE
INSIDE THE PRISON WHEN IT'S
NOT. WHY ARE THEIR INNOCENT
PEOPLE WITHIN CITY FEASIBLE THE
CAGES THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO KNOW
HOW TO DEAL WITH THIS PANDEMIC
LIKE YOU'VE JUST HEARD THE
PEOPLE IN PRISON AND THEIR
FAMILIES THEY KNOW WHAT SAFE
THEY KNOW HOW TO KEEP YOURSELF
CLEAN AND THEY THEY ALREADY DO
IT MY FRIEND JAY OUTSIDE OFF IS
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SURVIVED DESPITE CDC'S ODDS HE
WAS AN EIGHTY A WORKER PUSHING
PEOPLE IN THEIR WHEELCHAIR THAN
HELPING PEOPLE EVEN WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE TO. THE RESCUE SMALL
ANIMALS AND HEALTH- WHO'VE BEEN
INJURED ON THE ARTS AND HE'S
BEEN IN PRISON AS. LONG AS I'VE
BEEN ALIVE. ON MY- JAY WITH. IN
FOR. WITH STAGE THREE LUNG.
THAT HAS SINCE GONE TERMINAL
HE'S AWAITING TREATMENT HE'S
GETTING THE RUN AROUND FROM
MEDICAL STAFF. ABOUT HIS CHEMO
TREATMENT. IF HE GETS COBIT HE
WILL MEET HIS END. HE WASHES
HIS HANDS HE DOES EVERYTHING HE
CAN TO KEEP THINGS SANITIZED.
BUT THE PRISON ISN'T
DISTRIBUTING CLEANING SUPPLIES.
WITH FEW FAMILY MEMBERS HE
CAN'T AFFORD THE- CLEANING
SUPPLIES FROM STORE. PLEASE BUT
WHAT CAN YOU DO HE APPLIED FOR
CLEMENCY PERHAPS THERE IS A
THERE WILL BE COMPASSIONATE
RELEASED BUT WHERE DOES THAT
LEAVE THE UNDER OTHER HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE INSIDE.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WITH PRE EXISTING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS THAT NEED TO BE
RELEASED NOW. IF YOU COOPER
VERY MEDICAL RAMPANT MET
MCGRATH ON THE COLLECT WITHIN
THEIR SYSTEM. AND PEOPLE NEED
TO BE RELEASED THE ONLY
SOLUTION IS MASS RELEASES NOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GO AHEAD
FROM OUR. DAN I AM A BOARD
MEMBER FOR WE ARE THEIR VOICES
AND VOICES FOR LIKE YOU KNOW WE
ARE HERE I'M HERE TODAY MY
COMMENTS ARE GOING TO SURROUND
MORE AROUND VISITING- THE
DAMAGE OF CALL THE NINETEEN AND
HOW IT HOW IT IS IMPOSED. ON
OUR CHILDREN THIS IS WHAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT AND DAMAGE
IT IS COST TO OUR CHILDREN THUS
FAR THEM NOT HAVING VISIT TO
NOT HAVING PHYSICAL CONTACT ONE
OTHER OF PRISONS IN FIT FEDERAL
PRISONS IN STATE PRISONS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
HAVE OPENED SUCH AS FLORIDA AND
NEW YORK WHO HAS BEEN. VERY
IMPACTED BY COLEMAN NINETEEN
BUT THEY ARE NOW OPEN THE
DAMAGE IT IS CAUSING THE MENTAL
HEALTH THAT IS CAUSING ON OUR
LOVED ONES INSIDE OF THESE
PRISONS NOT HAVING A CONTACT
WITH THEIR CHILDREN WITH THEIR
LOVED ONES IS VERY DETRIMENTAL
TO THEM ON AUGUST THIRTY FIRST
DURING ONE OF OUR PROTEST IS
YOU ARE THEIR VOICES OF PROTEST
AT ALL THIRTY FIVE STATE
PRISONS. I ON AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST FIVE- INCARCERATED LOVED
ONES INSIDE OF CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON CORCORAN HAVE ATTEMPTED
TO COMMIT SUICIDE MENTAL HEALTH
IS A BIG ISSUE WITH VISITED
VISITING NOT HAPPENING THIS IS
VERY DETRIMENTAL TO THEM AND
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE I
WANT TO KNOW WHY CAFFEINE
ALISON HIS NOT BEEN ABLE TO.
COME UP WITH THE SOLUTION. WHAT
OTHER STATES WE'VE BEEN MORE
IMPACTED BY NINE. ALL WERE AND
CAL HAVE TO PUT A PARTY HAVE
MANAGE TO SOCIAL DISTANCE HAVE
MANAGED TO OPEN VISITS AND
STILL KEEP SOCIAL DISTANCE. AND
ALREADY SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
KATHY ALISON NOT A- THAT HAS
NOT. REALLY ATTEMPTED TO DO
THAT THE DAMAGE IS CAUSING TO
CHILDREN TODAY. IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT I WANT I WANT SHE
EXPRESSED TO CAPPING ALISON THE
DAMAGE YOU ARE DOING. HOW YOU
ARE HURTING HIS FAMILY TELL YOU
ARE TEARING FAMILIES DOWN. HI
YOU ARE DESTROYING MARRIAGES
BECAUSE YOU REFUSE TO. OPEN
WHEN YOU CAN'T OPEN ONLY WHAT
ELEVEN PRISONS OUT OF THE
THIRTY FIVE STATE PRISONS THAT
ARE OPEN. HAVE ZERO CASES
DONOVAN STATE PRISON IS OUT FOR
CASES THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE
PANDEMIC AND THEY ARE STILL NOT
ALLOWED TO BE OPEN. THIS IS
DISGUSTING AND IT NEEDS TO
CHANGE IN CABIN ALISON WE ARE
DEMANDING THAT YOU DO SOMETHING
NOW. THANK YOU. ANYBODY IN
OAKLAND OR LA FLUFFED. WE DO
THANK THE PUBLIC FOR ATTENDING
AGAIN WHEN I STARTED THE
HEARING THERE IS THE EMAIL THAT
YOU CAN EMAIL THE COMMITTEE FOR
US IF YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S NOT ALWAYS
EASY TO GET TO A LOCATION AND
TO DO THIS- YOU CAN EMAIL
BUDGET SUB ISSUE BE SIX THE
NUMBER SIX AT ASM. DOT C. A.
DOT GOV OR FEEL FREE TO CALL US
AT. 916-319-2099 WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PUBLIC EVERYBODY
WHO CAME OUT TO SPEAK AND WE DO
URGE. ALL OF YOU TO ENCOURAGE
YOUR FRIENDS OR FAMILY MEMBERS
TERM EMAIL US ABOUT THE YOUR
OPINIONS ESPECIALLY WHEN
VISITATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REALLY APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
FOR STICK AROUND ARE ADJOURNED.